is mute your microphones
and those people in the room here with
me please stand and join representative
Thomas in our Pledge of Allegiance
I I pledge allegiance of the United
States
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice
good morning everyone I'm representative
Michael Bose of Epping
as chair of the house science technology
and energy committee
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-4
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the science technology and
energy committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held at any time
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporary
temporaneously listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call
271-3600
or email
HCS at ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
I want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us today
Jennifer fore committee researcher for
STNA
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking parole
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting
that's required under the right to know
law I call on the acting clerk Kroy
murder you call the road
thank you
representative Thomas here
representative Harrington
here
representative daughter here
representative president
representative home alone here
representative freshly here
representative bernati here
representative cambrose here
representative
person
representative White
here
representative sausage
representative Jackie Kelly Pitts
representing your muted yeah
calipits here representative Ben here
representative man here
representative oxenham
president no one else in the room
Representative Vincent I'm here and no
one else is in the room
representative McGee
I'm here and I'm alone
representative Nick Williams
I'm here with my daughter Victoria
represented
Richardson
I'm here and I'm alone
representative
I'm here and alone
passion
here and alone
we have we have 20 members one yeah
the clarification this is Mike
Harrington my wife is in the room with
me
sausage it's right there on the bottom
right corner so we have everybody
but he hasn't responding yeah
Representatives yes I'm here
with that call of the role we have 21
out of 21 members
present well I announced my presence at
the very beginning of the meeting so I
trust that that will be sufficient to
indicate my presence
we have a series of six public hearings
this morning I will be meeting the first
public Hearing in just a few minutes but
before I do that
I wanted to pass along a few reminders
to everyone
for everyone who is here in the
Legislative Office Building
the state uh policy legislative policy
about mask wearing is that while you are
seated in your seat
it is permissible for you to remove your
mask
but if you leave your seat for any
reason you must affix your mask
I will be observing your behavior in
this regard
and I will report to the
speaker
anyone who violates this policy
so please remember to
put your mask on when you leave your
seat
it's common courtesy
to
all our fellow legislators and to the
members of the House staff who are in
the building
secondly because of the nature of this
hybrid meeting where some of us are here
and some of us are on Zoom
we need the people in the room here to
speak loudly and clearly
when you're recognized to speak so that
the people watching at home on Zoom can
hear you
we don't have individual microphones for
every member so we have some
devices around the room to pick up sound
but they might not pick up
any spoken words unless those words are
articulated loudly and clearly
so keep that in mind when you raise your
hand to ask a question
[Music]
we will in addition
to be observing the guidelines that we
talked about at our first orientation
meeting
we've asked everyone who plans to
testify this morning to submit written
testimony on their bills
we are going to allocate time for
speaking at the public hearing
based on the people who have registered
a desire to testify
so if we have in an hour's time 50
people who want to testify then each
person is going to get
very little time to testify
if we have only two people signed up to
testify
as is apparently the case on HB 80 the
first bill we will hear this morning
then time time limits will be
set aside
for the time being since they won't be
necessary to allow us to conduct the
business
of the public hearing on hpe
we do ask that when you testify that you
make
the points you want to make
highlight your most important points and
do not repeat points that have been made
by other
presenters
Depending on time limits we will
restrict the questions by members to two
questions
per member for a presenter
before I allow
a member to ask another question in
excess of the two
uh I will make sure that all other
members have asked any questions that
they want to ask
we also remind members not to make
statements
uh
that
are not germane
to the question you're about to ask
and I also remember remind members that
we're not here to engage in a debate
with the people who are presenting we
are here to hear their testimony
and gather information from those
individuals
foreign and with those guidelines in
mind
even though I
do not have a gavel yet
I will
knock on the table to indicate that
we're opening the public hearing on HB
80.
and we would like to recognize first
the prime sponsor of the legislation
representative Mann to introduce the
bill
thank you Mr chairman
thank you Mr chairman this bill is ready
rededicates money in the Energy
Efficiency fund
taking away its current use in reducing
energy bills a very small amount and
instead using it to fund Energy
Efficiency
and then process of justifying this bill
I will do uh spend some time talking
about Energy Efficiency itself and about
the effects of an Energy Efficiency
program run by the state
the Energy Efficiency fund gets its
money from New Hampshire's participation
in the regional greenhouse gas
initiative or Reggie
it's a multi-state pact that turns CO2
emissions into money
uh that is the that the utility either
reduce CO2 emissions or pay some money
into a kitty that we can use for Energy
Efficiency or any uh of a number of um
of measures
since 2012 in New Hampshire most of the
kitties been be used for what's called
direct bill assistance you're basically
giving back about
um 90 cents a month per household on
average
New England uh the New Hampshire
Electric Cooperative showed me a 68
cents a month figure for their customers
per month this is practically useless
assistance that can be outdone Anyway by
just handing out a couple of LED bulbs
and so
um the the bill wants to rededicate that
money to Energy Efficiency which is much
more useful
um the history of the rebate however
um was not even uh a decision by any
legislatures it was a maneuver to get a
very ugly lobbyist out of the way
essentially uh it was a it was a
quote-unquote compromise either we were
going to get out of Reggie all together
or we were going to give some money back
to Great payers and and not spend it on
Energy Efficiency so this has a
historical uh uh source and it is not in
New Hampshire's interest anymore now
that we've gotten rid of that lobbyist
this goes back to 2012.
um Energy Efficiency has a wide range of
meanings in industry it's very
complicated you have opportunities in
production processes Transportation
materials distribution and so on uh for
residential buildings it's an awful lot
simpler uh basically it's reducing heat
loss and worrying about moisture because
you know ice dams if you do the
insulation in the Attic raw things like
that
the state buys about 135 million gallons
of heating oil per year it goes to the
oil industry it goes out of the state
and out of the state economy that's
money people are not spending it's
monies people are not receiving
uh because people are not spending it
it is uh depressing our economy and our
wealth
so I think it's very important while we
have this opportunity with the
engineering Energy Efficiency
a program to uh available to uh to save
a lot of money and improve our wealth
and economy it's um
so I'm going to show a little bit of a
visual if you don't mind
um
and the um the idea is to explain why an
energy or how an Energy Efficiency
program
accumulates a lot of money so hang on a
second
[Music]
sorry to take my time on this but um it
was right here a minute ago
uh
oh yes hang on
representative man I must warn you that
well I will allow this this morning
because we don't have many people signed
up to speak on this bill I cannot
guarantee that we can allow this to
happen in future
public hearings
right I understand
uh hang on a second here
um
I'm going to share the screen now
[Music]
representative Mann would you suspend
for a moment yes Jen do you know if uh
representative Mann is authorized to
share his screen his screen
okay just verifying thank you do you see
my screen now
a picture of people doing work on a
house
no sir no you have to use share screen
I'm sorry we have to use share screen on
your bottom
toolbar yep for us to see yours
representative man I suggest that you
include this material in your written
testimony yes it will be and forego the
use of sharing screen during this
presentation okay well what happens is
this let me just do a quick narration
foreign
Energy Efficiency programs every year
for 10 years the first year
um you spend you know doing a work on a
number of houses in the second year you
do another a bunch of work on another
set of houses well that while this
um second year is
implementations being done the work you
did the previous year is saving money
to Energy Efficiency and that money is
saved year after year after year after
year so the money that the work you do
in the third year adds a little more
fourth year and so on
um the way the figure goes and you'll
see it in the uh in the visual and you
can run through the um the
slides that I send to you
um
the total amount of wealth that saved
accelerates it doesn't grow in a steady
steady amount the amount of work that's
been done actually goes up linearly but
the total amount of the effect the
Savings in the economy go up uh as a
perver ability as an x squared function
and that's really important uh
Massachusetts has been done doing this
for over
uh 25 years if they had been doing it
for 25 years the number of uh if you
take the years times savings done in New
Hampshire over 25 years is 325.
that's 25 times 26
uh
divided by two
squared so
um
when we're sacrificing Energy Efficiency
in order to give small amounts of money
back to ratepayers we are foregoing an
enormous
potential growth in our wealth
a good analogy might be Dunkin Donuts
you know you can make a lot of donuts
but you can also build a lot of
data of Dunkin Donuts stores and each
one is a revenue stream
each Year's work on Energy Efficiency
creates a saving stream
so it has accelerating impact now we
either get that savings by doing Energy
Efficiency or we hand it over to the oil
companies
and so if we're going to insist on
giving small amounts of money to our
rate payers
uh and pretend that's doing them a favor
the fact is we're robbing them
so we need to pass this bill
and we need to pay attention to Energy
Efficiency instead of giving away small
change thank you
thank you representative man do we have
any questions for representative Mann
from the members here in the room
representative bresney thank you
chairman for recognizing me just a
question uh thank you Mr Mann for your
testimony my question is you mentioned
in the beginning that there were
lobbyists who spoke on behalf of the
ratepayers to create the rebate can you
mention who the lobbyists were
uh they weren't
um
that's not exactly what happened the
lobbyist was Corey Lewandowski and this
was in 2012 in a bill 1490 HP 1490.
um
um let's see um
there's a piece of your question I
forgot let me think um
could you repeat your question again I
was just asking what uh who were the
lobbyists who lobbied on behalf of the
ratepayers to create the rebate yeah he
was lobbying on behalf of getting rid of
Reggie altogether I suspect it might
have been part of an effort
um by Americans for Prosperity which who
he's was representing to dismantle
Reggie because they understood the the
what I've described recently uh they
understood the impact on their revenue
of something like uh uh the Reggie pact
a whole bunch of States doing
uh things that were going to reduce
energy consumption
and oil consumption
so that was his purpose and I guess he
was acting a little bit rough and
a couple of very slick legislators um
finagle them into this
hilarious
rebate compromise quote quote unquote
she was unable to uh okay representative
thank you we appreciate the answer to
the question and we've not seen him
since
thank you
next uh question comes from
representative Kelly Pitts
don't forget to unmute yourself
we cannot hear you representative
representative Kelly Pitts and I'm a
co-sponsor on the bill but I'm not
presenting
though I believe I can ask a question is
that correct
yes you're recognized to ask a question
representative Mann do you
um agree that giving a rebate of
roughly a dollar a month and not having
an insulated house
wastes more energy and that dollar along
with many more would go out the window
yes that's I would definitely agree that
uh if you if that dollar doesn't help if
you're not getting the Energy Efficiency
done uh I just looked at a one and a
half kilowatt
space heater and it would cost forty
dollars a month to burn for um from uh
Sunset to bedtime
during a month
just an enormous difference in cost
and that people that are in lousy
housing are often using space heaters to
try to competency
thank you representative man any
follow-up representative Kelly Pitts no
follow-up thank you
so chair now recognizes representative
Pimentel for a question
thank you Mr chairman
uh representative man uh you mentioned
that
uh the average bill is uh paying roughly
90 cents a month
how much is being diverted
um
is currently being diverted from the
Energy Efficiency programs Statewide
we add up all those 90 census
yeah you're asking me to think
foreign
well it's 450 000.
um households and oh yes sorry yeah the
amount actually is five million dollars
according to the um the officials that
um
watch Reggie
five million dollars a year
any follow-up representative pin mintel
thank you Mr chairman yes a follow-up
um
could you give us an idea of what kinds
of programs could be run
that are currently not being run right
now on five million dollars a year
thank you
um yes I would um
of course we have eers coming online but
generally
you would spend that money doing as much
Energy Efficiency as you could you'd
have publicity you'd have um supervision
you'd have quality control and so on
um but um my view is
um low-income house households can't
really take stand to wait for maybe
eight or ten years before it's their
turn to have Energy Efficiency done in
their house so a good plan would be to
um develop and then uh invent basically
develop a program that would do some
minimal minimally
costly but
most cost-effective things for houses
for low-income housing so that at least
they are somewhat improved
while they're waiting for their turn now
the bill I believe dedicates and I was
just I did not make these original
suggestions I was just modifying an
existing or prior bill from the Senate I
believe there's a significant dedication
to low income so that they you would
prioritize those
since they can't afford to wait whereas
the other families like mine can easily
wait
thank you representative Mann
the chair now recognizes representative
samsich for a question
yes thank you Mr chairman
um
uh Mr Man
I my understanding is that Energy
Efficiency contributes significantly in
reducing the overall demand for energy
uh for the whole state
so that is it is it not accurate to say
that by reducing the demand through
Energy Efficiency or other measures uh
every every rate every rate payer every
utility payer will get a benefit out of
that not just the person installing
Energy Efficiency yes that's true that's
true at the uh the economy gets better
right away
um even if you have to wait four or five
years before your house is done the
economy is improving
um simply because there's more money
remaining in the state instead of flying
out
thank you is there a follow-up
representative samsich yes thank you
chairman there is uh also uh it is it
not true that Energy Efficiency is the
cheapest way of reducing your energy
bill
and it also reduces uh pollution and
greenhouse gas emissions
yes that's I would agree with that
absolutely
and I forgot to mention of course this
job's created
yeah thank you very much A lot of people
that work with their hands um
um and need jobs this is great work good
representative man the chair now
recognizes representative Thomas for our
question
well thank you Mr chairman okay
thank you there is a man to take my
question uh you mentioned the quantity
of somewhere between 60 to 90 cents per
month return to our
which would be a common residence
can you tell me what that is based on
how many kilowatt hours per month uh
usage
yes that's uh that's just taking 450
house thousand households that's the
Census Bureau tells us tells uh I found
somewhere tells us that that's the
number of households in this state and
divide 5 million dollars by 450 000 you
get about 11. eleven dollars a year or
about 90 cents a month
a follow-up representative Thomas uh I I
guess I need to restate the question
what what I meant was
is that figure based on
average household usage of say some say
600 kilowatts a month and say it's 650
kilowatt hours a month is it based on
that or or just like you said it's just
basically the overall money spent
overall by the number of house roles
it's not by looking at all the accounts
and what they're spending it's just
simply dividing
the number of amount of money that's
rebated
by the number of households that are in
the state
okay thank you representative man we
have two more people with their hands
raised sure at the conclusion of the
second question by the second person
we're going to move on to the next
presenter for time because because of
time constraints if there's time later
that'd be that'd be great okay so the
chair now recognizes uh representative
oxenham for a question
in the interest of time I'll pass
thank you representative oxenham that
you're now recognizes
representative partial for a question
yes my school district is struggling to
reduce operation cost
may I assume that this bill would help
reduce local property taxes by the
installation of such things as cost
efficient LED lighting
yes that would be a a you know the town
would have to push for it but clearly it
would it would help the rate payers
um I want to thank everybody for the
questions by the way I forgot to do that
thank you representative Mann
representative partial was there a
follow-up
no I just would speak that my local
constituents are already pushing for a
plan to install this lighting
thank you representative man for your
testimony on this bill we'll move on now
to our next presenter
and that would be
uh Michael Fitzgerald from the New
Hampshire Department of Employment
Security
Jen could you promote Mr Fitzgerald to a
panelist so that we can see him as he
makes his presentation
yeah
oh I misspoke it's not Department of
Employment Security it's Department of
Environmental Services thank you acronym
hell yeah okay thank you
Mr Fitzgerald are you there
good morning Mr chairman uh my computer
froze a moment when it was transferring
so uh are you able to hear me
we can hear you fine uh
can't see but we can hear you yes good
morning thank you very much Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
Michael Fitzgerald I am the assistant
director of the air Resources Division
in the Department of Environmental
Services
and uh our agency along with the puc is
responsible for implementing the Reggie
program in New Hampshire
um we our agency manages the uh the
auctions and the state's participation
in Reggie the puc is responsible for uh
the use of the revenues in accordance
with uh with current statute or as you
know maybe proposed under this
legislation I'm not sure if it's
possible but normally this bill has been
heard several times previously normally
we testify in conjunction with the uh
the puc and my staff Joe Fontaine who is
also on I'm not sure if they can be
promoted at the same time or not in
order to be able to answer questions uh
more efficiently for the committee that
might be helpful
um if it's if it's so possible I
appreciate that
um
so it would be Joe Fontaine and Karen
Crampton from the puc
I'll be doing the testimony but and I
believe I believe the puc also presented
some information to uh
to the uh committee
um a a chart that would help in
understanding the reallocation under
this legislation
um
so uh all right well I in any case I see
Joe
um I I don't I don't know if Karen is
available or not but um I'll proceed
again thank you very much
um the new the state yeah so okay
there's Karen
um
Joe and Karen you'll need to unmute if
there's questions also I understand
um
so thank you the uh the state uh began
its participation in Reggie back in the
early 2000s at the time that the
greenhouse gas initiative was created
um
and uh it's an initiative of 10 states
which uh regulates the emissions of
carbon dioxide from fossil fuel power
plants
uh plants are allocated a certain amount
of allowances or an allowance is equal
to one ton of emissions of CO2
and
um if they exceed the number of
allowances uh they have to purchase
additional allowances and they have to
surrender them uh during a certain time
frame and uh true up with their
emissions so those allowances are are
traded on a uh on like a stock market
platform and uh the allowances generate
Revenue which representative man alluded
to that Revenue
um uh varies with the cost of the
allowance
initially all of New Hampshire's
revenues were dedicated to Energy
Efficiency and as representative man
indicated back in 2012 there was a uh
there was a compromise when it was
proposed that New Hampshire
um
be required to leave Reggie and it was
changed so that
um
if an allowance sells for say five
dollars the way the current allocation
works is the first dollar of that
revenue for the state is uh put into
Energy Efficiency programs the remaining
four dollars are rebated by the puc two
rate payers in accordance with
um the ratio of commercial and
Industrial to
um residential rate payers and this bill
would uh would reallocate and again I'll
uh defer to Ms Crampton of the puc and
her her chart
um to uh to help you understand that
um I did provide written testimony and
um
uh one of the important things to
understand is that New Hampshire is in
Reggie because
New Hampshire's participation in Reggie
is better for rate payers than not
participating the cost of the the
allowances
for the fossil fuel plants that are
covered under this program those costs
are carried into their their cost of
doing business
and are ultimately charged to the rate
payer just like fuel
um if a utility buys coal or or oil or
whatever that cost is part of their cost
of doing business and that is included
in the
um uh in the costs that ultimately the
rate payer pays and so
um that cost
is is a fixed cost and and is paid no
matter what
um if we participate in Reggie we're
able to recoup some of that uh those
funds
um and uh then again those funds can be
allocated for
um the policy directive of the
legislature Des takes no position on
this legislation we do believe that
there are significant benefits and that
there's a significant body of
information that suggests that
investments in Energy Efficiency
are better for the ratepayer than than
rebates however we believe it's the
purview of the legislature to determine
um and that's that has always been the
question so our participation is
predicated on the fact that it's better
for us to be in the program and get
um get the revenues then what's done
with the revenues is uh uh is up to the
legislature and uh and and that is
directed in statute now and um this
legislation would would redirect some of
those funds as was described by
representative Mann
um I believe my testimony letter
indicated uh some of the studies that
have been done both here in New
Hampshire
legislative studies and some uh
um some studies that were done by
reputable analytical
consulting firms on behalf of uh
um the Reggie program and
um so I won't dwell on those I think
they show that there's significant
benefit to the reallocation another
thing that was mentioned
um uh was the fact that if these
revenues are dedicated to Municipal
purposes schools municipalities Etc
that they do provide a benefit not only
to the
um to the school or the municipality and
so on but also to the rate payer by
reducing costs for the for the rate
payer uh for the uh tax taxpayer um in
the in the municipalities if uh if a
school costs less to heat or less to
uses less electricity via lighting then
um that cost uh directly
lowers costs that that investment rather
directly lowers costs for the uh for the
rate payer uh and ultimately the
ultimately the taxpayer
um
and
um so uh we um we again take no position
um we're happy to uh uh try to answer
any questions on the way the Reggie
program works or this uh proposed
reallocation
um and with that I will uh I will
conclude my testimony and uh be prepared
to take questions along with Mr Fontaine
and Ms Crampton from the puc and I'm I
don't miss Crampton if she wanted to add
anything to what I've said I
be happy to
hear that as well
Ms Crampton did you want to add anything
uh to
Mr Fitzgerald's testimony if so please
unmute yourself
thank you good morning
committee this is Karen Crampton from
the Public Utilities Commission uh as Mr
Fitzgerald stated we provided the
graphics which attempts to illustrate
how Reggie currently allocates funding
and what the amendment the effects of
the amendment would have on that program
allocation and
um the puc takes no position on this
bill however I am here to answer any
questions that you may have on that
allocation so thank you very much
the chair recognizes representative
Thomas for a question
sure uh
police representative sausage
okay uh
let me ask our committee research here
pardon can't hear representative Thomas
we ask our committee researcher on my
screen
when I see a list of Representatives
with their hands up
how can I tell which one put their hand
up first
they are listed in the order in which
they were raised so I'm seeing
representative samsich Thomas
and so on
my screen it goes representative Thomas
representative samsich you know
do you have the the participant list
open represent
do I have what the participant list
I don't have it open right at the moment
no yeah if you open the participant list
it shows them in order whereas on your
screen it may be in a different order if
you're looking at the tiles
okay I did not know that thank you for
that
Clarity on
that so
okay chair recognizes representative
some search for a question
wasn't there a question from
representative Thomas that we didn't
hear and didn't get an answer
thank you for that uh question
representative oxen I'm representative
Thomas said and I'm sorry you didn't
hear it but he said that he thought that
represent representative samsich was
first
discussion about how to determine who's
so representative samsonshire recognized
for a question uh thank you Mr chairman
and thank you Mr Fitzgerald uh so I just
want to clarify what you just said
regarding uh whether our participation
in Reggie uh are not non-participation
would be a disadvantage so if I
understand what you said correctly and
please correct me if I'm wrong here
because that's why I want to know
um since we all buy from the same
wholesale energy Market all the
producers producing energy into the
wholesale Market have already factored
the cost of Reggie for all the other
States involved into their pricing
and so therefore when we buy energy from
them that's already factored in as part
of their pricing however if we're not
part of Reggie we don't get any benefits
from the auctions to compensate for that
additional cost is that correct
that is absolutely correct and although
this legislation does not
uh address the state's participation in
Reggie it presumes that we continue to
participate
um I I just pointed that out for
clarification
um uh as background information but yes
you are correct
representative samsich follow-up uh yes
thank you Mr chairman uh I I wanted to
just ask uh in light of the fact that
this money is being used currently uh uh
the amount we're getting the one dollar
out of the five
um how many projects that qualify to get
such
um Energy Efficiency measures what
percentage are we able to fund with that
amount uh and uh how much more would we
need to fund all the projects currently
uh in queue
um
I will attempt to address that a little
bit and then I'll deter them as Crampton
because they're the agency that uh runs
the program but I just want to point out
that the
um the first dollar uh of each allowance
sale goes into the Energy Efficiency
programs that are run by the puc
administered by the puc and run by the
utilities
um and those programs are by definition
cost effective
um it's my understanding that there is a
significant waiting list for those
programs uh I don't know I I could not
quote you specific numbers
um and uh
um that those those programs
um again are continually funded but the
the limitation is the current funding
um and with that I would defer to Ms
Crampton to if there's any other any
further information that would be
helpful
I recognized
be sure to raise your hand the thing you
explain so but I can try
here
yeah
you could move a little bit because
I will recognize uh
did you want to go to representative
Thomas first sir okay
um yes sir thank you chair for taking my
question yes sir thank you for uh
providing your testimony today one
question I I did have and if you could
just clarify does this bill change the
amount of money that's available to
residential customers in the New
Hampshire New Hampshire saves program
uh yes I would defer to Ms script into
uh perhaps go over that allocation
document but yes it does in fact
increase the uh amount of money going in
to the uh Energy Efficiency programs
uh Mr chair if you'd like I can add a
little bit to that
a little detail to Mr Fitzgerald's
response yes please respond
um based on the illustrative diagrams
that I provided uh the puc provided as
testimony
um assuming that the Reggie auction
revenue is approximately 17 million
dollars you can see by looking at the
left hand side of those charts that
under the current law
approximately 2.9 Million Dollars would
be used for funding Energy Efficiency
programs in the state
with this amendment that amount uh
increases to approximately 6.7 million
dollars so yes there is an increase of
funding and then the
the
boxes below
uh show you how that's allocated and
both bills or the current law and the
amendment both provide an allocation for
municipalities and schools and local
government for Energy Efficiency there's
an allocation set aside for low-income
Energy Efficiency and then the balance
goes to fund an all fuels program which
currently is administered by the puc as
a competitive bid
um and I can go through those breakdowns
but basically
um municipalities schools and local
governments would
get an increased allocation from 2
million up to 5 million
the low income goes from a minimum of 15
to a minimum of 35 percent
and then the balance is of course the
all fuels program
thank you Miss Crampton uh I'd like you
to stop there please yes we're down to
the last 10 minutes of this public
hearing so the future questioners will
be limited to one question each and the
chair recognizes representative Thomas
for a question thank you Mr chair I
thank you my question uh really quick
what other programs in the state or
federal
also contribute to the Energy Efficiency
fund besides Reggie
thank you for your question
representative Thomas the uh systems
benefit charge
um uh from the uh again a puc
administered program that charges is on
your uh on your bill those funds also uh
are allocated to a you know portion of
them are allocated to the uh Energy
Efficiency fund and and thus then into
the Energy Efficiency programs
thank you for that answer the chair
recognizes representative Pimentel for a
question
thank you Mr chairman
um
are there other states in Reggie that
are diverting their funds
uh to the ratepayers
are we the only one
um I I believe there are uh there are
other states that have a portion um I
believe ours is probably the uh
uh the lowest amount
um you know where when we're only
allocating one dollar out of the five or
or whatever the allowance price is
um and I believe that
um it was uh in my testimony letter that
more than 50 percent of the uh uh the
states uh the total funding from the
states does go to Energy Efficiency but
there are other funds diverted for other
uses in the states and I would also open
it up to Mr Fontaine if if he has any
um additional information that could
help with that response
Joe if you do you need to unmute
I could Mr Fitzgerald I could jump in
quickly I think um Reggie Inc uh
generates or or produces an annual
proceeds report that shows state by
state how every state uses their Reggie
proceeds and now I did see Joe's unmuted
I'm sorry Joe unmuted thank you
um yes that's what I was gonna say Karen
was the answers to a lot of your
questions uh may be found at the Reggie
Inc website www.rggi.org
and they have uh an annual report on
their
that shows how the money is spent by
each state
we could follow up and send to send to
the committee members a link to that
report
okay thank you for that response uh the
chair now recognizes representative
McGee for the
for a question
thank you Mr chairman
um Mike my question is around uh you
know I think what the committee is
grappling with here is whether this is a
good build for New Hampshire whether
it's worthy of our our votes to move it
forward and I wanted to ask the question
of the way I see Energy Efficiency is
that it lowers demand and therefore it
lowers costs and so it's kind of this
program is sort of a force multiplier
for helping us to lower those energy
costs that come from the transmission
piece that we have about 9.5 percent of
as far as you know our regional
um partnership goes so please ask a
question representative yeah so what I'm
asking is is that a correct assumption
that that
um passing this bill would create uh
would continue that Force multiplier so
that we can lower demand
assumption
yes that's correct
um and again investments in Energy
Efficiency lower overall demand
um and in uh in addition there's another
factor that um more recently has come to
be better understood is that when demand
is lowered the the cost of the
transmission system in New England is
apportioned among all the New England
states based on their demand so when
States lower their demand
um they also lower their percentage of
the required uh you know if they're
going to invest if ISO is going to
invest 10 million over the next 10 years
in in uh transmission say or or 100
million whatever
um that that cost
uh it can be reduced by reducing our
portion of the demand in other words if
we pay if we're 9.5 percent of the iso
load
um we would pay one cost if we're 10 we
would pay
another half percent higher
portion of that cost and so by lowering
demand we not only lower
um the cost to the direct rate payer
that that
um to the direct uh uh entity that
lowers their uh invest the money and
lowers their cost but uh then that
lowers demand to all rate payers and
um that also translates into reduced
demand to for for the entire uh uh
system and reduce costs
that's the point in your testimony I was
trying to get to okay I'm gonna have to
cut you off there it is now three
minutes before ten
Mr Fitzgerald we thank you uh and Miss
Crampton and Mr Fontaine for your
testimony here this morning we have one
more person who would like to speak this
morning so the chair recognizes now Mr
Joseph quasnick
you will be allowed to speak
please unmute yourself
and tell us if you have any new points
to make other than the points that have
already been made
yes thank you Mr chairman can you hear
me
we can yes
uh thank you Mr chairman and uh the
committee
um I'm today providing oral testimony in
support of house bill 80. my support is
based on the following reasons one as a
member of the original a Reggie
stakeholders committee I helped shake
the objectives of Reggie one of the
objectives of Reggie was obviously to
reduce carbon emissions from fossil fuel
power plants in the Reggie participating
States
but there was a second just as important
objective and that was to allow allocate
the carbon emission auction proceeds
back to the participating states with
the attention of reinvesting the
proceeds in Energy Efficiency measures
in those States unfortunately at least
50 percent of current Reggie proceeds
are sent back to Bill payers
as direct refunds these refunds which
may not even be recognized by Bill
payers nothing to reduce the demand for
electricity in the participating ready
States
if those rebates are invested in Energy
Efficiency they would according to
reputable studies return over the long
term through lower energy costs
approximately four dollars to Consumers
for every dollar invested in Energy
Efficiency much better return than
simply returning cash rebase to
customers
second Energy Efficiency saves money for
all electric bill payers in our New
England electric Distribution Systems by
reducing the importation of electricity
from out-of-state sources thus reducing
the outflow of our scarce energy dollars
into surrounding states
it also reduces carbon emissions helps
lower electricity costs to Bill payers
especially to low-income Bill payers
enables New Hampshire's distribution
utilities to delay or even eliminate
expensive infrastructure upgrades and
provides good paying jobs right here in
New Hampshire how can that be bad for
the citizens
third item seconds
third item
House Bill 80 is consistent with and
supports the proposed but not your
triennial Energy Efficiency plan now
waiting approval by the public school
commute utility submission and lastly
the bill takes at least one step in the
right direction in allocating today's
residential rebate for Reggie reflected
the non-on-going Energy Efficiency
programs in New Hampshire do what's
right for New Hampshire's electric bill
papers thank you Mr chairman appreciate
the time today
thank you Mr quasnick for your testimony
unfortunately we don't have time to
allow any questions of Mr kwasnick I
want to thank everyone who presented on
this bill this morning
and I would also like to alert everyone
that it is possible that there will be
an executive session on this bill later
today
so with that I will close
[Music]
excuse me I've been interrupted
representative Thomas
ah
representative Thomas will announce now
now the result of the blue sheet
but
according to the sheet here uh we signed
in we have 25
Pro and zero opposed and two neutral
could that be repeated by the chair
I'm sorry repeat that please
could you please repeat that we couldn't
hear it
oh I'll repeat it then there were 25
people who signed to end on this bill
most were in support there were two that
were neutral
so with that we'll close the public
hearing on HB 80.
take a two minute break before we
reconvene for our next public hearing
thank you chair
you know the last person
he just read what he already sentences
he read what he already sentences
excuse me
um
with it
foreign
[Music]
this morning
it was really nice
before
once I hit the king of Angus I didn't
know that
should be an album
foreign
[Music]
probably
because they have all the remote stuff
in here now is very updated
um
[Music]
well it's only an issue because if we're
not locked into the zoom uh people in
the room can't get their hand up in
queue like we are waiting till the
testimony is over if you're home on Zoom
you could raise your hand while they're
speaking and then all of a sudden you're
in queue so it
you know people in the room just don't
do that aren't doing that okay
so I aired on that
the first public hearings you're
learning
so from here on out before I recognize
anybody else
stay in the room lights in the room
we'll watch asking questions
okay welcome back everyone
I will now
open the public hearing on
HB 382
and I will recognize the prime sponsor
of the bill to introduce the bill
that is Peter leishman
Mr leisman you're recognized to speak
thank you
I apologize I misspoke that's
representative policeman
oh not not a problem Mr chairman
uh good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee I'm here in support of HB
382.
several years ago I learned of seasonal
demand charges due to a railroad
crossing accident with a large dump
truck
one of my trains collided with a truck
and the accident prevented the railroad
from serving an aggregate plant due to
the Damage Done to some of the railroads
equipment
as a result the aggregate plant shut
down due to the lack of material that
the railroad was able to deliver
it was then I learned that the aggregate
plant was still required to pay a
monthly demand charge whether they used
electricity or not
in time the railroad did receive a
settlement from the truck driver's
insurance company which included a seven
thousand dollar check to cover the
two-week portion of the monthly demand
charge
this past summer
due to grid issues the same aggregate
plant lost power on several occasions
and electric motors and soft start
equipment was damaged
nearly three weeks of production time
was lost
the utility was asked for a demand
charge credit due to the interruption of
power that request was declined
how fair is that
prior to the filing of HB 382 I had no
idea that the New Hampshire that New
Hampshire's largest utility has more
than 78
000 customers that are subject to some
form of demand charge
I learned that the monthly demand
charges are especially impactful on many
seasonal businesses and oftentimes these
charges are dictating when seasonal
businesses can either resume operation
or cease their operations due to weather
or other factors
I know for a fact in the aggregate
business these monthly demand charges
are limiting production as weather is
often a factor in the early spring or
fall due to freezing temperatures and
paying a monthly demand charge of
thousands of dollars for a few days or a
week of production makes little sense
I have also learned that ski areas are
also experiencing the same type of
impacts during their seasonal operations
as I think many of you know
several years ago the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
asked large on-site generators to
connect to the grid
economically and perhaps environmentally
this was a great thing at the time
it was felt that by connecting these
large Industrial
on-site generators to the grid would
improve air quality as one major
interest
air expanse New Hampshire businesses
connected to the grid
it was not uncommon for these business
owners to spend tens of thousands of
dollars to upgrade their New Hampshire
plants
at the time it was thought these
conversions would be a win-win or again
the businesses and the environment
however before the conversion to the
grid businesses with on-site generators
weren't impacted by demand charges and
could make business decisions without
the fear of monthly demand charges being
assessed for little or no electrical
usage
well these demand charges encourage
businesses to return to off-site power
production or worse
Mr chairman I believe it is time for a
diverse group of stakeholders to take a
look at demand charges in the harmful
effect
these demand charges are having on New
Hampshire business and I thank you and I
certainly would take any questions
thank you representative leishman for
introducing
Bill HB 382
do we have any questions from the
members assembled in the room here this
morning
representative Thomas thank you Mr
chairman that question thank you
representative for
uh for my question just real brief this
bill as I understand it is a bill for a
study committee
correctly
yes
or a commission so my question is
why do you feel like we need a
commission to to study um
on this bill it seems like you're
testimony was more as to uh we need that
if you wanted to actually do something
okay tell me why you feel like you need
that we need to have a commission on
this have you determined is too complex
or or what what issues did you find out
that the improvements that we have to
have a commission on this
uh thanks for the question uh several
years ago a number of issues were raised
uh concerning actually the Secretary of
State and the Department of
Environmental Services and some of you
may remember governor sunoon who issued
an executive order to look into a number
of different things to improve business
in the State uh that was executive order
2017.02 I believe and as a result uh
members of the house including former
speaker hinch and I were on that
committee or commission and we came up
with a number of recommendations uh
based on our work which turned into
house bill 11.
o4 I believe it was in 2018 which was
passed by the house and the complexity
of the things we found at DES we're glad
that there was actually a group put
together to look at DES and the
Secretary of State's office and other
agencies to try to improve the business
climate New Hampshire and I think as I
found the complexity of demand charges
I'll be perfectly honest this is the
first time I've ever even got to the
surface of demand charges and I think a
diverse group of a few select
legislators from is to build calls for
from your committee and one from the
Senate side but stakeholders I think can
provide valuable input the utilities for
instance I think everyone should be
brought to the table but that it being a
very complex issue I think it needs a
great deal of work to come up with some
good Solutions
thank you follow up representative
Thomas
thank you are there any other members uh
in the room who have
if not the chair recognizes
representative samsich for a question
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr alishman
um uh just to comment uh point of order
to the chair if I may
um we here have a hard time hearing uh
the voices of the people in the
conference room so if you could please
ask them to speak up loudly so we can
hear what they have to say uh just uh as
a request on my part
so um thank you for that comment uh in
case you were joined us late I did make
that request of the members in the room
at the beginning of the meeting but I
will repeat it uh thank you Mr chairman
so Mr lishman um I just wondered uh
aside from the business Community are
are you also aware that even churches
who may only have one service per week
are actually charged the demand charge
as well as their electric usage which
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
yes as I've learned actually eversource
has been very helpful and provided me
with some uh interesting documentation
and I was completely unaware that uh you
know like you just pointed out even
people that may use electricity uh once
a week for say a church service or also
subject to demand charge to me it's
something uh you should pay for when you
need it not to just have it on a standby
situation because anybody that's facing
these demand charges uh especially
during the time right now that we're in
an economic crisis being stuck with
these huge charges when they're not even
using electricity is just a very
problematic in my in my thinking
thank you representative some such a
follow-up
uh yes thank you Mr chairman uh Mr uh is
it has it been your experience that
you've said the demand charges often are
higher than the actual electricity
tragedy
I I have I have seen some of that I've
heard it I don't know it for a complete
fact but I believe that's probably
correct
thank you
thank you for the question and the
answer
representative leishman I have a
question for you
sure how can the utilities
adequately plan uh for their load
uh if they do not
if they cannot
make these demand charges on users who
usually occasionally use a large amount
of electricity but not always so how can
the utility plan for and guarantee that
that the supply will be available
without these demand charges
thank you Mr chairman you raised an
excellent uh point a question and my
feeling and my response to that is the
need for a commission to look into
questions just like the one you raised
thank you I appreciate that answer
so next we go to
the chair recognizes representative
oxygen for a question
thank you very much my question was just
asked and answered
okay thank you uh the chair recognizes
representative Ali Pittsburgh
representative leishman if
if companies or churches or
organizations face these demand charges
can they
get around those charges by having a
contract
um contract
sure I can always speak to the uh
aggregate company that I'm familiar with
they have been unsuccessful in
developing any sort of contract
arrangement with the utility that serves
them I can tell you one of the things
that's I've noticed uh this company
operates around
Massachusetts and all over New Hampshire
as well they have facilities in
Massachusetts that they have left
um on on-site generation in their
quarries and their plants so they're not
subject to the demand charge because
they found it so punitive so we're
seeing the impact of uh companies
electing to keep their on-site
generators because it's cheaper and they
can turn on the plants when the weather
is conducive to production or shut the
things down without being penalized by a
demand chart so the
hope that the Department of
Environmental Services had put out there
a few years ago to get these on-site
generators removed to improve air
quality the demand charges are forcing
companies to take another look at
keeping their on-site generators
thank you
follow up about Representative
no thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you
representative Nick White
that raised my hand
by accident I thought you did no
apologies did you not
I did not know
okay I apologize for calling on you so
apparently we have no more questions for
representative leishman so
next I will call on the next speaker
Madeline Monroe representing clean
energy New Hampshire
you are recognized to present
thank you chairman Vose and uh thank you
for hearing my testimony today
Representatives clean energy New
Hampshire supports house bill 382.
um demand charges are something that we
hear a lot about and that we work a lot
on uh with the work that we do we hear
from churches and schools that are being
hammered by these demand charges and
trying to understand them better and
trying to figure out how they can manage
their energy use
um to better reduce those demand charges
and that's something that we help them
with to the best of our ability but as I
mentioned in my written testimony the
information that customers can get from
utilities about their demand charges the
detailed energy usage and how they can
manage those demand charges is quite
limited so that can be challenging we do
think that demand charges deserve
careful consideration and study and we
want to thank representative leishman
for bringing this issue to the Forefront
by introducing this bill
as I also mentioned in our written
testimony we do think however that the
scope of the commission should be
expanded specifically to address how
demand charges affect electric vehicle
charging
uh energy storage battery charging
and how demand charges are calculated
affects the payback of Energy Efficiency
um Investments
we also so we ask that the scope of the
commission be expanded to add these
issues as well as Representatives on the
commission with specific expertise in
these issues
that's my testimony I'm happy to take
any questions
thank you very much Ms minnow
so far I only see a couple of hands
raised are there any questions from
anyone here in the room
I'm trying to be vigilant about making
sure I don't miss any ends up there in
your group
so before I go to the uh the other
questioners I have a question for you Ms
minnow
you you know that the the demand charges
come from the regulated utilities
primarily and since they are regulated
one would assume that the puc has some
oversight authority over demand charges
if the POC thinks demand charges are
legitimate and useful uh is there
a question about whether that's true or
not is that why you think maybe this
committee is necessary
um no I as I mentioned my testimony
we're actually actively working on
specific issues related to demand
charges in dockets related to electric
vehicle charging and energy storage uh
more generally the puc moves very slowly
and I think does appreciate policy
direction from the legislature and so I
think it may be helpful to specify
certain policy recommendations to the
puc if the legislature or this study
commission found that that was helpful
thank you the chair now recognizes
representative some search for a
question
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Ms minnow
um
can you uh enlighten me whether I got
this right but I believe that the way
the demand charges are usually charged
is in any given month uh what the
highest Spike of usage is
in a very small time interval maybe
within half an hour interval or
something and that is used to charge the
use for the demand charge is that
correct yes most uh commercial
industrial customers are on a much more
detailed metering than a residential
customer for example and so their usage
is considered in 15-minute increments
and it is whatever 15 minute increment
in the month that you hit the highest
usage that is what your demand charge
will be based on but as I mentioned some
of the utilities also use an annual
ratchet so it will also be whatever the
15-minute increment was the highest in
the whole year and so even if you make a
huge change in our energy usage in
November you won't and you won't see a
reduction in your demand charge for a
whole year until the following November
um
a follow-up representative samsich yes
thank you Mr chairman so so what in
response to what you just said I I
understand that if if I were and I've
done this with my church and I I said
you know if you guys Implement Energy
Efficiency uh not only do you reduce
your electric usage but you also reduce
your demand charge that correct yes
that's correct if you can either Target
whatever is causing that one spike in
your usage or just reduce your usage
overall your demand charge will also be
reduced and so for some
um commercial customers that can be a
specific piece of equipment that Cycles
on and off so you could change that from
uh to a variable drive for example so
that it it doesn't Spike on and Spike
off or you can put a specific piece of
equipment on a battery
um it is possible to manage demand
charges in many cases but it can be very
costly to hire a consultant to get
sometimes they have to put on more
detailed metering than they're able to
get from the utility and to be able to
to to sort of get to the root cause of
what is causing the one you know price
usage Spike that that causes their
demand charge
thank you very much
thank you the chair now recognizes
representative Michael Harrington for a
question
uh hello can you hear me
yes yes okay uh my question was simply
uh I thought there was a way to really
reduce charges I look back to the few
years back when Westinghouse was testing
react the coolant pump motors on the
Seacoast and they had interruptible
power so the utility was able to say
turn off those pumps now we we can't
give you that power and that was able to
drastically reduce their demand charge
is that option still available for or
any large user
um I think you're talking about demand
response programs and yes as part of our
eers and our energy excuse me I wasn't
talking about demand responses okay
interruptible Power what it means is
they would test these reactive coolant
pump motors would suck up huge amounts
of electricity and they will cut
customers of public service at the time
and public service can simply say shut
off your Motors now and they agreed to
do that and so they were able to
substantially lower their demand and I I
believe it's still a negotiable thing
that companies can do with the utilities
simply say during a certain time I'm
going to have to tell you not to use
that much power and they have obviously
the company would have to agree to it
and then we'd save money is that still
in effect I do believe that is still a
tariff in effect for eversource
customers so they would be able to opt
into that thank you
follow-up representative Harrington
nope that's all set thank you
thank you very much the chair now
recognizes representative McGee for a
question
thank you Mr chairman
um in listening to other folks speak
about their specific issues around
demand charges I'm reminded of a
conversation that I had with uh Hollis
primary school they invested in solar
panels on the roof uh to lower their
their costs uh for them McGee could you
suspend for a moment sure could you
um possibly get a little bit closer to
your microphone because it's very hard
for us to hear you thank you I
appreciate that no problem I usually
project pretty loud so
I was
I was just our our primary school system
has invested in solar panels as many
school systems have to try and lower uh
their fixed costs and they were among
the first people to mention to me the
idea of the peak demand charges being
something they had not anticipated
because Peak charges from their
perspective are middle of the day and as
uh as a school system they can't avoid
um being affected by those Peak demand
charges and so they have not realized
the savings that they hoped for and it's
all just policy so I I I wanted to see
if Ms minnow could could talk about that
the time of use and how that affects
various users in the system because I I
can't say that I fully understand why
the schools are um are uh in this
situation where they can't realize uh
the benefits that they had hoped to by
that investment in local energy
yes that's correct so with their solar
I'm guessing they're net metering and
demand charges are never credited to net
metering customers and so that's not
something that when you export you can
reduce your your demand charge so
um with solar the amount of solar that
you're using in real time behind the
meter can help you lower your demand
charge but that can be difficult to
predict when you're developing a system
for a specific application how much will
be used at a very fine scale time
increment in real time behind the meter
versus being exported to the grid so
that does affect those situations and
what you were talking about
time of day there are more sophisticated
demand charges that are called Peak
coincident demand charges because really
demand charges are meant to
um
allow utilities to recover the cost of
serving very high draw customers but as
you all have probably heard many times
Peak demand times is when most of the
grid costs are created and so if a high
draw demand customer their Peak always
happens at night time when Demand on the
overall grid is actually quite low the
cost of serving that customer is
exaggerated by their demand charge
because we use blunt demand charges
doesn't matter when your Peak is
happening we're going to charge you
based on how high that Peak is and so
really there are more sophisticated
demand charges which are called Peak
coincident demand charges
thank you Mr chair can I just have a
follow I just yes follow up
so Ms minnow then again I'm assuming the
complexities here are are significant so
I'm assuming that's why you're
supporting the bill
yes correct I mean there's a lot of
complexity here and as as I mentioned
there's a lot of uh very important clean
energy sectors that are very uh very
affected by demand charges like electric
vehicle charging as um DC fast charging
stations are very high draw however
um at at low U usage rates
um the cost of running those stations
can be so high because if a car charges
there once a month you're going to be
paying so much for that demand charge
compared to the electricity used that it
completely destroys the economics of
developing a DC fast charging Network
thank you
thank you the chair recognizes
representative oxenham for a question
thank you very much Mr chairman I I very
much appreciate you bringing forward the
issue of the complexity of this uh on on
on on first glance it makes so much
sense to I mean get rid of these demand
charges what what's the purpose there
are a lot of reasons for them and if we
eliminate them those charges are going
to be put somewhere else those charges
aren't going to go away they're going to
be reallocated and it if we
I believe and I could be wrong here
because I'm really not as up on
Commercial and Industrial rate design as
I am on residential design but I very
much fear that this could lead to
increased rates for our residential rate
payers so I I support the the idea
um
and thank you for bringing up the
complexity of this because it's
important in our willingness and
Readiness to go forward with a study
committee was there a question there
representative oxenham I started with a
question and then I realized that it
didn't make any sense so I'm I just I
can say that generally the costs are
shifted to volumetric charges and so it
is more reflective of how much energy
you're using
in general
chair recognizes representative Kelly
Pitts for a question
don't forget to unmute representative
luckily I remember to get dressed uh you
asked for some additional
um
things to be included in this
and I just wondered
you you talked about battery charging
which I was I'm going to assume it's
cars
what about storage batteries
um that are now coming online
uh being becoming more effective would
it affect storage batteries in
residential and in commercial uses
the demand charge that's correct I
talked about both electric vehicle
charging and energy storage battery
charging and in New Hampshire thankfully
residential customers are not charge
demand charges so battery charging in
the residential application would not be
affected by demand charges however
larger energy store battery energy
storage installations that would
interconnect to the grid would likely be
put on a commercial industrial tariff
which would have a demand charge and as
I explained in my written testimony
these batteries specifically operate to
charge at low load low-cost times and
discharge at Peak demand high cost times
and so for them for example a peak
coincident demand charge would make a
lot more sense because
by definition they are operating to only
charge at off-peak low-cost times
thank you you need a follow-up
Representative no I do not thank you
thank you
you have no more
raised hands so I would like to ask if
there are any members or any persons who
want to speak who have not been so
recognized who
recognize yourself your desire right at
this moment please
see none I will close this public
hearing whoops
I see that Krista shoots has has to be
recognized so Chris to shoot
you will be uh permitted to speak go
ahead please
thanks very much this is Krista shoot on
behalf of the office of the consumer
Advocate
um Mr crease had submitted some
testimony and I just wanted to follow up
on the comment
that um
in regards to uh
so Mr crease's testimony
um asks for an amendment for the repair
Advocate to be represented on the board
and I wanted to point out that though
residential ratepayers don't currently
pay demand charges there is both the
potential for an impact from changes but
also because of batteries and EV the
potential for ratepayers to start paying
those in the future and so that is part
of the reason that we are interested in
supporting the committee and being on on
the committee and also to make myself
available for questions if anyone has
any
shoot I will remind everyone that at the
direction of the speaker of the house we
have been requested to retain all study
committee and study commission bills so
there will be adequate time to make
adjustments to this bill
uh when we take it up in the fall
I'll just remind everyone of that
and I will now recognize recuperating
member of the
stne
Fred Platt for a comment go ahead
representative play
I just wanted to say hello
um it's back to be good to be back in
the saddle I want to thank all of my
friends at the at stne who said cards
and otherwise uh contacted me including
uh rep cap McKee who forgot to put my
name on the card so they had to open it
up to find out who it's for but thank
you all
and it's great to have you back
representative but uh we'll monitor your
recuperation and we'll welcome you back
to the committee as a full participating
member as soon as you're able
um
Troy Marner wants you back soon as it
turns out
so representative oxenham did you have
another question
yes I do
um be nice to ask you a question thank
you very much it has to do with this
issue of whether or not we can have
study committees and study commissions
at our at a previous meeting you told us
that the president of the senate had
directed that bills would be itl'd when
they reached the Senate if they were
passed out of the house with a component
of a study committee or a study
Commission Now this morning you're
telling us it's the direction of the
speaker of the house I spent a great
deal of time tracking down this issue of
the president of the Senate because I
have several bills for very good reasons
that contain study committees and study
commissions I'm very concerned about
this issue so it could could you
elaborate please for us where it's
coming from whether it applies to every
committee uh just the ramifications of
this are really quite quite important a
lot of the legislation that we receive
requires more substantive consideration
and thought than we can give it
particularly with these truncated
compressed time periods were allocated
okay I understand your question I'll do
my best to answer it
the way it was explained to members of
house leadership
was that the president of the Senate
Senator Chuck Morris
approached the speaker of the house and
informed him that if the house sent to
the Senate and he studied committee or
study commission bills that they would
be itl'd
the speaker of the house then informed
house leadership which included
obviously the chairs of house committees
that the best strategy to use for study
committee and study commission bills
would be to retain them
because if you pass them they'll just be
itl in the Senate
so that's my understanding of the
progression of the communication between
the leadership of the Senate and the
leadership of the house
so with that uh
I'll recognize
representative Kelly Pitts for a
question
of the
are we permitted to work on it over the
summer
as as we have in subcommittees or after
committee work or when we are not inside
when we are not meeting
yes the answer to that question is yes
typically you do it in the fall but I
suppose we could do it in the summer
although you wouldn't be allowed to
collect any mileage for going to a
subcommittee meeting in the summer but
um I'm not collecting mileage for this
one
all right representative Thomas
if I may just add to the explanation for
the clarity for the entire group
my understanding is if the bill is
retained
on your own you can do work on it
during whatever time you have you won't
get paid mileage from coming into it to
do it because that bill will not be
taken up until the next line of the year
the other reason for the retaining
strategy is plain and simple we don't
have a space for the time to give to
subcommittees
to around the Committees to to meet
with our situation with the pandemic and
the and the limitations we have
leaderships of both house felt that on
both sides felt that we you opened up
for one we have it open up for everyone
and there's no space to put these
committees so that was part of the other
garage sale or or you know for the
reasoning so it wasn't just an arbitrary
decision it was it was reason for it
that's their reason that's their
rational board that's what we've been
instructed to do and do
thank you representative Thomas this is
not an issue for a debate so I will
recognize representative McGee for a
question but only a question we're not
going to debate this issue
I'm not here to debate the issue
um my question is I was looking at
Senate bills the other day and I noticed
that they have an awful lot of study
committees and I'm wondering if the
house is going to take the same position
that the Senate has taken because they
actually have a lot of their work in
study commissions as well so I'm just
curious because
um they a lot of the bills that they put
forward are also committees and
commissions
I can't comment on how the Senate
conducts their business no no I'm saying
I'm saying is the house going to their
bills that way if they come over to us
if they don't retain their study the way
that we're approaching the moment would
be that we would receive no study
committee bills from the Senate
okay that they would retain their study
committee bills the same way they've
advised us in a few hours okay thank you
you're welcome thank you all right so it
appears that we have exhausted the
speaker list and the questions for this
bill so I'm going to close the public
hearing on HB
uh
gotta announce the blue sheet I'm sorry
our Senate support and zero approvals
did everyone here
very close
okay so with that we will close the
public hearing on HB 382.
and I will immediately open an exec
session
and I will call on representative homila
for a motion
thank you I make a motion to retain
house bill 382.
representative homela has made a motion
to retain House Bill 382 representative
Bernardi I second that motion that
motion has been seconded by
representative Bernardi is there any
discussion on the motion to retain House
Bill 382
seeing none I will ask the clerk to call
the roll
and vote on House Bill 382 on the motion
of retain
Ed
okay Bill number three eat two
okay
the representative Thomas
yes
representative Harrington
I'm sorry
representative Harrington was in the
attendee list so he's just been promoted
and he's now on screen okay can you hear
me now yes okay my vote Yes
representative not
representative Myrna
representative homela yes
representative bresney yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative chambles yes
representative close
here closure yes Jose
I'm not that fancy representative white
yes
representative sausage
don't forget to unmute yourself
yeah
representative Kelly Pitts yes
instead of man
yes
representative oxenham
no
representative Vinson
yes
representative McGee yes
representative McWilliams
yes
representative Christian
it's creation yes
yes
representative
represented partial
yes
in the chair
representative those votes yes
okay the vote is 20 years and one day
with a motion to retain passes
because we're going to retain the bill
it's my understanding that we do not
need a
majority or Minority Report
that we just keep the bill in committee
and it doesn't go any farther is that
correct
yeah it doesn't go before the house
Okay so
uh the bill passes and is retained since
we have some more time
I'm going to call on representative
Nutter for a motion
yes we're going to do another bill
well I would like to conclude that we um
Ito
[Music]
representative naughter has moved itl on
HB 80.
representative regini I second
representative bresney has seconded the
motion of Ito on hb80 is there any
discussion
representative nodder yes um I had made
a call to legislative Services asking
for the number of study committees and
commissions that we already had finally
came in this morning well I didn't have
time to read through them all but it's a
very very long list and all of these
commissions and studies add up it costs
money and I know it all it's only a
little bit of money here a little bit of
money there but it all adds up to a lot
of money and we've we just have too many
and a lot of these things can be studied
without having to to meet we're talking
about HB 80 which is not a study
commission though
[Music]
where are all these study committees
that we're going through
um
all the Energy Efficiency but okay
Reggie yes subsidies I everyone knows I
have an issue with with the subsidies
and taxes and it I know it's only a
little bit so again this also applies a
little bit here a little bit there it
all adds up and the only way to reduce
taxes is to chip away a little bit at a
time so for that and uh also so I don't
have to speak again when we get to the
studies we'll start even soon don't have
to talk again
representative
are there other representatives in the
room that would like to express an
opinion
oh this is John Mann I would like to oh
this is I would like to speak to it
I don't see your hand raised uh I don't
know how to raise my hand I'm just so I
used my voice
if you want me to wave or is there a
button there's a little button on the
bottom of the secret
not with mine
representative man or anybody else on
Zoom I'm going to recognize
representative Amala for a comment yes
thank you chair
um the comment I wanted to make is in a
lot of the testimony and discussion and
the questions that we had on this bill
my concern is that we talked about
Energy Efficiency which which everyone
agrees with Energy Efficiency things are
great but that wasn't the focus of the
bill the focus of this bill is that this
will take away money out of the answer
space
residents can now let all residents can
now equally participate in it and things
like the two years ago they offered four
thousand dollars for insulation and that
was right off the top of your program so
if a homeowner had a six thousand dollar
insulation Project New Hampshire State
took four uh four thousand right off
that last year that was actually
increased to about 8 000.
um so those things are really important
and and those things just to say that
unless this money gets shifted we're not
doing energy efficiencies inaccurate
because we actually are and homeowners
now have the choice to do the projects
that that work best for them and so my
concern is by taking that away that's
actually a very big savings to
homeowners and it allows them uh people
that just aren't in low incomes with
just the level of incomes it allows them
to do some pretty amazing things to
their home so that's my concern about
this building
representative samsich
thank you Mr chairman uh I would just
like to say uh that uh there is nobody
taking away any money from New Hampshire
saves I think we've heard the testimony
from Mr Fitzgerald that this this bill
actually gives New Hampshire saves more
money and will provide more help to the
very cases that were just mentioned as
needing more funding so uh all the
testimony we've heard on this bill has
been saying that this is a very useful
and very good bill both for the
ratepayers as well as for the State of
New Hampshire so I think we should go
ahead and improve it thank you
thank you representative McWilliams
thank you chair Bose I just wanted to
reiterate that from the uh sign-ins that
we received on this bill there were 23
in support and two neutral we have not
heard any testimony against this bill so
I'm surprised that the first motion that
was brought up was an itl that's all I
have to say about this thank you
representative Kelly Pitts
yes as I'm looking out the window and
the wind is picking up I don't think
there's anybody in the state of New
Hampshire that would not give up a price
of a cup of coffee and a muffin at
Starbucks to provide five million
dollars more in insulation and Energy
Efficiency for for the rest of the state
that's all thank you representative
Harrington
uh never mind it's not necessary
uh representative oxenham
yes thank you very much I I want to do
uh mention the exact figures that uh
Mike Fitzgerald gave us currently New
Hampshire saves is getting 2.9 Million
Dollars
this bill would raise that to 6.7
million dollars so in in the interest of
uh you know absolute Clarity here what
we're talking about is is taking away
that one equivalent of a dollar a month
from the bill that people don't even
notice is there
aggregating that money into a pool from
which people competitively are chosen
for their projects
and we we get the most cost effective
use of that money and another speaker
said in in general for every one dollar
we spend on Energy Efficiency we have a
four dollar gain so they all have to
pass cost benefit analysis this is a
very good use of our money we should not
be walking away from Energy Efficiency
it's the best thing we can do for air
pollution greenhouse gas emissions
lowering demand lowering our prices
across the board thank you
thank you representative partial
yeah I saw as a new legislator I'll be
very uncomfortable in having to explain
to my constituents why I'm not doing
everything in my power to reduce
property taxes reducing our school
expenses
I am all in favor of this bill
thank the representative Mann
yes uh thank you
um
I just think after all the testimony
that was given in favor of the bill
I'm not going to repeat myself but I
cannot believe anybody would even think
about it yelling it thank you
thank you representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair uh you know
this is very indicative of
in many ways in government knows best
and I would like to say that we could
take more money out of people's
paychecks for child programs for
infrastructure for anything we wanted
and say that it benefits everybody and
yet we're just making money more away
from people I would suggest that instead
of sending out the message that we don't
care about our business repairs we're
going to take all that money and give it
to where we think it works best I
suggest that we keep
a some type of a proportion to at least
sell repairs we understand your plight
and we you know like to take some but
not all of your money to do some
programs not take it all so I'm getting
a little tired of people saying it's
only going to cost a cup of coffee you
add up Taylor's programs it becomes the
cost of a you know maybe a meal so I
suggest that we keep the program the way
it is uh would be in favor of IPL and at
least we show some support for the
residential repairs and we understand
that it will take so many money but we
don't take it all all the time so that's
the way I feel about that
thank you Representative Vincent
thank you uh Mr chairman I've heard two
Representatives talk about saving money
on taxes this has nothing to do with
taxes this has to do with Energy
Efficiency and let's face it taxes never
go down they always go up they never go
down in my history I've never seen taxes
go down so this is about Energy
Efficiency thank you Mr chairman
Mr chairman thank you representative
representative
taxes because you can't they're going to
spend it all and ask for more because
hashtag Never Enough redistribution of
wealth is redistribution of wealth
representative evantell
don't forget to unmute
sorry Mr chairman thank you Mr chairman
this bill is going to save people money
this bill
deserves our vote
we should we should vote no on itl in
this bill so that we can take a new
motion thank you
thank you everyone
our representative Bernardi thank you Mr
chairman for that so as I've listened to
the testimony going back and forth It's
always this Energy Efficiency is going
to save us money it's going to say the
very very very very small number of
people some money because they're going
to be the benefit Fisheries of the
Energy Efficiency projects it's going to
take money from 450
so it's a balancing question here and
it's not as has been characterized this
is a great Boon to Energy Efficiency
it's a very selected population that
will benefit everybody else will suffer
thank you I would remind the members in
the room to speak loudly and clearly
representative Presley thank you Mr
chairman during the initial testimony I
heard that rate payers are are not going
to save are not benefiting from the
small amount that they're saving and
that they would benefit a lot more if
they were to invest in energy efficient
light bulbs
um but the the price for an energy
efficient light bulb is significantly
covered by these rebates so if you were
to to continue the rebates right payers
can use that money to buy energy
efficient light bulbs and lower their
bills
thank you it appears that everyone now
has had a chance to stream everything
period
excuse me that I hear someone say
something yeah it was representative
McGee
no go ahead
thank you Mr chairman
um I I've heard a whole bunch of
different positions here but
um the itl motion from my fellow
representative from district
Hillsborough 27
um
stated the that the bill does the
opposite of what it does and if that is
the basis for the itl I I think
we need a clear understanding if there's
going to be a motion to um make this
bill inexpedient to legislate and that's
going to be the recommendation of why
it's being proposed that way because
this bill would support increased
funding for Energy Efficiency which does
lower rates for everyone because it
lowers our Demand right it it lowers the
amount of energy that we're required to
purchase and so in my town in our town
in suhimolas and my town we have that
school that is looking to figure out how
to make their investments in locally
generated energy on the school buildings
work for them
and those investments in Energy
Efficiency are forever
it means that that those are the
negawatts that that consumer Advocate
Chris spoke about which means we don't
have to pay for that energy anymore
because once the efficiency is in place
they don't use as much energy
so this idea that it it it's somehow
being
um transferred to rate payers as a cost
they will pick up that's not true that's
why we're advocating for the bill
because the bill
supports lowered energy costs so you can
look at it as property taxes that
municipalities have to pay because their
energy costs are going up and not down
but this is one way you can bring those
energy costs down and that's the reason
it's being proposed so when it's being
presented here is this that and the
other is a study committee and none of
those are relevant to what we heard in
the testimonies today so I would really
ask that people on this committee look
at it for the benefits that it's going
to bring to New Hampshire and not from
an ideology ideological standpoint
okay thank you representative
representative McGee representative
omila did you want to respond yes sir
all I was saying was that my statement
wasn't the basis for an itl I did not
mention Ito one of the things that I was
just trying to bring up was the fact
that reducing if we reduce if this
affects in any way and the question I
had originally was does this change the
New Hampshire Sage program the answer I
received in testimony was yes and so my
my point just went to
why are we why would we want to reduce
the New Hampshire stage program because
it is still accomplishing what we wanted
to accomplish for Energy Efficiency I
just want to clarify that thank you and
the response was that it increases the
New Hampshire saves program it does not
reduce it okay thank you representative
McGee
okay we're running short of time here so
I'm asking clerk to call the roll on the
motion of Ito for HB 80. okay
okay
representative Thomas
yes
representative Harrington
representative NADA yes
representative Myrna yes
representative Home Alone yes
representative bresney yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative kimbrells yes
representative yes
[Music]
representative White
representative sausage
no
representative Jackie Kelly Pitts no
representative men
no
it's stuck representative oxenham
um I'm sorry about the telephone ringing
I just um Can someone say yes or no
I I have to protest this this is a
charade having a vote where people don't
understand what they're voting on this
is the problem with rushing through this
entire process
yes or no
[Music]
no
Representative Vincent
and all no
representative McGee
no
representative Williams
representative chittenton
it's creation no whisper in my ears
representative Pimentel
no
representative paschall Molson
[Music]
and the chair Mr Rose representative
Rose representative folks know
Amanda folks yes I apologize
okay the vote is 11 to 10 for itl
so the motion carries and representative
not her we'd appreciate a majority
report
by next Tuesday
representative samsich will there be a
Minority Report yeah I I assume that uh
representative Mann will write the
report is that correct absolutely okay
we would appreciate that report by next
Tuesday representative man no later than
next Tuesday
how is it set
you can send it to our house committee
researcher Jen four
via email
got it thank you
thank you
and of course I'd appreciate a copy
there to uh representative oh no
all right I would like to call to order
the public hearing on House Bill
169 and I would like to recognize the
bills
Prime sponsor
Jackie Grote
so representative wrote your
recognized to speak
Jennifer do we have any uh
roads
I do not see representative grow in the
attendee list it looks like
representative white has recognized
representative Cannon
um
might she be a co-sponsor
yes
um she's the sponsor
it's broke in Rockingham 24.
I have Meg diori
available to introduce the bill for you
okay the chair recognized representative
Cannon to present uh this Bill thank you
good morning Mr Speaker Mr chair excuse
me Mr chair and uh
fellow members of the uh of a committee
um in this in the house
um my name from the record my name is
representative Jerry Cannon I represent
the uh the represent Stratford County 18
which includes four of the of the five
Awards in Somersworth and the small town
of Rollins
I have submitted my uh my testimony and
I instead of just reading it verbatim I
wanted to uh talk to this consider that
your
a disabled person and your only way to
get around town is
and through an electric wheelchair
as you go out on the street to go down
to the local
grocery store or to the market or to the
Pharmacy
you're traveling down a sidewalk for
safety and you come across a double pole
in the road which crowds you between the
pole and a brick wall
forcing you to back up and find a spot
to drive ride your
your wheelchair on the street
putting your life at risk
so you get back you get around that you
go down the street and you get to an
intersection with a four-way stop
there's another double pole there and
you have to go around it to get to the
crosswalk
across the walk there's another car
coming into the intersection
and
and as you proceed from behind the
double pole the driver doesn't see you
and you may not see them
the potential for an accident exists
other safety concerns with the city are
that double poles are usually there to
rep to replace the damaged pole either
from an auto accident or from
um natural causes
these polls are lashed together and you
never know when
the the pole that has been left for
utilities to remove their equipment
um May collapse or parts may fall on
someone
in the community
a challenge we've had has been has been
told to us from the public works
department
is that a damaged Pole
make it many of its power components
replaced immediately when the poll is
replaced however all of the other
utilities that utilize that poll and
have been notified of poll is replaced
then we'll have to schedule time with
the city to replace their
their hardware and their cables and all
of that
the challenge is that many of these
utilities don't replace or their
equipment or move their equipment for
weeks months or even years
and we have many polls in the city that
are in this condition
these um these poles detract from the
the character of our communities
they put our
residents at risk
they also put property values at risk
when
a resident goes to sell their home
so
um
so I support adding a commission to take
a look at this because last year a house
bill 1111
um was supposed to take a look at this
particular issue
and as I attended a work session on it
it was determined that there was no
formal
ability for all of our utilities to
coordinate to move all of their
equipment onto a new coal and it was
recommended at that time that we formed
some form of commission so that all the
parties could get together and work out
an arrangement for how we do this in a
coordinated fashion so that cities
weren't left with what some utility just
sort of ignores
and so I would I voted I would vote in
support of this bill so we can extend
establish a commission to look into how
these utilities will work together to
provide our our residents uh with the
safety they they deserve as well as the
city
it doesn't have to call on a regular
basis to see if somebody is going to
repair it and remove their equipment
thank you
thank you representative
before we uh
before we move to questions
let me just
I see that Jackie Grote is now here and
has her hand raised
and would like to to speak
so I'm trying to debate should I let her
speak before we uh
allow other ask questions I I think
that that probably is the is the best
way to go so I'm going to recognize the
chair is now going to recognize Jackie
Grote to speak
thank you
um Mr chair and can the committee hear
me
yes you're a little bit uh
is this better
I hear you
all right first of all I apologize for
my tardiness
um and I I wanted to ask you and I want
to thank representative Thomas for the
guidance that he gave to me before this
hearing I understand the difficulty of
having a commission
um did Ms um Martin from the puc speak
to you yet she was she had planned on
speaking
no she's on the list but we recognize
you first okay thank you
um
so the the conversation that I had with
representative Thomas was to try to
change this bill from a commission to
something that could be more active and
perhaps enforce the um
the moving of
these
um the the moving of the telephone poles
and after several phone calls actually
with the puc it was determined that this
is a complicated issue in that we have
telephone pole owners on one hand
and um we have uh some of the people on
the telephone pole some of the companies
on the telephone pole are under the
jurisdiction of the puc such as collect
electric companies and then we have some
com some carriers that are not under the
jurisdiction of POC such as cable
companies
and so to put together a enforcement
RSA would make it difficult without the
input from some of the individuals that
are not part of the puc the thought was
at first to give this the response this
gives responsibility to the puc however
they don't feel that they can do it
as it is because of this component of
the cable companies not being part of
their jurisdiction
so
um I think it's well recognized that
this is a problem throughout New
Hampshire and the puc is recommending
that we go through with the commission
even though this is a terrible year to
do such a thing and I know that the
policy has been to reduce or eliminate
any commissions so I made it I mean I
understand the position I recognize the
difficulty and the attempt was made to
um give this authority to the puc
through RSA however they're unable to
carry out with their task based on the
way it's set up now
did it was does anybody have any
questions for me
uh representative Thomas has a question
representative my question
thank you for the new information uh and
uh I guess my my question would be uh
number one I'm in favor of whatever
brings this to a fruition uh so are are
you um
therefore saying that by going forward
with a commission that we can expect to
perhaps no action for the next at least
two years because of the time we have to
wait to get to this Mission Bill and
then the time for the commission to act
and then for the time for whatever they
want can actually be put into rules or
reflect upon so we're looking at maybe
two or three years in the future if you
personally actually happens is that your
understanding
that's correct
okay thank you any follow-up
representative Thomas
okay the chair recognizes representative
McWilliams
thank you turbos I want to follow up on
City and town Authority for charging
whoever is responsible for these polls
I'm I'm curious if there's a way that we
can come up with a solution to allow
cities and towns to find whoever owns
the poll give them that Authority
through legislation which I think would
then incentivize the owners of the polls
to remove them so I'm curious if that's
something that has been discussed
researched if you have any information
on this representative grody
oh am I still okay um
there are towns that do do that
um through their own
ordinances but there isn't a Statewide
um
law that gives them that Authority
follow-up chervos
thanks follow up
yeah so um since you're talking about
potential revisions to this legislation
might I propose that perhaps a Statewide
Authority
um some kind of Statewide statute
Authority for cities and towns to find
for double polls perhaps
we could
thank you
representative oxendum for a question
that was an error I removed my hand but
not soon enough
oh sorry thank you uh representative
Thomas your hand is still up do you need
to ask another question
okay
uh all right there appear to be no
further questions the members
online are there any questions from
members in the room
see representative brezhny thank you Mr
chairman my question is are are do the
electric companies have liability for
what happens with somebody who is
injured while trying to go around the
polls
um can you please in what way going
around the polls what does that mean
uh like the story that was told earlier
with with somebody going around the poll
and being hit by a vehicle for example
uh okay so this is one of the components
that the um that I had a conversation
with the puc on is that safety is an
issue
and um
to answer
um
safety is an issue and the other is that
um the the the
culprit if I could say that word Loosely
in this is not the electric companies
um in in every case the electric company
because of the the danger involved in
moving electrical electrical lines are
always the first ones to move their
lines from one pole to another that step
is
um it goes well and that's the step
that's being monitored by the puc
step that's not going well and is the
issue is the transferring of the cable
companies or private security companies
that don't have an incentive to move
their pull to move one poll to the other
so that
um that is the that's the that's the
Crux of the problem how do you
incentivize those people and safety of a
different having two polls and people
having to go around them especially in
the city is a problem
I realize that I'm sorry realize that
these telephone poles are owned by are
not all owned by the same entity
any follow-up no thank you okay thank
you the chair now recognizes
representative pennantel for a question
thank you Mr chairman uh representative
Grody are
the towns
allowed to tax the unused polls
yes and they do at least I've checked
with my talent and they do
thank you
any follow-up representative Pimentel
no follow-up
chair recognizes representative Kelly
Pitts for a question
don't forget to turn on your mic
representative
polls are around some in some areas
they're owned by the telephone company
in some areas they're owned by the
um
The Electric Company so that's the
difference
I know because I used to put polls in
that's all I wanted to clarify and I I
don't know and I I think one
I don't know if you would agree but if
there's two poles standing
perhaps double taxation on the poll
owner
could be could be levied and then there
would be some pressure for the others to
move their wires
that's all this is part of the um so the
polls are owned by it's true there are
polls that are owned by cable companies
and pools that are owned by electric
companies but there's several for
example the New Hampshire Electric Co-op
on some polls eversource owns some polls
they're not you know all owned by one
entity or another and there is no um
this is why we have to have the
conversation between these different
Services because
um there's no enforcement mechanism to
move to make one
um
there's no enforcement mechanism
mechanism for example for someone who's
getting the tax to make the other person
make the other company move their line
there's no enforcement mechanism for any
of this in New Hampshire which is why
we're you know this is why the POC
recommended the commission we have to
have an understanding in a conversation
between many entities before we can move
on
do you need a follow-up representative
Kelly Pitts no thank you
and if I might add although
um I know I understand the delay but if
the commission was allowed to um do its
work then we would have legislation
ready in two weeks I mean 22 years as
opposed to putting this you know off
again in two years
thank you the chair recognizes
representative samsich for a question
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Brody
this is just a comment
and I think it's not the highest
priority for polls but I would like to
point out that this is pretty much
Scenic clutter
absolutely
it detracts from everything around it so
you know maybe shaming people might not
be a bad idea
thank you representative samsich
representative McGee is recognized
requested
I don't think
generally is a good idea
um my question is actually a little on
the process side because
um as your uh your testimony opened you
acknowledge the fact that commissions
and committees are being pushed off and
retained and that you might want to
bring something more active in terms of
not a commission but maybe a fully baked
amendment to this bill so I'm wondering
how you see the disposition of this
going
um because we may be executing it as
soon as today so I'm just curious did
you plan to have an amendment to this or
are you still looking for a committee
that may or may not be retained all
right the conversation that I had with
representative Thomas of your committee
was that I should try to bring forth a
Amendment today which is what I tried to
do this week and after conversations
with the puc it was decided that we
really didn't have enough
um
information or enough agreement between
companies to put together
an amendment and if I might if I may
I'll explain to you the difficulty
um
all the telephone poles whether they be
duplicate or not are listed in a puc
database
there are hundreds of thousands of these
telephone poles
and the piece the electric companies are
required to participate in this in this
database
and so as any activity that's done on
these telephone poles by the utility
polls is called them by the the electric
company has to be is monitored through
this puc database
however cable companies and telephone
companies volunteer to participate
so some do some don't
but there's no
mandatory time for them
to move their equipment from one pole to
the other so we have this sort of
mishmash of
you know at that level we have a
mishmash of participation which makes it
very difficult and the puc has no
jurisdiction to mandate anything for
them
to them so that's what makes it
difficult The Hope was to just give this
to puc and let them be the the company
to the the process to in which to carry
this out but based on current rsas
they're unable to
and they don't have the
um
they don't really have the they don't
know they need they need this commission
this is why they're proposing the
commission so they can have this
conversation between all these entities
so they can actually take that on so
then the bill would be at the end to
um enact what the commission
um
recommends if
when it's completed
did that helped
Public Utilities Commission is on the
list of speakers so that we can probably
get additional information there did you
have a follow-up representative McGee I
just had a thought that would be a
follow-up yes it it which is would it be
possible that this could be something
that could be a Public Utilities
Commission docket because they do study
commissions there all the time
um and maybe in this type of year it
would be easier to to authorize that
through this motion rather than try and
have it be something that's done in the
house right
we can ask them when they come up but
okay I'm gonna call her and find out
where Miss Martin is
when you've completed your questions for
me I'm all set thank you okay
thank you
chair recognizes Representative Vincent
for a question
thank you
um
Mr chairman
so I represent summersworth award two in
summersrath I'm very familiar with this
and my question is uh
in a 10 squat 10 square mile area in
Somersworth would you believe there's
over 200 duplicate poles
and Statewide more than 6
000 polls that are doubled in a state
would you believe that ma'am yes I would
thank you Representative Vincent I will
remind you that
we do not
accept would you believe questions for
Witnesses thank you very much Mr
chairman for that reminder I'll keep it
cognant thank you
thank you
all right seeing uh no more questions on
the list I'm now going to call the next
presenter who is
Diane Martin the chair of the Public
Utilities Commission so Ms Martin the
floor is yours
[Music]
thank you
good morning can you hear me
yes okay good
morning chairman Vose members of the
committee my name is Diane Martin I'm
the chairwoman of the Public Utilities
Commission it's nice to see you all
again so soon
uh representative gota asked me to
attend today to comment on the bill
for you
and the issue of polls in the rights of
way involves many interests which I
think the representative was just
alluding to
it involves the cities and towns the
state and different companies in
addition to the public utilities
some polls are owned by public utilities
and some are not
there are issues specifically related to
rights of way and there are issues
specifically related to utilities and
the facilities attached to polls related
to them
the jurisdiction for addressing those
issues currently lies with different
state agencies with the municipalities
and and towns and there's sort of a
mishmash of existing statutes out there
that need to be considered and taken
into account when coming up with the
best way to proceed to address these
issues
the legislation appears to have been
thoughtfully crafted to include the
parties that really need to be part of
that conversation
and and to get the right outcome from
this and so for those reasons I would
respectfully request that this bill
remain a study commission Bill and be
permitted to proceed despite the
pandemic and I know that's something
that is not happening routinely
um but I will say that the puc is happy
to assist in any way it can to make that
happen we regularly do
um WebEx proceedings and can certainly
facilitate that and I've been
participating in the offshore wind
commission which has been meeting
monthly remotely and it's worked really
well so I think it is possible and I
think that if there's one bill that
really should be able to proceed despite
the pandemic
because of the significance of this
issue and because of the multitude of
Interest parties and statutes that it
involves it would be this bill
thank you for your time and if you have
any questions I'm happy to answer them
thank you Ms Martin
um I see we have a question the chair
recognizes representative Kelly Pitts
for a question
thank you for taking my question I fully
agree that this is a problem and I've
been involved in a couple of them myself
but I wanted to ask you
do you believe that the puc can take
partial jurisdiction
over a private company and that's what
in many cases we are dealing with you
know we deregulated the telephone
company we we took them out of the
jurisdiction
cable companies and not under the on the
auspices of the puc or do you believe
that this commission would simply be to
get them all at the table and don't you
believe that that could do you believe
that that could be done
without a study Commission
it's loaded I know but there are a
couple pieces to that
um first I think that the puc has some
jurisdiction already related to poll
attachments which you're you're all
aware of
um and that
covers sort of the facilities related to
utilities that are on the polls which is
sort of separate from the issue of polls
themselves particularly if they don't
have
utility facility utility facilities or
other facilities on them if you just
have a poll in a right-of-way
um that poses sort of a different issue
um and the jurisdiction for that
really is with whoever owns the right of
way and there are current statutes right
now for towns and municipalities in my
prior role I used to represent the
department of transportation we often
encountered issues related to things in
the right-of-way that shouldn't be there
and took action and that was generally
in Superior Court and and was and can be
effective and effective quickly and so I
think the point is that there are
different interests here there are
already existing
um
statutes to address them but they are
not really
um working well together and so I think
the commission would would be well
served to be created and bring those
people together to address the bigger
picture but even more importantly to
make sure that the resulting statutes
um reflect each other in a way that
makes sense so that you know if it's a
poll in a right-of-way there's an action
that can be taken that's fairly Swift
versus a process that's related to
facilities on polls and moving those
which
um can sometimes tend to be lengthier
and more cumbersome so I I just think
that the commission that you have before
you brings the right people together and
that the puc is just a piece of the
puzzle
and the puc alone would not cover the
gamut of the issues that you guys are
looking to address
thank you
the chair recognizes representative
Thomas for a question thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um
does the BC currently have any rules
that sets a time limit
for the agencies that they do have
jurisdiction over to remove such polls
and if they do have have those times uh
limitations been met and if not are
there is there any enforcement mechanism
that can be done
our current jurisdiction really is
related to poll attachments and so
that's the the things that the wires and
the other things that you see on polls
and it really relates to
how and when those attachments can be
put onto polls and the jurisdiction is
actually pretty Limited in that
um once
they're they're supposed to be voluntary
agreements and so
um to the extent they can't be reached
then there is the ability to come to the
commission and ask for sort of a
resolution of the dispute if there can't
be an agreement
um
and so it doesn't really get into
all of the parts that you're looking at
which are more related or at least
um at least as related to just the
existence of polls in rights of way
which is
I think traditionally a right-of-way
issue
no follow-up needed apparently Ms Martin
I have a question we heard an earlier
testimony that
towns can and frequently do tax these
unused polls
is it possible that the tax
that the owner of the poll pays is less
than the cost of removing the pole even
over time
personally I don't I don't
I don't sit in that area
um and so I can't really tell you the
significance of the taxes and whether
that has an impact
okay I thank you for for that answer see
no more questions for Ms Martin I thank
you Miss Martin for being here this
morning and testifying on this bill
I will now call on the next speaker Mara
Weston who represents the New England
cable and Telecommunications Association
Ms Weston the floor is yours
good morning can you hear me
yes it's wonderful
um good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Maura Weston
and I'm testifying today on behalf of
the New England cable and
Telecommunications Association
in opposition to HB 169
my written testimony will be forthcoming
NAFTA is a five-state regional trade
Association representing substantially
all private cable telecommunications
companies in New Hampshire Connecticut
Massachusetts Rhode Island and Vermont
in New Hampshire nectar represents
Atlantic Broadband Charter and Comcast
our members Communications networks are
physically attached to the majority of
polls in New Hampshire virtually all of
them are owned either solely or jointly
between the electric and telephone
utilities
collectively our members serve more than
500 000 New Hampshire residential
commercial and public sector customers
with Broadband video voice mobile home
security and Automation Services
to be clear we don't oppose HP 169
because
we view this as a non-issue or concern
rather we come to the table believing
that the puc does in fact have Authority
Under the 1300 rules over poll
attachments
um we also believe that they have
Authority Under New Hampshire RSA 374-1
which establishes that every public
utility shall furnish such service and
facilities and shall be reasonably safe
and adequate and in all other respects
just and reasonable
so with all due respect to to
commissioner Martin I appreciate her
perspective about the complexity of
these issues
um we were going to speak this morning
to the fact that we actually believe the
puc has the statutory Authority the
administrative processes and the and the
expertise to ensure a balanced
well-informed stakeholder process
um in recent years the commission has
undertaken investigations into utility
pulse safety for example as well as rule
makings regarding poll attachments and
make-ready timelines and we in fact were
participants in the 1300 rulemaking
process
um and we recognize that the commission
continues to use its dispute resolution
authority to resolve conflicts between
poll owners and attachers as well as
municipalities and Pool owners
um we believe that given the complexity
of these issues that the POC would be
the most appropriate venue and again we
welcome a conversation with
um the commission
um and the stakeholders and
um
would welcome participation in any
stakeholder process with which results
preferably within the the commission
um so I'm I appreciate your time today
we're happy to work with you and again
we would urge that hb69 be voted in
expedient to legislate and we look
forward to working with you thank you
thank you Ms Weston for your testimony
are there any questions from Ms Weston
seeing none I will ask if it is
hand raised
sorry I didn't see it
uh well it's on my screen and recognized
to ask a question
thank you
thank you very much Mr chairman uh Miss
Weston um
I I understand your perspective here but
um
couldn't this be resolved unless
bureaucratic way uh couldn't your
members or your company's
voluntarily pledge that within a certain
time interval they will remove their
things from those polls without having
to have coercion or enforcement
certainly representative in fact our
members participate in a system and not
sure exactly what the acronym stands for
but it's known as engines which is a
system it's a a computer system that is
used to facilitate Communications among
in between
companies both the poll owners and the
attachers to facilitate
um the process and the most expedited
process
[Music]
that's uh that's realistic and that can
be managed so we do rely on a process
currently that we think actually should
remain the process and it has by and
large worked although we recognize that
the Dual poll issue you know is is there
but for our attachers the engines
process has worked well it is
um
uh essentially an agreement among
attachers and poll owners and
um we would be happy to to provide you
more information about that system and
uh perhaps engines could provide some
education as well
Representatives
follow-up yeah
yeah thank you Mr chairman well uh
having heard what Representative Vincent
just mentioned where we're talking about
thousands of poll double polls in a
small area and also that some of these
are there for years uh obviously your
process is not working
um well I I can't speak to those
specific instances
um Mike I could certainly get
information from my clients for you my
understanding is that engines has by and
large worked quite well over the years
and that yes there are situations where
there have been miscommunications or
where notification hasn't happened
through engines as it should have and
therefore unfortunate circumstances have
resulted
um
and so that is my limited knowledge of
where we have had issues that it has
resulted from a miscommunication through
that computer system where the next
attacher or the uh the attacher hasn't
notified the next attacher in line and
it was a Communications breakdown that's
my understanding and my knowledge and
again I'm happy to do more research for
you and uh have my clients input on that
thank you thank you uh representative
I'd remind you that we're here to gather
information not to debate with the
presenters representative Bernardi is
recognized for a question
thank you chairman both uh so this is a
question from for I think two presenters
here speak loudly because what I heard
is the last presenter say that the 1300
rule series of the puc provides
jurisdiction for the puc to take action
yet I heard the commission saying
they don't have the ability so
can there be a Reconciliation of that
point of view do we actually need
some action here in order to resolve
this
um
Mr chair is that question directed at me
Mara Weston or
would you like me to respond
that's a question this is Ms Weston okay
thank you
um
uh it's my client's position that
these issues could be addressed within
the current context of the puc's
authority and jurisdiction and existing
rules
um again with respect to commissioner
Martin as to the complexity of these
issues I certainly understand where
she's coming from but we believe that
the puc would be an appropriate venue
um for this conversation to unfold and
frankly that this legislation is not
necessary
you need a follow-up
s
chairman so then commissioner Martin do
you agree that you have the authority as
it's not been uh referenced
that question is directed at
commissioner Martin are you still there
commissioner
hi there sorry I had to be promoted
again so I could speak
um so the current Authority for the
commission relates to poll attachments
it's statutory Authority in RSA 374 34A
and our rules rely on that Authority
um and that and the rules the 1300 rules
also relate to poll attachments and
that's why my point was this is a
multi-part issue you have polls which
are in rights of way which may or may
not have facilities on them our rules
speak to
polls poll attachments and give us
Authority within that realm they are
somewhat limited as well in the the
definition in the statute which refers
to polls owned by public utilities and
for example Comcast is not a public
utility and so the polls would not be
subject they're polls owned by them
fully owned by them would not be subject
to the statute and so I I think that the
statement related to our Authority is
over Broad and I think that it um
it does not cover the entire issue which
relates to rights of way as well
thank you uh see no further questions
let me ask if there are any persons on
this in this meeting who have not signed
up to speak but would like to speak
yes
seeing none I will close the public
hearing on House Bill 169.
and reward everybody on the committee
with an extra eight minutes on your
lunch break representative momila did
you have a question
[Music]
on a duet I wanted to State something
I'm sorry if I don't really care anymore
but I wanted to State something for the
record uh regarding house billing okay
certainly go ahead oh thank you so much
basis
I
work it really comes down to I don't
think that it's fair or appropriate for
us to
take money away and start another fund I
agree with some of the comments that
representative Thomas made but I one of
the points I just wanted to state is
that I acknowledge that I may have
misunderstood the New Hampshire saves
program but I I do want to say that the
majority of the testimony time that we
had for questions the hard part of that
was that it was taken up really by kind
of teed up questions that just appeared
to validate the reason for the bill in
the first place and it really left no
time for German questions I really
wanted to talk about the answer stage a
little bit more and I had follow-up
questions and I I would have loved to
have been clarified on that and I just
wanted to kind of say that when we when
there's a lot of questions that right
off the clock that just validate the
bill it actually leads far less time
questions to clarify the bill thank you
so much thank you chair
thank you representative samchitzer
recognized for a question
um
remember the uh yes thank you Mr sp169.
thank you Mr chairman
it's just a a point of order here uh as
as I uh mentioned to you previously uh
since I have to testify uh at another
committee on a bill at one o'clock uh
you agree to postpone my bill to 130 is
that correct
I did agree to that and I appreciate you
reminding me of that uh skipping 3
6 I had forgotten that
okay I just want to know then then our
lunch break would go to 1 30 is that
correct
1 30. no we'll take up that Bill yes at
1 30 basically I mean Mr chairman I
think he's asking if we have an extended
lunch and now we're not coming back
until 1 30. yes
um
what I originally stated was that we
would open the hearing on your bill at
one o'clock
and then recess it until 1 30.
so to do that
at least I need to be in the room I
don't know if anybody else needs to be
in the room okay but we need to have the
recording going at one o'clock
um
so that we can we can recess uh
the bill
um
maybe we perhaps pick up the two o'clock
excuse me
who who wants to speak
oh I just wanted to clarify you need to
have someone there at one o'clock to
recess the hearing is that what you're
saying in which case may be represent
McGee could be there if you have to have
more than one person you don't need to
have
I think we just need you there
representative samsich to basically
introduce the bill
and then I can't do it I can't do it at
one o'clock
Representatives I'm sorry for
interrupting but I I think it's okay
um you can't open a bill early you can't
you can't open a two o'clock bill at one
o'clock but if you need to open the bill
late that's okay
which is the way it's been done and
recess the hair and you can open the
hearing and recess the hearing
you don't need anyone there to do that
okay the only one that you can do that
by yourself
okay now we're going to have half the
time for the hearing why can't we open
the hearing and have the sponsor present
his remarks at 1 30. you can
yes that's what we're going to do
but because it's
well I have a recess we have to open it
at one o'clock and then recess it until
1 30. I don't understand the need for a
recess we have so little time we just
had an explanation from one member that
she would have appreciated more time for
clarification
and
I I I don't think there's any I think
it's crazy we're gonna go just go from 1
30 to 2 and then slam that hearing into
even less time
doing this is a courtesy for
representative sausage
Mr chairman I I have no objection to uh
you opening the hearing at one o'clock
and allowing me then to come back at 1
30 to testify
chairman we will definitely allow you to
testify anytime you anytime you desire
okay well then then you don't need to
recess the hearing I'd say right
okay we'll let the other people who have
signed up to testify and that includes
uh representative oxenham and
uh news we'll let those two folks
testify first and and
people will ask them questions and maybe
by the time they're done you'll be back
and you can take over okay sounds very
good to me okay
we're doing this we're learning on the
fly as we as we do this so uh
we'll we'll do what we have to do to
make it work
all right so at this point uh
representative oxenham did you need to
say anything else or did you make the
point you were making wanted to make
I think I made my points thank you Mr
chairman
in that case uh let's adjourn for lunch
and return at one o'clock at which time
we will open the public hearing on HB 3
7 6. thank you very much everybody
appreciate your patience
just a reminder to everyone to mute your
audio and video
in the room mics
foreign
representative votes just a reminder to
the room if representative brezhny could
unmute the station by the television set
um when you guys are ready to be heard
that'll be great
hi Representative Vincent
hello representative Kelly Pitts how are
you good how are you
doing okay
hanging in there is that a water dog
that you had in your lap
this is my um radio hey come here come
here
she won't come over here come here
hi Sarah
yeah it's actually uh uh a shih tzu it's
yeah
it's a it's a purebred
the dog only gets to be so big and it's
very nice dog it's they're bred to love
people and that's what she is she's a
little intimidated by this
by my iPad
I wish I was bred the same way
oh that's funny that is actually that's
that's good
that that's not not a laughing matter
thank you
nice to see everybody
no we can't see you Jackie where are you
are we intimidating you Representative
Vincent
no just some people put words in my
mouth and change them around that's all
Janine that's not what it is
I've got chocolate in my pocket you
can't have any you're just a face on a
screen
and I can't hear I'm deaf I have hearing
loss so I'm going to plug this in
[Music]
so Kim had a list of 300 of babies and
this is only 14. I don't know what I'm
missing
so she told me I was being put on one
that has something to do with historical
there's one on monuments
okay it's one o'clock so good afternoon
everyone and welcome back to
day one of public hearings for the
science technology and energy committee
we have three bills to look at
this afternoon
or maybe four uh no I forgotten but uh
it is three okay three bills to look at
this afternoon
and uh we're going to uh
start
by opening the public hearing on House
Bill 376
which is a bill that establishes a
committee to study the applications of
micro grids in New Hampshire and changes
in the law necessary to allow for
microgrids in electricity Supply
Prime sponsor is Peter representative
Peter samstrich
he will not be available to speak on the
bill until approximately 1 30.
so I'm going to ask representatively
oxenham who's also a sponsor on the bill
I believe or maybe not uh anyway so she
has signed up to speak so I'm going to
ask representative oxenham to take the
floor and give us her best shot at
explaining what this bill is all about
and I particularly appreciate
representative oxenham if you could
explain to us why we need
a study committee for micro grids since
microgrids is a part of the public
utilities committee's
commissions
docket on
what's the talking about the docket on
grid modernization so help us understand
why we need a study committee to study
microgrids and take it away
don't forget to unmute yourself please
thank you very much
and thank you for allowing me to go
first uh I had my hand up I wanted to
ask a question about the the process
before we began
and in particular
um I wanted to know if anyone had
provided written testimony on this bill
as I understood it
we were being compelled to keep our
public hearings within one hour but we
were supposed to be getting written
testimony on which we were supposed to
rely for these proceedings I've received
no testimony
as regards this bill and very little
testimony on preceding bills
I'm going to let representative Thomas
answer that question
yes representative Austin as far as I
know I received
three written testimonies at least as of
12 o'clock last night
on HB 376 one of them came from
representative sausage
one comes from the New Hampshire tumor
Association Mr stock
and what comes from you
so that's all I have in my position
right now
so there was nothing from Consolidated
Communications
well they're not even on the list
nothing that came to my email that I
printed out anyway and I uh I tried my
best to hold off but I had to go to
sleep
thank you thank you for that
clarification
um
if if I could proceed uh then directly
into a discussion of the bill
we ran into difficulties this morning
with people not understanding the
content of the bill so I'm actually
going to begin by quote it's a very very
short bill and I'll take you to the
duties section the committee shall study
the applications of microgrids in New
Hampshire
and changes in law necessary to allow
for micro good grids in electricity
Supply with a view to both near-term and
long-term applications in the state
for this purpose the committee shall
consult with representatives of utility
companies companies involved with
microgrid development and members of the
general public with specific knowledge
regarding microgrids and their benefits
as well as obstacles to their deployment
um moving to my own testimony
microgrids offer a crucial Safeguard
against emergency situations you know I
and I think I think I was relying on
Peter to have gone first so let me stop
there and and just give a brief
definition of what a microgrid is
and the best example I can give is the
one that I actually used in my testimony
which is Princeton University during
superstorm Sandy the electrical supply
system in New Jersey was devastated
people went prolonged periods without
electricity which meant not only no
lights but no water supply no ability to
flush toilets it was a it was a major
disaster for that state and surrounding
states however Ray of good light
Princeton University had a microgrid
they were able to run classes provide
meals have dorms with air conditioning
and their students were able to pursue
their studies scientists were able to
pursue their work teachers were able to
teach so migrid's in short are subsets
of the electrical system that can be
isolated or islanded to preserve and
protect the supply of electricity within
the island
and when there's no need for islanding
they can be part of the
um the larger grid
okay and uh Peter in his testimony
provided a definition from the U.S
department of energy
um which I imagine
um he will refer to when he comes back
so back to my testimony where I uh
described the Delights of Princeton
University's survival in the face of
disaster and uh support the notion that
this would be a very good idea in New
Hampshire particularly for disasters as
with climate crisis impending we're
going to see more floods we're going to
see more wildfires we're going to see
more heavy precipitation events which
lead to communities being cut off
sometimes losing both uh their access to
lights water in the wintertime that can
be heat in the summertime it can be air
conditioning
for medical centers loss of electricity
can mean loss of lives
in the Town of Plainfield where I live a
microgrid could easily be established
which would connect our emergency
services our fire police our town
offices with our our elementary school
which can serve as an emergency shelter
we have one store in town it could also
be on a very small isolated Loop no more
than five miles in length
and as a result of that we could have
access to the silver array at the school
we also have Kimball Union Academy
within that Loop which has wind power as
well as solar power we could be a an
access area for surrounding communities
to come to in an emergency situation so
in short micro grids can be life-saving
the military uses them extensively to
cut off a base to protect its Supply and
also for cyber security reasons
um and
I think that's about
no the question that you asked me uh
chairman Bose I knew there was something
else I was supposed to get to why have a
study committee when there's a grid mod
well gridma has been going on for five
years
and we're not getting any closer
so I I think that this this is something
that we can do in a short term but it is
complicated as so many of the issues
that come before this committee are and
getting having an opportunity for
stakeholders to work together to bring
the utilities in I'm sure there are
reasons why in some areas it's difficult
to Island a segment of the grid
um we need to understand what what that
means would there be a need for State
investment would there be a need for
other other measures that could make it
possible for towns to have access to
this life-saving technology and I'll
take questions
thank you representative oxendum
I saw a hand up earlier but now it goes
representative Thomas is recognized for
a question
thank you chairman uh thank you for
taking my question
um my only question is
I seem to have remembered that a bill
like this was submitted before not
tomorrow maybe the last couple years
um can you refresh my memory if this is
the same type of Bill or is there
something different because something
didn't get done or what was the impetus
behind this this particular committee
bill
excellent question I I do recall that we
had a prior bill on microgrids and as I
recall I did not research this prior to
our hearing as I recall it was merged
with another bill that was on a somewhat
related subject
and that's about as far as my memory is
taking me
um does anyone else on the committee who
was here in the last session recall what
happened with that bill was it rolled
into an Omnibus or
you know I perhaps uh the the sponsor
when he does arrive I will recall
because I believe he may well have been
the sponsor on that bill as well
follow up thank you Mr chair uh and uh
and can you also verify it's kind of
fuzzy but I I thought that bill did pass
our committee at the time uh to remember
if it did and then it got emerged
somewhere else
I believe we merged it and it passed our
committee but that's my recollection and
it's not based on Research
thank you my recollection is that uh
the bill was merged with some
Omnibus Bill from the Senate that got
vetoed and the veto was sustained that's
my memory but I could it could be wrong
but I think that's the reason we see it
again here well if it got that far it
must have come out of our committee with
a positive recommendation yeah I think
okay
the chair recognizes representative
Bernardi for a question
thank you chairman
representative remember to speak loudly
I I would like more detail on why this
bill is necessary uh given the grid
modernization program
and you mentioned that it's going on but
you didn't say what specifically this is
going to do what the timing of this is
going to be as over the grid
modernization
between efforts here
oh
two two questions the first one is why
go ahead with this while grid mod is
still proceeding and the second one was
um are we duplicating efforts uh highly
related yeah
so the problem with grid mod is that
it's an enormous issue with you know and
correct me if I'm wrong here cat
hundreds of interlocking interwoven
moving parts and there are many actors
who have a stake in not going forward
with one element here or one element
there so that this particular technology
is being held hostage even though it has
broad support
um and yeah that's that's really the
point this has broad support it's being
held hostage to other things which are
much more controversial and this was
seen as a way to there's no necessity
for it to wait for everything to go
forward it can be it can be islanded it
can be segregated from that entire
revamping and re-understanding and
recasting of how electricity is provided
with grid mud
do you need a follow-up representative
I know we have one member of the public
happy to try
it was raised before some of the other
hands that I see raised I'm going to
call on The Honorable march shepherdson
to ask a question
thank you very much Mr chairman
I just um I remember talking about this
a few years ago
and um everyone seems to agree that it's
a a good thing to have that you should
be able to
have some place like Princeton or a
small town center separate itself during
times of Crisis especially and that it
can be a great asset to that town or
that college or whatever
entity has done this
provides safety much in the same way
that homeowners can have a generator in
their garage this would be a way to say
well if we need to we can separate
ourselves from the grid and still
provide Power
I don't see why we would not go forward
knowing that as representative oxenham
said it's it's part of a larger bill
that has other more controversial pieces
it's not getting dealt with on an
untimely manner why would we not go
forward with this I strongly urge you to
do this thank you
I should point out to new members that
uh former representative Marge
shepardson served with great Distinction
on science technology and energy for for
many years and thank you very much for
the call in Marge and I agree why not
this is this is an opportunity to do
something and uh we can we can really
make a contribution to our communities
that I think we can all take home and
talk to our constituents and be proud of
I thank you as well
uh former representative shepherdson for
calling it it was nice to hear from you
chair now recognizes representative
Jackie Pitts for a question I believe Mr
I believe Lucius was ahead of me
how can you tell that I'm looking
because his hand went up before
[Music]
I will yield to him if you come back
okay I'm happy to yield Jackie go ahead
uh representative Pitts please go ahead
um Marge I just wanted to ask do you
believe that this microgrid system
could be a cooperation between Homeland
Security
and
what we want to do and that it should
move forward under even a federal
Administration and I'm going to follow
that with do you remember the ice storm
that we had where people were weeks
without power and that also means that I
found out the hard way
can't go to the gas pump if there's no
electricity so I I just wondered if you
felt maybe there could be a connection
there
between Homeland Security and and
planning
thank you um for that other question I
certainly do remember the ice storm it
was difficult here too we had
people from all over town going down to
Main Street to The Community House the
only place around that had power so they
could charge their phones and get water
to drink and so forth so it was
difficult and uh
I
don't know about linking it in with
Homeland Security I would think it would
be a logical uh discussion to have
it's certainly um a safety issue in my
mind
if I could also try to answer the a part
of that with the
large-scale Federal funding that's going
to be coming available
oxenham I didn't recognize you to speak
I the the question
yes uh
Mr chair the question was originally for
Lee
I I didn't think we were asking
questions with the public so
my fault didn't think we were either but
I let you
check for you may I
Mr chairman
representative oxenham I'll get back to
you in just a second
representative partial has been waiting
to ask a question I want to recognize
him
well again I'll be glad to defer if uh
this is the following a line of
questioning I'm happy to do that
speaking
thank you very much
um yes I'm no expert on homeland
Security's jurisdiction however I do
know that there are going to be
substantial federal funds available if
the bill currently before the Congress
is indeed passed out and they may well
um have we here in New Hampshire our
towns and municipalities May well have
an opportunity to have
investments in things which relate to
Homeland Security and disaster
preparedness and uh recovery from
disasters because if we have something
that's as they call it shovel ready to
the extent that we would have a bill
that we could get through and towns
could be working on actual plans when
those monies are made available that
they're looking for places to be put to
work when I was in Baltimore I was
working on dam removal and we had a damn
that we were all ready to go but there
was no funding when 2008 2009 happened
and they were looking for shovel ready
projects boom that Dam went to the front
of the line and it was removed so I
think we have an opportunity here to to
do things that could save our taxpayers
money by being available for the federal
funding and by linking microgrids as
they well should be to issues of
disaster preparedness and uh Homeland
Security
thank you Lee
thank you representative partial you're
now recognized for what thank you so
much I appreciate that chair
um I am looking at a letter here and we
were speaking about letters of support
before and this is from New Hamburg
Timberland Owners Association in support
of this bill
um I don't think I'm the only one who
have received this though
why this would like that included with
the testimony
testimonies it was
it was several different
simultaneously yeah it was yeah
yeah my error and not including it
okay
um and uh I also have a observation I
guess you'd say
um
in New Hampshire I don't believe even
have a legal definition of what concepts
a micro grid and I can see where that
could contribute to uncertainty about uh
innovators who want to get into uh
microgrid who
uh who are fearful of What legislation
may be enacted after the fact they're in
it so I would think that nothing else a
study group would allow us to establish
what constitutes a micro Grid in New
Hampshire this is why you support this
bill
thank you
thank you representative
um
on the issue of written testimony I have
to let you all know that David Muse who
is about to be recognized to speak did
submit written testimony about
a half hour ago so that it should be in
your inbox when you get a chance to
Peru's said inbox
so with that I would like to now
recognize uh representative David Muse
to speak floor is yours sir
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'm going to be
brief because I realized the purpose of
this hearing uh is to determine whether
or not to form a study committee and not
to actually start the study itself
um I'm basically supporting this bill
because like the rest of us I live in a
state that doesn't have any oil well
uh we don't have any coal mines we don't
have any natural gas fields and for the
most part I think we find ourselves
completely at the mercy of other states
when it comes to our energy supplies and
especially the supplies of fossil fuels
we learned a very hard lesson back in
the 1970s that Supply shocks are not
only possible they're extremely probable
in a world where much of our energy
Supply needs to travel very long
distances to actually get here to New
Hampshire
um according to one of the better
definitions that I've seen
microgrids are basically self-contained
electrical grids that can operate as an
Island Independent of a central power
grid
um in communities like mine uh
microgrids are intriguing
um we have a downtown area uh that it
would be wonderful if there was a way to
uh essentially protect and preserve the
ability of our businesses to operate in
a natural disaster that's that's where
um that's where a lot of our downtown
area fuels much of our economy and
growth we have a huge area of medical
centers over near Portsmouth Hospital
not only in the hospital itself but
there is there are a slew of different
uh Medical Office Buildings uh and it's
extremely important uh that uh that
those facilities uh uh you know have an
under uninterrupted power supply I think
it's also extremely important because as
we don't have those uh those coal mines
and those cast fields and things like
that what we do have is a renewable
energy business uh in in New Hampshire
uh we have people who are in the
business of providing wind energy and
solar energy
um and while microgrids can actually be
made up completely of fossil fuel
producers
um much of the attraction is the fact
that they can also be made up of folks
who are producing renewable energy
which saves greenhouse gases and and
solves a bunch of other problems they
also help solve the issue of loss of
power along long transmission lines and
I think representative partial raised a
a great uh issue when he when he noted
that we don't even have a legal
definition of what a micro grid is in
New Hampshire
um according to the Center for uh
climate and Energy Solutions uh there
are other legal barriers that states
like our space
um including laws that might limit uh or
prohibit specific activities
um laws that might increase the cost of
doing business online uh for for those
trying to create micro grids
um and also there's just the uncertainty
that anyone who goes ahead and tries to
implement one of these things might
actually find restrictions imposed on
them in additional costs imposed later
once we get our act together and figure
out exactly what we want to do with
microgrids and and how we want to
regulate and how we promote them so I
think the study committee would be a
great way to get the bulb rolling to
educate the legislature and to also
educate members of the public about how
we can benefit from this solution
thank you
thank you representative
I assume Representative Sam said that
you're not you're raised hand is not to
ask a question but just to notify us
that you are back in the in the meeting
that is correct Mr chairman yes okay
thank you are there any questions for uh
representative Muse
seeing none I will turn the floor over
to representative samsich so that he can
give us his testimony on this bill
thank you very much Mr chairman uh
obviously since I wasn't here to listen
to what other people have said uh I
might be repeating a couple things but I
just have a few brief oral uh comments
uh you've already received received a
testimony from me and you can take a
look at that but this is just very
briefly
um just as a comment about the
definition of microgrids it is correct
that we don't have one here in New
Hampshire right now however
military bases such as the Portsmouth
Naval Shipyard have been microgrids for
a long time they can operate on their
own even when the grid goes down that's
one of the requirements that they've
they've hardened their their energy
Supply and right now UNH is working
together with eversource and some other
utilities to create a micro grid for the
University of New Hampshire so that's
just two examples of what's going on
right right now in New Hampshire
so um
I think in addition to providing the
larger municipalities in our town a way
to incorporate some of their local
energy generation into a system that
provides local citizens and with local
power at an attractive cost even smaller
towns could be considered can consider a
Cooperative microgrid with neighboring
communities that would offer more
economic opportunities for all
municipalities involved a more resilient
and a more reliable power system in the
case of weather events and a way to
control the town's energy costs in the
future as was mentioned before uh
microvision contain both fossil fuel
generation and renewable energy
generation so uh as as that grid
develops one replaces equipment with
another and also uh
adjacent communities can decide that
they don't need all the backup power
they have in case of
urgency but they could help each other
out if they need backup power by re
removing some redundancies
uh but both small and large communities
would benefit if we could figure out
what what areas benefit a small versus a
larger town and identify those and
that's the purpose of a study
and remember microgrids are operating
behind the meter so basically uh they
are reducing Demand on the primary grid
and therefore they're reducing the need
for additional expensive Transportation
transmission infrastructure
so these would be savings that all
customers of a particular utility would
benefit by and even the whole state of
New Hampshire so thank you very much
those are the only comments I have and
I'm glad to take any questions
for
such
representative Sanchez can you describe
to us or explain to us what is the
difference between a micro grid
and a group net metering group
uh thank you Mr chairman for that
question I think that's an outstanding
question uh and I think uh part of the
problem with not defining what a
microgrid is is that you probably don't
want to Define it too too rigorously uh
for example in um in the in Brooklyn New
York uh uh several streets got together
to create a solar microgrid where some
of the residents had solar installations
on their roofs and others didn't but
that Community got together to invest in
putting those solar energy on the roofs
and now they're sharing both the
benefits and the costs so as far as net
metering is concerned
um I think that is exactly the kind of
issues that need to be worked out with a
utility because the utilities have to be
part of anything such as a microgrid uh
and in fact maybe they are the ones on
contract operating the microgrid for a
community so I think those are
unresolved issues but they are important
ones and that's exactly why I think a
study a committee would be useful
[Music]
representative assumptions yeah
three years ago the stne committee went
to UNH to look at their
[Music]
a power plant
on the campus at unh
[Music]
ired uh
power plant I believe and
I think I guess it was just gas but
anyway
um
that's when we first learned about the
the project to create a micro grid
uh on the University campus and at that
meeting we were told that uh part of the
delay in making progress on creating
that micro grid was the cost that was
extremely expensive to create a micro
grid
you recall that discussion and do you
remember why
it was reported to be costing so much to
create that microgram
uh thank you Mr chairman for that
question uh I was also on that tour as
you mentioned and um I don't recall that
specific discussion at least not very
clearly
um and if you know if you're a member of
the the gas that they were getting at
UNH was coming actually from the
landfill it was landfill gas otherwise
referred to often as a renewable natural
gas
and uh so
yeah well yeah it's methane but it came
not from a pipeline somewhere it came
from their landfill
uh and um so in addition to that I
assumed that they also planned other
measures including Energy Efficiency and
perhaps other sources of energy
generation and to be honest I haven't
kept abreast of what the progress is
there uh so I can't really report to you
uh on that uh but um I'm sure you know
um anything like this first of all it's
a novel idea in New Hampshire and
secondly
um you know uh the the The Upfront cost
for something like this are are are not
uh small however they do provide
long-term benefits so I think the idea
with UNH is that if they could incl
create such a micro grid they will have
more flexibility later on to integrate
new sources and more efficient sources
of energy that they can generate
themselves uh in the form of solar or uh
methane gas from landfill and so forth
so I think these are really interesting
ideas that need to be fleshed out and
it's not the model that's used for UNH
is a different model than let's say
would be used up in the North Country if
if a couple of small towns got together
they would need other other ways of
doing things
thank you representative samcich for
refreshing my memory that the UNH power
plant gets regular natural gas from
Unitil in addition to getting landfill
gas from
the big landfill of an upper history
they have two different burners in their
power plant yeah because the uh the
methane they get from the
the landfill is actually cleaner and
purer than the natural gas they get from
Unitil I remember that now
and I appreciate your your memories of
that trip unfortunately it was long
enough ago that I don't have real clear
memories but it does seem to me that
what UNH is doing constitutes a research
project on microgrids
and so that it would seem to me that
there would be a lot to learn from what
they are doing and presumably
discovering as they try to implement
this
okay are there any additional questions
for
representative samsich I see none here
excuse me Mr chairman one more comment
remember
uh one of the companies working on um
with UNH is uh
TRC a a nationally renowned uh micros
micro micro grid company that's actually
has its headquarters here in Portsmouth
so that we have some some local
companies in New Hampshire that have
already created microgrids in other
states besides here
okay thank you for that reminder chair
recognizes uh representative closure for
a question thank you Mr chairman thank
you thank you representatives for your
presentation speak loudly
speak loudly
I was just about to ask that question if
has any entities identified themselves
in favor of the microgrid idea and
opposed to it do you know of any
to this idea of Michael gritty
a question for me
representative yes
um well
um in New Hampshire like I said we don't
have really any good examples except UNH
right now as as chairman mentioned it's
more of a research project and it's very
appropriate to do it at the University
that has a lot of research uh asset so
we don't have any good examples in this
in this state however uh the company TRC
that I mentioned is creating a micro
grid on Long Island in New York uh for a
town of 50 000 residents uh and that's
just one example of a project that
they're working on Nationwide so there
are many projects working uh and the met
and the incidentally the the thing I
mentioned before with the Brooklyn solar
solar energy microgrid uh they actually
are using uh blockchain technology as a
protection so they can accurately charge
and and charge the price that they're
gaining from solar to each each
shareholder on that so this is a process
that gives an opportunity to look at new
technologies that can be incorporated
but in New Hampshire we have very few
examples yeah
representative project a follow-up yes
thank you Mr chairman on that
um would not wouldn't not the microgrid
work in unison with the existing RSA 53e
[Music]
Community power Aggregates if it makes
its own power and can
provide it
thank you
thank you for that question I I think
you're right I think there is there is a
lot of synergy there and I see a a
strong connection to that
um
uh
so
the part of the reason I suggested this
study is to look at the elements we
already have in in the state as far as
legislation and to also see what
opportunities there are in small and
large communities and to come up with
some ideas where things seem appropriate
and where they might work so yeah I
think you're right
thank you the chair recognizes
representative Kelly Pitts for a
question my question was going to be the
same what's the uh maybe a little tiny
different what's the difference between
Municipal energy Community energy and
microgrid to me they seem the same
thank you uh representative Kelly Pitts
I agree with you
thank you
representative McGee is recognized for a
question
don't forget to unmute yourself please
[Music]
I'm wrong representative samsich but I
think
concept of microgrids is around the
concept of resiliency which is why the
issue of security came up when we were
first discussing it I'm not sure if you
were back in the room at that time
my understanding of the community power
piece is that people who want to invest
individually will be able to pull their
resources so that if they're all
producing a little bit of energy they
can be in some way pulled together so
that they can leverage the benefits of
the sum total of the energy that they're
creating so that's my sort of Layman's
interpretation of the distinctions
between the two it wouldn't be that you
wouldn't also have a bunch of small
plants that would be aggregated together
but it's that the purpose and the design
of the microgrid is that it be able to
stand on its own if the if the utility
grid was not available and I think that
that's a distinction because I'm not
sure that all the aggregators that are
working in communities
go into it with that particular end goal
in mind so that I would see that as the
distinction between those two and
Municipal just means that the
aggregation is being done at the Town
level versus some other form of
groupings
and that's how I that's how I try to
distinguish it and I just want to know
if that's correct or if there's
something else I don't understand
no thank you thank you representative
for that question and that that uh I
think that's a good clarification uh in
community power uh uh projects those
could be projects that are are dependent
on the grid and cannot disconnect from
the grid uh but they're they're they're
being operated uh as a separate entity
however they can't really Island
themselves independently so that's
probably the main distinction that you
can do you can be independent of the
Grid or you or you have to depend on the
grid
okay thank you for that answer
the chair recognizes representative Lee
oxenham for a question
yes and on a similar line uh asking for
clarification Peter I think that notion
of islanding is critical so group net
metering also has nothing to do with
being islanded from the Grid it's
dependent upon using the grid am I
correct there
yeah I totally agree
thank you
I thought you were somebody else with
their hand up but that doesn't appear to
be the case
so it appears we have
no more questions
oh no more hands up so
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative my question uh just for
clarification
yeah I apologize for not having that
particular particular bill in
this commission uh part of this member
should be include any of the utilities
and if not I believe we heard testimony
some years ago that the war one of the
utilities
are or know about microgrids and are
working on some on their own can you
extract that and how that would play
into being on his commissions
okay
uh thank you representative Thomas for
the question uh I just want to clarify
it's not a commission it's a committee
study committee and
as I wrote it initially it does not
specifically mention
the utilities but I am
first of all I totally would would think
that the utilities have to be part of
this project and I would be open to
amending the membership to include them
for sure because we need them
Thomas
just a follow-up are you aware if they
are or aren't acting on any of my groups
at the present time at all for your
lawyer
if they are having plans at all
I'm sorry representative Thomas I didn't
quite hear you
I'm sorry I said are you aware if if the
utilities are
knowledgeable and are perhaps working on
some long-range plants or microgreens on
their own
um I I thank you representative for the
question I I must say I I don't know for
sure I've had conversations with several
of them and uh all of them seem to be
interested in the idea and I haven't
heard any pushback against it uh but I
haven't heard also that they had any
particular plans
especially yeah
thank you representative samsuch as we
mentioned before UNH is involved with
eversource in researching microgrids at
the University
and so are there any more questions from
any of the members here in the room
I see no more questions from those
online so I would like to
read the blue sheet and I have received
a request
that I not only list the numbers on the
blue sheet but read the names on the
blue sheet so I will attempt to do that
so for this bill there were seven who
signed in in support zero who signed in
in opposition and zero who signed in as
neutral
the person signing in in support were
Peter samsich Lee oxenham David Moose
Joan Hamlet Jason stock Susan Richmond
and Eric Rathburn
the only one of those folks who was not
representing him or herself was Jason
stock who reference represents the New
Hampshire Timberland Association
so with that reading of the blue sheet
I'm going to close the public hearing
a house bill 376.
I would like to convene an executive
session
and I would like to recognize
representative Nick white for a motion
thank you chair I would like to make the
motion that we retain this bill
representative white moves that we
retain House Bill 376
the chair recognizes representative cam
grills
thank you Mr chair uh I would like to
second that motion
it has been moved and seconded that we
retain House Bill 376
is there any discussion
see none I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll
all right
bill number 376
representative Thomas yes
representative Harrington
representative Harry
yes
representative NADA yeah
representative
Home Alone yes
Mr Clark could you suspend for a moment
yeah
representative Harrington could you turn
on yours your video camera briefly so we
can verify that that was you who voted
yes
okay thank you very much
a new resume representative bresney
yes
representative bernati yes
representative chambrose yes
representative yes
representative white yes
representative samsich
yes
representative Kelly Pitts yes
representative men
yes
representative oxenham
representative Vinson
yes
representative McGee
no
representative McWilliams
creation
representative Christian
no
no you can get a ride or no no
yes on the pronunciation no on routine
no okay
representative Pimentel
and thank you
yes yes on retained
and representative paschall
well
no no
okay sure and the chairman uh
representative Rose
yes I'm retained
okay
17-4 will be the vote
so by a vote of 17 to four the bill is
retained and we will take it up later in
the
session here
so thanks to everyone for participating
in this public hearing
we will now take a brief
nine or ten minute recess
and then we'll start the new public
hearing on House Bill 624
thanks everyone
can go upstairs and send you an email
Phyllis would you like me to mute the
room
yes please
thank you
Christmas
14 ounce vacuum one hallway
yes good afternoon and welcome back
everyone
I would like to now open the
public hearing on House Bill 624
and since I am the prime sponsor of that
bill I will introduce it to the
committee
in 2020
Senator Ruth Ward and I co-sponsored a
bill that was introduced to the Senate
that was essentially the substance of
the bill you see before you here today
the Senate uh energy and resources
committee passed that bill uh with a an
amendment
and then the full Senate basket on a
Voice vote
and they were about to send it to the
house when
covid-19 interrupted the natural flow of
legislative activity
that bill which was called SB 626 was
briefly added to one of the Omnibus
Senate bills
but at some point it got extracted from
that bill and was eventually tabled
so I have reintroduced the bill this
year as House Bill 624
essentially what this bill does is it
lowers the fee for a declaratory ruling
from the site evaluation committee from
either ten thousand five hundred dollars
or three thousand dollars depending on
whether it's heard by the full committee
or a subcommittee to 250 dollars
that was the
dollar figure established by the Senate
and their amendment to Senate Bill 626
last year
I decided to keep that dollar amount the
original Bill actually lowered it to a
hundred dollars but since the Senate
thought it was 250 was a good number we
decided to keep that number
now the reason for lowering the price of
a declaratory ruling
was to make the site evaluation
committee
process more accessible to the General
Public
at a price of either ten thousand or
three thousand dollars getting a
declaratory ruling from the commission
was prohibitively expensive for the
average person
and it was the police of Senator Ward
and myself and several other folks who
you will hear from later today
that in order to make the site
evaluation committee process
transparent and to
ensure that the public can trust the
process
the public needs access to the process
and so lowering the price for a
declaratory ruling
uh
was a way to make that happen
now what is a declaratory ruling
basically a declaratory ruling request
from the site evaluation committee
a judgment about some serious question
about an energy citing certificate
these certificate comes with terms and
conditions and typically a
question might arise about whether the
terms and conditions are being
followed and met by the owner of the
certificate
and so
as you will hear in later testimony this
morning or this afternoon
there are
occasions when the certificate of a
particular energy
project
is questioned as to whether or not its
terms and conditions are being met
I took advantage of the
opportunity
of introducing this bill to also make a
couple of clarifications to the language
of the bill to indicate that it is the
responsibility of the sign evaluation
committee to judge whether or not
and the energy sighting certificates
terms and conditions are being met and
followed
the language of the
statute prior
led to some confusion about whether or
not the administrator of the site
evaluation committee could make
judgments about whether a terms and
conditions were being followed
it is our belief that the administrator
of the SEC can gather information about
terms and con conditions can register
or gather the complaints about
any such terms or conditions but can't
pass judgment on whether or not those
terms and conditions are being followed
that's something that only the full site
evaluation committee should do
so the bill makes a couple of small
adjustments to the language
or in the statute
to clarify
that
it is the full site evaluation committee
that ensures the terms and conditions of
sort of a certificate are being met so
if you look at the bill on line four and
we added the words the committee
to clarify in that sentence that it is
the committee that does this work and
then on line 22 you'll
see that we deleted the words or the
administrator as designee
from the sentence that uh talks about
who can determine whether any term or
condition of a certificate is being
violated
so those changes to the statute language
will clarify that it is in fact the site
evaluation committee
has the responsibility for determining
if the terms and conditions of a site
certificate are being met
now there is a larger issue which I'm
sure you will hear about in a moment
because
the chair of the site evaluation
committee who also happens to be the
chair of the Public Utilities Commission
Diane Martin will testify in in just a
few minutes on this bill
and
in her testimony you'll likely hear that
the site evaluation committees
funding situation is
apparently not that sound
the way the site evaluation committee
gets its funding right now is when I
application is made for a site
certificate
the committee can impose substantial
fees on the applicant to do the work
that's necessary to determine if the
certificate is a valid one
but once the certificate is awarded
there doesn't appear to be a lot of
additional funding available to enforce
the terms and conditions of the
certificate
and
the high price of declaratory rulings
was one of the ways that the committee
made up of that lack of funding
so it seems to me that further
reform is needed of the
site evaluation committee process to
provide for funding
to deal with issues that arise after a
certificate is issued
and I trust that Ms Martin will
elucidate on that issue
it was outside the scope and the purview
of this bill
possibly if we pass it here and it moves
on to the Senate that is you could
address there but for now
all we address in this issue in this uh
in this bill in this legislation is the
issue of making the site evaluation
process more trustworthy by allowing
access of the public to the process
so that's my uh explanation of what this
bill is all about and I'll be happy to
take questions from
members of the committee
representative Bernardi is recognized
for a question
thank you Mr chairman
the past how many
declaratory rulings
how big this
happen is
in testimony before the Senate last year
the then administrator site
administrator
administrator of the site evaluation
committee
Pamela Martin or Pamela
I've got her name now but the then
administrator testified that there had
been three
request for declaratory ruling since
2015.
just three
representative Presley thank you Mr
chairman what was the original reason
that the fee was set so high
I've heard a couple of reasons for that
one of the reasons I heard was to
discourage nuisance requests for a
declaratory ruling
but
there have been no nuisance requests
made as of this date
another reason I heard is because they
need the excited evaluation committee
needs the money
to fund
to fund dealing with
the aftermath of a
warded certificate
but maybe Miss Martin can shed some
light on that
any other questions
representative Thomas
do you happen to know maybe we'll hear
it from his apartment you have to know
how much effort is involved and
going through the dictionary really
talking
months and months of Manpower or
something that's relatively
well I think it requires the committee
to be convened and to hold at least one
meeting maybe multiple meetings to come
to some kind of a resolution sometimes
the committee can also be required to
hire
an outside expert to evaluate
the question being asked or the
complaint being filed so it could be
a simple situation or it could be a
complex one
either way uh
nobody will be able to to access or a
few people will be able to access the
committee if the fee stays at ten
thousand or three thousand dollars
any further questions from folks in the
room here
see none I will attempt to figure out
who raise their hand first here it looks
like
representative samsich is recognized for
a question
yes thank you Mr chairman
um so we just heard that um
that the number of requests is 2015 was
three
so that means you only get one of those
things every two years
I can't see how that would be much
funding if funding is an issue then I
could see that you know we're lowering
it to a price where people might be
willing to take advantage of it more
frequently that would certainly give you
more funding so I
I I I'm a little perplexed about whether
it is the funding issue or or whether
it's the nuisance issue
um
do you have any idea what what the main
what the primary motivator was for the
higher fee I mean I I don't know
the first response I got when I asked
that question was to discourage nuisance
yeah
issues
so I'm sure miss Martin will help us
with that when she testifies in just a
few minutes
past representative Kelly Pitts is
recognized for a question
don't forget to unmute
I just don't want you to hear me
breathing
um the site evaluation committee
permit is Akin in my mind simplistic
little building permit
and the people who
follow these things
if they notice that
they don't believe that that the
conditions of this building permit are
being adhered to you can't is there
anybody you can go to and complain about
this without filing a ten thousand
dollar fee
if I understand your question correctly
representative and thank you for that
question
you're asking is there a cheaper way to
get a resolution of a of a question or a
complaint
and right they're an appeal process
I I believe the answer is no
part of what a site certificate terms
and conditions provide is guidance about
the day-to-day operation of the energy
facility and as we'll hear in testimony
that's coming up from some other folks
one of the
energy facilities that has been causing
some issues with some folks is the
Antrim Wind Facility
oops I turned off my mic I'm sorry
keeping my finger on the button is
probably a bad idea so
as I was I forgot exactly when I turned
the button off but as I was trying to
say we'll hear and testimony later this
this afternoon about some problems with
the antrum Wind Facility and that will
maybe be illustrative of
what can happen when a a site
certificate terms and conditions are not
being
or are suspected of not being followed
so I hope that answers your question
almost
do you want to elaborate well I I just I
you know I can't believe that or I'm
having a hard time believing that there
is no process by which
these people and I I've been up to the
antrum when why they can't
there's nobody that they can go to to
appeal this either the puc or the the
there must be some oversight at the uh
at at the site evaluation committee they
issue these permits and then they go
away and never come back again I mean I
I didn't think that that was the case
through all the site evaluation
committee hearings we've had
I thought there was somebody that's
supposed to keep track of what's going
on
no typically it's not that simple
um the part of the terms and conditions
of a certificate include for example in
the case of Antrim win
regular quarterly or semi-yearly tests
sound tests of the facility and
the question arises about whether those
sound tests are accurate whether they're
being implemented correctly then uh the
public might want to ask questions of
the site evaluation committee and have
them investigate just exactly what's
going on we'll hear more about that
later
if I'm sorry Mr chairman and that costs
ten thousand dollars
for them to ask questions
right now it does yes
thank you
thank you for the question
next up is representative Jacqueline
credition
thank you chairman Bose
um actually one of my questions was
already just answered um so I was
wondering would it be possible maybe to
give an example of one of those requests
that has come in over the last three
years just to give me a sense of
the questions that are at that ten
thousand dollar level right now um
answered resolved
thank you for that question I don't
remember the
what the three previous
declaratory ruling requests were all
about
um
the most recent declaratory ruling
request is about Antrim win and you'll
hear a lot about that in just a few
minutes
thank you
is that awesome
okay next is representative Pimentel
thank you Mr chairman uh on the
financial notes it indicates that this
bill will leave uh essentially a money
hole
which has to be made up
by legislation or some other means uh I
mean typically
uh
these committees they have to find the
money
using the fees
or or maybe by increasing rates yes I'm
wondering if if we're taking the fees
away
and knowing that this won't come out of
General funds
where else would they get the money to
do their work
thank you for that question as I
indicated in my testimony
some reform of the funding of the site
evaluation committee would definitely
seem to be in order that was beyond the
scope of
my legislation
um
the question we're debating or or the
question that this bill tries to address
is what's more important the funding
issue which I'm sure we can find a
solution for eventually
or trust in the size evaluation
committee process by giving the public
access to that process so that's the
essence of what we have to decide as we
decide whether or not to go forward with
this bill
next step is uh representative Michael
Harrington recognized for a question
yeah thank you Mr chairman let me stop
by saying that I'm familiar with the
site evaluation committee because I
believe I'm probably the only member of
the committee that's actually served on
it I served on I don't know eight ten of
them whatever quite a few so to get back
to uh Kelly Pitts question
there is options meaning that if you if
someone who is an aggrieved individual
citizen called up the administrator or
called up the general counsel was uh I
believe is still Mike icolpino or a
member of the site evaluation committee
expressed concern that something wasn't
being followed by their uh conditions
that I would hope those people would
follow up on that but there's no
official process for doing that without
actually follow filing the formal
requests which is the ten thousand
dollar one so I think that's the big
reason we're looking at this so if
someone's discouraged if they discuss it
with the administrator or the council or
remember the site evaluation committee
and those people say well we believe
it's being done and the person the
individual doesn't believe it they then
have the option of just going home and
going away or spending ten thousand
dollars and I think this is what this uh
this bill is is going up to uh do and
like I I agree with the chairman on the
funding issue that's something that's
going to have to look that but we really
need to make sure that uh people believe
in the process because this is sort of a
David and Goliath most of these projects
are in the tens or hundreds of millions
of dollars and if you are individual
landowner who happens to have bought one
of these projects you had a huge
disadvantage if you have to spend ten
thousand dollars to get a declaratory
judgment so I hope that clarifies a few
things for people
thank you representative Harrington
so I see no more questions uh no more
hands raised except for Representative
Sam said she's already had his two
questions I believe so
no Mr Cameron I had one question
all right you get one more go ahead
thank you very much Mr chairman uh so
um uh and I'm glad that representative
Harrington is on this call as well
because
um are is there not already maybe I'm
confusing the two I think when they that
evaluation committee looks at a project
there is public input in that project
process I believe in people who have
objections can bring them up and I've I
heard in the past that there is also
some kind of attorney for the public
part of this process that can uh
basically Champion a residence or or
affected individuals in bringing up
their issues is is that not the case
yes the situation is the site evaluation
committee process is a public process
um
that's not a question that this bill
tries to address essentially this drill
Bill tries to adjust address what
happens when a when the terms and
conditions of a certificate that's been
issued are no longer being met how does
the public gain access to address that
question
so thank you for your question thank you
and uh now I would like to call on the
chair of the site evaluation committee
Miss Diane Martin to uh take the floor
and to speak to us on behalf of this
Bill thank you
I'm not sure
Ms Martin did you submit written
testimony on this bill
can you hear me
yes yes we can hear you now thank you
good afternoon chairman Vos members of
the committee I am returning this
afternoon with my other hat on which is
as the chair of the site evaluation
committee
um and no I did not submit written
testimony my plan was just to give you
some background on the funding
um after having spoken with uh chairman
Bose so if that works I'll do that and
then I can answer any questions
yes please proceed okay and I I think uh
chairman of those you already covered a
good deal of this but I will just lay it
out quickly so that everyone has an
understanding
RSA
162h21 creates a special non-lapsing
site evaluation Committee Fund that's
known as the site evaluation Committee
Fund
all application and filing fees like the
ones we're talking about today that are
received by the SEC are to be deposited
into that SEC fund
the law limits though how that money
within the SEC fund may be used
specifically it can only be used to pay
for compensation and reimbursements made
under 162 H22 for energy facility time
and expenses that includes the
compensation of the public members who
are on the committee compensation estate
agencies for their representatives on
the committee and compensation to the
Department of Justice as was just
mentioned for its role as Council for
the public before the site evaluation
committee
this provision does not provide for
funding of an SEC administrator position
or any other committee support cost from
the SEC fund
instead RSA
162-h-21 2 provides that all other
operating costs of the committee
including but not limited to the
administrator and other committee's
costs and public member compensation and
reimbursements that are not paid from
the society evaluation Committee Fund
are to be funded through Appropriations
from the general fund and so that would
mean that in a scenario where you have
no filing fee for a very small filing
fee you would have to have general fund
money available to support the the
proceedings related to that
the legislature provided Appropriations
in this biennium for anticipated filing
fees during the biennium but it did not
provide any general fund appropriation
for any cost of the committee or for
proceedings that occur without a filing
fee or with a small filing fee
and so that brings us to this bill and
its implications for the operations of
the committee
the decision about what is an
appropriate fee for a particular
proceeding is a policy decision that is
wholly within the purview of the
legislature I am not here to take a
position on whether a fee is appropriate
or not from a policy perspective and I
certainly understand the policy reasons
for having a low or no filing fee to
make access to the SEC process easier
but I am here to to explain is the
implication of the current funding
scheme and how the language before you
may impact committee operations
when there are proceedings that do not
have filing fees or have very small fees
like what's proposed here related to the
declaratory ruling proceeding and there
has been no appropriation of General
funds the committee is still required by
the law to hold the related proceedings
but has little or no funding to do so
and the same thing applies to what
chairman Bose was just talking about in
scenarios where we have substantial post
certificate
issues those proceedings don't come with
any fee at all and so
frankly operation of the committee
without funding is difficult or
impossible particularly in light of RSA
9 colon 19 which prohibits me from
spending money that hasn't been
appropriated
the committee cannot meet without public
members pursuant to the statute and they
are required by Statute to be paid for
all of their time on any project
the committee also has training
requirements that are not related to any
particular project and what and what I
just mentioned which has been an even
larger funding issue is the post
certificate proceedings related to
compliance and complaints those don't
have any related fee that can fund the
related proceedings but do take up a lot
of time
this is a long way of say saying the
committee has significant and important
responsibilities but without fees or
without fees that cover the costs of
those proceedings or general funds it
has no way to support those operations
and lastly I wanted to point out this is
just a technical issue the registration
the legislation strikes the reference to
the three-member subcommittees related
to these types of petitions initially
this was understood to be intended to
remove the three-member subcommittee as
an option for such petitions which would
potentially exacerbate the funding issue
because you would have to have a full
committee or a larger committee for
these type of proceedings upon further
review it appears that the existing
statute for establishing subcommittees
would still permit the use of three
three member subcommittees for such
petitions even with the language
stricken in the fee Section I raise that
point as a point of clarity just to
determine whether the legislation was
intended to eliminate the ability to use
read member subcommittees and if so to
point out that further a member a
further Amendment of the statute would
be necessary I believe if that were the
intent
I I'm happy to take any questions on any
of the topics
thank you Miss Martin we appreciate that
testimony the chair recognizes
representative Thomas for a question
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question
it's a related question what we've been
talking about I was going to uh
part of it is what has been your yearly
budget for the SEC and
um and what are your expectations for
your your future requests for election
budget
well our so the what was appropriated in
the biennium is very different from what
we have actually spent and in large part
that is related to the
um number of proceedings that have been
filed
which have not been very many and so the
fees that have come in have been
um minor so the original appropriation
for fiscal year 20 was 500 000 and and I
believe that we spent
um under 250
000 with a proceeding that went on and
with at the time we had a full-time
administrator
um the administrator recently took a
position in another state agency and so
we don't we don't have an administrator
so those costs have been reduced for
this year
um
I expect that we're going to be even
lower than that in what's actually
expended but I'm
in the process of going to the fiscal
committee to attempt to get some funding
in order to continue to hold proceedings
okay you need any follow-up
no but you mentioned in fiscal year in
20 and 21
now if I was asking about fiscal year 19
or 18 would those figures be affected by
I believe those were years where you had
a lot of meetings involving more than
the past and those types of sites could
you give us some insight as to what do
those years cost
I don't have the um the budgets for
those in front of me and I actually
joined the Public Utilities Commission
and the site evaluation committee at the
end of 2019 but what I can tell you is
that in the biennium the prior biennium
the legislature
um provided for 480 000 from the
renewable energy fund to be used by the
SEC and I believe that approximately
three hundred and eighty thousand
dollars of of those funds were actually
used by the SEC to accomplish its tasks
so in addition to what it got for what I
understand were be were significantly
more proceedings during those years the
fees related to those there was also
um almost four hundred thousand dollars
in other funding sources that was used
to keep this process going and so in
this biennium we did not not have that
access to the
renewable energy fund I did go to fiscal
um
earlier in or at the end of the last
fiscal year to to get some funding for
the administrator position because there
was no funding for that
um
and so the costs are greatly reduced
obviously because we have
um
not as many filings that makes sense but
what what I will say is as uh the chair
pointed out there has been a lot of post
certificate work related to
existing projects and those um
do not come with a fee and I do want to
point to follow up on someone else's
question about enforcement the statute
RSA
162h12 which is entitled enforcement
specifically provides for a process
whereby
um
someone can come forward about a
violation of a certificate and the
committee
or the administrator as designee
historically
uh can determine whether the term or
condition of the certificate is being
violated then there's a there's an
adjudicative process related to that
that must follow
um and that process does not have a fee
uh and so
I think part of the concern there was
that that can be designated to the
administrator we don't currently have an
administrator but the discussions with
the committee most recently were that um
they similarly felt that the committee
should be making those decisions
thank you the chair recognizes
representative Callie Pitts for a
question
about
something you just said that you have no
administrator so what happens to these
complaints does someone else handle them
these complaints about non-certificate
compliance
yes so we did have an administrator for
most of the last calendar year but
without an administrator
um it is definitely a struggle because
that really leaves only the chair of the
site evaluation committee as the sole
remaining member of the agency so to
speak and that uh chair as you have seen
today has lots of responsibilities
related to the Public Utilities
Commission
um but no we continue to schedule
meetings and hold those I think the
funding issue is really
the biggest problem uh because that
impairs the ability to hold proceedings
if you don't have funding I I will say
it is a strain for sure to not have
staff or a consultant or anything but
again those require funding
I may I follow up
I think you asked two questions didn't
you nope
okay follow-up
follow-up would be as as things are now
um this adjudicative process that you
talked about that costs nothing when
does the declaratory judgment kick in is
that a second appeal of that
adjudicative process
so they're really two different things
um a declaratory ruling is a specific
request to determine whether
um the committee's rules are applicable
or
um an order is applicable and so
arguably you could speak to a
certificate through that process a
specific request as to applicability the
enforcement Provisions are really
related to
um you know are you complying with your
obligations under the certificate and
and when we say no cost I I want to
clarify that there is a cost because we
have to pay for all of the costs
relating to the proceeding there's this
stenographer I think the last time we
had a meeting that was hundreds and
hundreds of dollars and then the public
members and amongst other things so
there's a cost it's just there's no fee
and and that's the same for all of the
post certificate
um processes this statute does not
contemplate a fee related to the those
um or really any any post certificate
compliance thank you
you're welcome representative pamola is
recognized for a question yes chairman
thank you
or provide your testimony
I just wanted to understand when
somebody makes a petition for a
declaratory ruling on your end do you
have a one one person multiple people
can you give any kind of explanation of
what kind of man hours it takes you all
to attend to that petition just so we
can understand what it what the work is
on yours
I think it really depends upon what the
petition is we haven't had one since I
joined but I did dig into the history
and uh one of the ones that I found
the total cost for the um proceeding was
six thousand dollars so I'm not sure
exactly what made that up but most of
these things take
um you know staff time if you have staff
if you don't have staff obviously
there's no additional cost because the
chair
um
gets paid through the salary
um but you have to set up
the proceeding you have to have a
stenographer present those are not
employees those are people that we have
to hire to bring in
um and then the public members get paid
for all of their time for Preparation
and attendance and agency members get
paid for a certain amount of their time
depending on the length of the
proceeding so
um it sounds like there have not
historically been a lot of petitions for
declaratory ruling but that they have
been not inconsequential certainly not a
significant in cost as some of the large
applications for certificate
recommended
is recognized for a question
Mr chairman um thank you Miss Martin for
taking our questions
um so I have um
can you explain to us a little bit about
since this bill is partially about
access by the public to this procedure
after the license has been
awarded can you uh give us a little bit
of an insight about what is the Public's
role in that whole process before and
after the license is greased and what is
the rule of the uh the council for the
public
that's a good question so counsel for
the public
um in these post certificate filing type
of scenarios generally is not involved
the council for the public plays a
significant role in the application and
certificate uh review process and and
sort of serves as
an advocate for the public and
um you know brings up issues that are
important and might not otherwise wise
be brought up but generally their role
kind of drops out after the certificate
is issued
um accessed by the public
so it depends upon whether you're in an
adjudicative phase or if you're holding
a public meeting all of those should be
accessible to the public and are
supposed to be posted consistent with
RSA 91a and so the public can always
attend any of those things and we are
required by rule and do hear public
comment at any proceeding
um and so it it varies depending upon
where we are in the process and what
exactly is before the the committee
follow-up Mr chairman okay follow up uh
just just briefly uh on the question of
funding uh if I heard correctly that
we've had only like three such
declaratory judgments since 2015. if I
look at the amount of money that would
be raised that maybe compromises uh
comes up to about two percent of your
annual budget
I can't believe that that would be
significant impact on your budget if
that were lowered however maybe I'm
getting this wrong
well the
evolved
um as I said I'm I'm new to this um
scene but
um they're supposed to be reflective of
the actual cost and as I just told you
the six thousand dollars for the one
that that I dug up so less than the
current statutory fee
um
but the issue isn't really how
Whittle the fears versus how much it
costs it's that if we have no funding
then I don't have any means by which to
legally and lawfully establish any
proceeding and so you know I really am
struggling with my ability to establish
proceedings that comply with the law yet
I don't have any funding for them it's a
difficult position to be in I think
particularly for someone like me who is
well aware of the statutes that prohibit
um
public employees from spending money
that has not been appropriated
thank you
thank you Miss Martin we have kept Miss
Martin now for a full 20 minutes we have
four additional speakers who want to
speak at this public hearing
so I'm going to ask the three people who
have their hands raised if you hold your
questions until after the the next
series of speakers
would that be okay
okay in that case
I will now call on Lisa linones a member
of the public who wants to testify in
support of this bill Ms Lino's you're on
she has written testimony
this lenos has submitted written
testimony uh members of the committee
I'm sorry Mr chair I was I was muted can
you hear me okay now
yes oh good thank you uh Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you very
much for the opportunity to speak I have
been involved with the SEC process as a
member of the public for many years
dating back to 2006 so before SB 245 was
passed at which time there were no fees
and now after the fees so I I have some
responses is some of the questions that
might differ from what you've heard so
far
um
because my firm belief that when the
legislature introduced the fees to the
SEC process it never intended for
non-corporate entities to face a
financial barrier that and this is
evidenced by the language in RSA
162h8a that explicitly removes the fee
of ten thousand five hundred dollars
when the condition petitioners for
committee jurisdiction are
municipalities registered voters or
abiding communities
so in this in essence in the scenario
where the legislature understood the
petitioner to be a member of the public
no fees applied it's also my belief that
at the time when the fees were adopted
there was no consideration or thought
that a declaratory ruling would be a
petition that would be filed by members
of the public and frankly when I went
through this the process when I was when
I watched and participated in the 245
uh deliberations
I didn't think of it either and didn't
think it would come up and um and let me
explain why the really the motivation in
my opinion
behind HB 624 and it dates back to 2018
in that case the SEC administrator was
in place
he had made a determination about a
condition of approval there was a
certificate granted for Antrim win
New Hampshire the and there was a
question by members of the public as to
whether or not one of the conditions had
been properly met
they filed a complaint with the SEC the
administrator
it had responded to the complaint and in
her response she stated
that and if you bear with me for one
second I'll get the exact wording
um I'm sorry I had to have to close one
window and in fact uh she she stated
that her determination was Final that
the dis that the um
so that what she wrote was according
that her determination was fine on that
according to the SEC committee it will
not hold a hearing
on this
on the complaint and to the extent you
seek additional relief from the site
evaluation committee you should file for
a declaratory ruling in other words we
had the only way we could get relief
from the administrator's decision
was to pay three thousand dollars or ten
thousand five hundred dollars
to get before the site evaluation
committee we were shocked by that
decision because it was never our
understanding or expectation that an
administrator would have the authority
the single authority to make a
determination on that and that we would
have to pay money to appeal a decision
of the administrator
so that is the well the hope is that the
fee would be eliminated if that is going
to be the process we follow into the
future
so in general a petition for declaratory
ruling is filed when a party has a
specific question regarding how a
committee interprets Provisions our RSA
162h or any of the SEC rules introducing
the lower fees which was stated today
and apply it uniformly I don't think
anyone should pay significant quantities
of money
in order to get access to their
government especially when the
government especially when the question
is arising as to confusion over what the
rules say what the actions of the
committee are or its administrator we
should have ready access and that was
the expectation with 245. I do not
foresee a regular pattern of harassing
declaratory rulings I do not think that
that has not was not the case before
there were no fees and then after their
fees there was as we heard there were
only three cases that came up since 2015
and one of them was the one we at
Guardian answer when
and then secondly that I would like to
speak to the question of the powers of
the administrator because that's one of
the other clarify the clarifying
language that um chairman both spoke of
on the matter of the SEC administrator's
Powers when the when the public went to
the committee and requested relief
the committee issued an order that
stated as a matter of procedure seeking
re-hearing of a decision by the
administrator is not proper under the
committee's statutes and rules
in effect the order stated this is the
sec's OWN ruling that the
administrator's decisions can be made
unilaterally without public deliberation
or apparent opportunity for appeal
when we brought this into the attention
of Senator Bradley who was intimately
involved in sb245 passing
he was surprised by this and said that
the level of authority that appears to
be confirmed conferred to the
administrator is in his mind
unprecedented in the state and contrary
to the legislative intent of 245. we
believe if you were if you look at the
language that is written even the
current language of SB uh once I'm sorry
RSA 162h wherein now it explicitly
States the committee has to make a
determination regarding whether the
terms and conditions are met on a
certificate if you look at the language
as it stands today and even the
languages it stood before RSA 162h was
changed by 245. there's a discrepancy
between what the SEC rules say and what
the and and how the SEC is operating in
terms of conferring this level of power
to the administrator then what the
language of those statute actually says
I believe it was a mistake by the SEC if
it cost us a fortune to go to court over
it there'd be deference to the SEC so in
general so it was a we founded a losing
battle so that's why we're hopeful that
this uh bill will pass and clarify the
authority of the administrator or the
powers of the administrator to the SEC
and also reduce the cost of access thank
you
thank you uh Ms minnows are there
questions from Ms minnows I see one from
representative sausage
thank you
yes thank you Mr chairman uh Miss
minnows uh would you think that it might
be an improvement to this bill if
instead of saying 250 dollars
uh we would say 250 dollars were all uh
um
for for non-corporate or non-business
entities
oh I'm I'm sorry oh
did you I'm sorry broke up can you I'm
sorry sure so so would you think it
might be an improvement to this bill if
instead of just saying flat out 250
dollars for a declaratory judgment it it
would too would read 250 dollars for
non-corporate or business entities
that would be fine I have no problem
with that at all in fact I and I'm quite
certain that all of the other fees that
are in there would only apply to the
corporates as well so yes that would I'd
be very comfortable with that and I if I
may ask I would like to see that right
now at rsa162h does allow for uh the
committee to the SEC to increase its
fees 20 every year I would like to see
that 250 remain flat so not increased
so but thank you for the question thank
you
okay next we have a question from
uh representative Kat McGee
chairman
um my question is it it sounded to me
when uh chairwoman
um Martin was speaking that she's the
only person currently involved on the
SEC and so I would like an understanding
if there's a statutory requirement as to
how many people serve on the SEC because
it says that a subcommittee is three
people so I I'd like to understand what
the structure is
absolutely thank you for the question
there is I believe it's I can't remember
now which is seven or nine people but
there is a statutory size of the
committee and it also designates
the agencies from which people of the
SEC
um what roles they play in in the state
and and who sits on the SEC
the odd thing about the SEC is that it
does not exist except when it is meeting
per se you have so the um the chair has
the authority to take certain actions as
it apparently uh you know we would like
to see this change but the admin has
authorities as well
um when the committee is not in in force
or seated however
um to the question to your question what
happened before 2 45 was passed
the public would issue would file
either motions or complaints or
something to the site evaluation
committee the site evaluation committee
would act on it in its entirety so for
instance there was a compliance problem
with Groton win which is down near
um Plymouth
and when that was filed the committee
convened and dealt with the issue
I think ultimately in that case there
was a definitely a compliance issue and
Groton win paid for the cost as
generally as the case the applicant
picks up the cost for the sec's
activities
um and so it's that that's how it did
work I'm I'm very confused now about how
the admin and the the chair operate well
it sounds very much like a chicken and
egg thing the way it was described by
chairwoman Martin because
it sounded as though statutorily they're
not allowed to do work that isn't funded
and if there isn't funding so I you know
I mean that's what I'm trying to
understand because I want to make sure
it's not an unfunded mandate that we're
requiring under the guise of being able
to provide people access because that's
how I understand what's going on is
we're saying we want regular people to
be able to have access to to voice their
objections and to be able to be heard
and to have a part in that process and I
I think that that's all a great idea
I've been involved myself with Ned in my
town halls years ago up in the site
evaluation committee rooms but but I am
concerned that what we're doing may not
be fixing that that may be causing
another problem in terms of the
um sort of gutting of the ability of the
SEC to operate that's what I want to get
at basically I'm not sure who could
answer that for me but yes um can you
hear me okay my Internet isn't unstable
I as I understand it the members that
sit on the committee are paid as part of
their regular job so when they do seat
that when they are seated they
their salary covers their cost so it
comes out of their respected divisions
or agencies
um but when there's additional work to
be done
that is if it's not paid by the
applicant or the owner of the energy
facility
I don't know where the money comes from
general fund presumably
thank you representative
for those answers
um
we have no more hands raised so I would
like to move on to our next presenter I
would like to call to the
to the Forefront Ms Lowery Lerner
who is representing herself as a member
of the public
and Ms Lerner the floor is now yours
good afternoon
chairman those and committee members I
appreciate the opportunity to speak to
this bill I hope that everybody can hear
me
yes perfect thank you I do have written
testimony that I submitted hopefully
everybody has seen it I will not go
through it
um word for word given that we've
discussed many of the points that are
contained in it but I would recommend
that you do read it I reinforce
everything that Lisa has said I got
involved with the site evaluation
committee process and all the
legislative activities that were
happening from 2012 on so I was very
closely involved in SB 245 and SB 281
which set the wind sighting guidelines
and it's my firm belief that these were
unintended consequences that came out of
such a lot real change that was enacted
with SB 2485 I don't think anybody in
the legislature or the public or
probably at the SCC ever anticipated us
to find ourselves in this position
um we back in
2012 as Lisa referred to there were some
issues with rotten wind there were
grievances filed by the citizens and
almost instantly the SEC came together
and had an adjudicative process to find
their way through both the public
citizens grievances as well the fire
monster Fire Marshal had some concerns
with the project at the time and
everything was handled
um
to a point where they're you know the
parties that were aggrieved had some
closure to that as it stands right now
as we're seeing with antrum wind when
there are serious issues uh when they
had PM Monroe as the SEC administrator
in place she was making the decisions
without input from the committee or
giving the opportunity for the public to
work with the SEC committee to
understand their concerns she was making
as Lisa said unilateral decisions and
when we brought that through a
declaratory ruling it became very
obvious through commissioner honigberg
that that was now the new Norm for the
SEC process that the administrator has
the unilateral decision-making Authority
which again in speaking with Senator
Bradley and being involved in sb245 and
sb99 back years ago that was never the
intent the intent was to
include or incorporate public trust into
the process give greater particip
relation to the public the public back
in 2012 and on time frame had a lot of
distrust and were very concerned with
where the state was heading and that's
why all of these large changes came
about unfortunately
nobody caught these other underlying
issues that have since come about and so
we're asking now for this committee to
help us in making some corrective
actions to remedy it so that the people
that are living in the shadows of these
energy facilities have an Avenue when
there's such a grievance without having
to spend a lot of their own personal
money to make that happen
I'll speak directly to the particular
declaratory ruling that we had
um it was determined to have a
three-person subcommittee to hear the
grievance and I will say the
subcommittee came together and it was
probably within 15 to 20 minutes as I
recall that the decision was made to not
hear the case and therefore the public
had just spent three thousand dollars
plus legal fees for something that they
didn't even have an opportunity to voice
their concerns
with that are there any questions
thank you Ms Lerner before we open the
floor to questions I am going to
open the public hearing on
hb614 and recess that public hearing so
that we can continue this public hearing
thank you now uh representative Jackie
Kelly Pitts is recognized for a question
uh Miss lerna thank you very much for
testifying today I was around during 2
45 and I I'm trying to
um to get this straight in my mind I
don't believe anybody I I believe
everything should be able to be appealed
but did you or the individuals who took
the case on Groton have to pay you said
3 000 and I thought the fee was ten
thousand five hundred so was it a group
or was it an individual
okay so there's a couple different
things so when I mentioned Groton wind
that was before SB 245 right so the
public filed their grievance there was
no fee at the time at that time there
was no SEC administrator so the full
committee came together to hear it now
with the passing of SB 245 there was a
concern with Antrim wind and the option
was to pay the ten thousand five hundred
or the 3 000 and because of the
limitations on finances there were a
couple of residents within Antrim win
that decided to go forward with the
declaratory ruling but only could afford
to spend the three thousand dollars so
they got a subcommittee hearing out of
that
so that raises a good point prior to SB
2485 Not only was there not a fee but
they had a full committee now there's a
exorbitant fee even to just get a small
subcommittee of members
so you needed
representative Kelly Pitts yes I I I I
guess I'm I'm really bewildered about
this so and what I heard you say or with
my brain interpreted please correct me
because I want to get this straight that
you could buy a whole committee for Den
Phi but you could take a subcommittee
for three correct
and that's that is a correct
interpretation on my part that's the way
that currently works okay thank you
thank you for the question thank you
okay uh we have two more
no just one more hand raised so uh I
recognize representative samsich for a
question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Miss
Lerner to thank my question uh I'd like
to ask you do you think that this
current bill would be improved upon if
we I just charge the 250 dollars to
entities that are not corporate or
business interests I do I agree with
that change
yes I also believe the other component
of the bill which clarifies the
authority of the SEC administrator
versus the committee is also very
important
thank you very much thank you thank you
I've seen no more hands raised I think
you um Ms Lerner for your testimony we
have two more people who would like to
speak and because we're running it
against a time constraint I'm going to
restrict each of the next two speakers
to two minutes each the first of those
speakers is Joseph quasnick
what is yours
for two minutes
this time I will not provide oil
testimony well thank you very much
thank you I appreciate that I next call
on Barbara Berwick to testify
Ms burrick you have the Berwick you have
the floor for two minutes she's a member
of the public representing herself
and she submitted written testimony so
go ahead Miss Barrack
hi can everybody hear me okay
yes yes
um so I am a butter my husband and I are
a Butters um and um
I just feel like with three thousand
dollars or ten thousand five thousand I
mean there is no point we would like we
filed a complaint back in January about
a sound
um exceedance of decibels I recorded it
on my phone it had a graph and
everything I didn't know what to do
because it was you know I sent it to I
think our um selectman and he and to
Antrim win enter win basically said are
we required four times a year to monitor
the sound and that's basically what they
were going to do
um and then
um okay I got to make it quick because
in only two minutes but basically if I
have if we if we want to
the long story with that January thing
is nothing has ever been done yet
nothing when they did come and do this
sound study in the spring they were
there for I think nine ten days and they
got nine hours of usable
um sound dater the rest of it they
considered unusable so one place that
they were there for eight days they had
one hour of usable sound data if and and
we just feel like you know we want to
question that they're not following the
laws that were written by the SEC we got
in sound data and we never said they
could not come to our property we said
they could we want to make sure that
they're following the laws that are
written before they're allowed to come
back after that that Springtime one
um but we I we can't afford three
thousand dollars that's just it you know
we have we just basically feel like it
doesn't matter anymore we don't matter
we're not important we're not big
business and we have no voice so if you
if we have to pay three thousand dollars
to have three people hear our case or
ten thousand five hundred dollars
we just can't we just there's no way we
can it's not something within the means
of most normal people
and I just feel like um
the SEC is supposed to be somewhat of a
intermediary between the public and the
big business and that they're supposed
to be there to help represent and make
sure that the big business doesn't just
run over the little people and if this
bill passes it will help a lot
thank you
you're welcome
are there any
on this Berwick I have one
uh representative not are you recognized
for a question
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
submit some written testimony yes I did
any additional questions
Michael Harrington you recognize for a
question
uh yes I just want to say Barbara uh I
was on the antrum site evaluation
committee and I was responsible putting
a lot of those sound issues in in the
testing and I'm really sorry to hear
that's not working I was supposed to and
I understand your frustrations and
hopefully we can change something so you
have some options rather than just to
that you're going to spend a lot of
money or just listen to stuff that you
don't want to hear I I really I really
really appreciate that um I you know
just all we really want is that the law
is being followed that's all we really
want but it does get to feeling like we
don't matter
thank you representative Jackie Kelly
Pitts is recognized for a question
don't forget to unmute yourself
Jackie I'm I'm bad Miss Berwick just a
yes or a no do you have did you have or
do you have access to that sound data
is that data that was collected in this
spring
right to show whether they're within the
levels that they're supposed to be do
you have access to that
data I probably do it's probably on the
SEC website
we normally have access to everything
that's on the SEC website like they did
just have a meeting with did not inform
us about but usually everything
um is is available through the SEC
website
um I think that I can get access to it
so hey thank you for that uh answer just
to clarify for you representative Kelly
Fitz there is a serious question about
whether the methodology used to gather
that data correct Oh you mean the
methodology I don't think I do have
access to that no I have access to what
they reported but uh we actually asked
when they were going to do a sound study
that you know if the one of the people
that was a specialist with a sound could
um just meet with the person that was
going to do it we're going to have a
phone meeting and everything this was
through Pam Monroe and she was fine with
it and she was setting it up and then
suddenly he's gone it didn't happen and
I'm sorry I know I'm going over time but
it didn't happen and we never did find
out why and now we're talking about like
having to pay a lot of money to get
experts involved and this was going to
be absolutely no cost to anybody just to
have this phone conversation
I don't know what happened thank you
you're welcome
mrwick we appreciate you um
the teachers and the kids in my class
appreciate the time out so okay
thank you bye-bye
okay having uh Mr chairman you you're
you're you're muted right now we can't
hear you no I'm sorry
uh okay so thank you Ms Berwick we
appreciate your testimony
so we have no more hands raised we have
no more uh folks who want to testify so
I'm going to declare that this public
hearing will be over as soon as I read
uh
blue sheet
unfortunately the blue blue sheep for
this bill is huge we've got 22 people in
support of the bill 17 people who oppose
the bill two people neutral
reading all the names would
substantially lengthen this public
hearing so I'm going to defer that this
information is available to anybody who
wants to look at it so
feel free to Avail yourself of that at
your earliest opportunity
uh representative Thomas
leadership or the elected officials
just gives us a short list
yes that's probably a conventional
practice so we can do that
Senator Bob Guida
supported the bill Senator Ruth Ward
supported the bill
um
I think that was it
so those were the
significant elected officials who
supported the bill
so with that now we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 624.
and we will reopen the book hearing on
House Bill
6 14.
since I am the prime sponsor of that
bill I will now introduce it to the
committee
during this past election campaign the
2020 election campaign
as I went around my district I had a lot
of talk for people about lowering
that's kind of a perennial question but
I would always respond to them by saying
well
your local property taxes are based more
on your your Municipal and school budget
than anything else and so you need to
you need to deal with that by
participating in the local budgeting
process but I would still get a lot of
people saying well can't the state
provide more relief for
property taxes
and uh
so I thought about that a little bit and
I decided to submit House Bill 614 unit
which is a bill that exempts the state
and its political subdivision this
meaning municipalities towns cities
school districts counties from paying
the renewable portfolio standard
fees that are part of the electric bill
and part of the reason for doing that is
because every citizen of every town
pays for the RPS on their own personal
electric bill
but then when they go to pay their
property taxes they essentially pay for
it again when they pay for their
municipal or School District or or
County tax bill
so that seemed like double jeopardy to
me so I decided to submit this bill to
allow cities towns and other political
subdivisions to lower property taxes by
not having to pay the renewable
portfolio standard
fees that are part of the electric
electric bill that every
City Town
Etc receives every month
and these fees can be considerable
according to the puc the state of New
Hampshire
actually bought over 105 million
kilowatt hours of electricity in 2020.
and based on the reconciled RPS rate
of the state's largest utility
the reconciled rate for 2019 that would
mean that the state spent over five
hundred thousand dollars almost five
hundred and ten thousand dollars on the
RPS in 2020.
just as an aside it spent over seven
hundred thousand dollars on the
assistant benefits chart
I even looked at cities like Manchester
and Nashua and determined that they
spend tens of thousands of dollars to
satisfy uh
the RPS portion of their electricity
bill and even my little town of Epping
spends a couple of thousand dollars a
year to satisfy the
RPS as part of their electric bill
so by exempting those
fees those
portions of the electricity bill from
all these Municipal and other government
entities
we can lower property tax rates and save
people money
in the case of the State of New
Hampshire that half a million dollars
that we would save could be used for
Education funding or Health and Human
Services or any of uh a dozen or more
other things that you can think of in
the state budget
so the reason I submitted this bill was
to provide that relief and the way the
bill is worded and I have a or I will be
submitting an amendment to the bill
the amendment number
I should give to you I sent it all to
you to your legislative email yesterday
last evening the amendment to the bill
is
2021-0156h and it just clarifies some of
the language the original bill
which was written by OLS
made a good stab at trying to do what I
wanted to do but it didn't actually work
out and in conjunction with the some
folks from the Public Utilities
Commission I came up with some or we
came up with some better language that
implements the bill as I wanted it to be
implemented
and section B in particular
which says providers of electricity
shall not be subject to compliance under
RSA 362 F3 for electricity sales that
have been Exempted Exempted pursuant to
subparagraph a specifically
provides that there will be no cost
shifting uh
as a result of this bill so the RPS
charges that would have been levied on
cities and towns and other political
subdivisions
but are not but are Exempted it will not
be shifted to other people to pay they
will instead not even be required to be
paid
I also added some language in the
amendment to
uh
deal with the issue of
contracts that the state or political
subdivisions might negotiate with
competitive electricity suppliers as it
turns out the state gets almost all of
its electricity from competitive
electricity suppliers
and those suppliers are not regulated by
the puc
so I added language to the bill that
requires those competitive suppliers to
negotiate contracts with any political
subdivision
that exclude the cost of compliance with
the renewable portfolio standard
and also to report yearly to the
commission on all of those contracts and
finally there's a provision in the bill
that if any particular
political subdivision like a city or a
town wanted to continue paying the RPS
they could do so with a majority vote
of the governing body of that political
subdivision
so that's the essence of the vote of the
bill rather it's a it's a way to save
some money
it will deprive the uh
renewable portfolio standard of maybe a
few million dollars a year
but it's not a huge amount of money
but that money will be
directly applicable to property tax
relief should the cities and towns
choose to use it that way so I'd be
happy to answer any questions about the
bill and uh thank you for
hearing me up
okay so the first person I see is
next year
representative Thomas thank you
the question
does would this bill
was enacted
um you know let it have a
a more direct
effect uh
AQA a a
photography town city whatever whatever
a more direct effect on the people that
live there on their direct
property taxes as opposed to
in the future maybe possibly having a
lower electric bill where the money
could be could be used to like over
to have proficiency of carpet efficiency
if you think about it this is supposedly
in the past
well this bill will lower the
electricity bills of all cities towns
school districts
the County government and the state
government
how the governing body of those
individual political subdivisions
decides to use those savings is up to
them
so
property tax relief is one of the
possibilities other possibilities so
they could just spend that money on
something else
that answer your question
yeah have a follow-up
there's no cities
the opportunity
to lower property infections to keep it
correctly as opposed to
future delivery lowering electric bill
into the future
yes that's correct
okay next step is uh representative
Michael Harrington
thank you Mr chairman um so if I
understand this correctly what you're
saying is that the cities and towns can
make this decision for themselves so if
they feel it's worth it to pay the extra
money to support renewable energy then
they can do that but if they think
they'd rather save the money and use it
on something else whether it's relief of
for taxpayers or more money for the
schools or whatever they have that
option so in other words this is a bill
about Freedom it sounds like to me
freedom to make a decision on what you
think is the best way to go forward with
your electric purchases is that correct
yes that is definitely correct and
freedom is was on my mind when I drafted
this bill absolutely
a follow-up question
oh
no follow-up okay thank you sorry I I'm
muted no follow-up
oh okay no follow up thank you next up
is representative Ken Vincent
thank you Mr chairman I'm really looking
for a definition
I keep hearing everybody talk about
lowering taxes
and I brought this up earlier
when I think of lowering taxes I think
of they're going to go from what they
add down when you say lower taxes does
your definition mean they're not going
to go up as high because I never seen
taxes lowered
what's that old uh cliche and nothing
ever goes awakes
yeah yeah so you just mean you just mean
that they're not going to go as high
they're not going to increase as much as
if they normally would at the freedom to
choose how they want to uh
deal with the savings they're going to
realize on their electricity bills they
can use it to lower property taxes which
as you point out hardly ever happens or
they can choose it to you know spend it
on the fire department
please some other
town of government entity and I re I
respect that
but it the word is not increase them as
higher as as high because we're not
going to lower they're not going to send
everybody a check for the the check the
the taxes went backwards
am I correct it's just not going to
increase size so if you didn't have this
and you say your taxes went up 50
cents per thousand
they might go up 49 cents per thousand
that's what I'm trying to find out
because the word of the wording that
people are using is lowering taxes
they're just not going to go up as high
am I right because I I have a hard time
understanding this definition
yes
thank you thank you
the freedom to choose whether they lower
property taxes
that's what this is all about
not going up as high thank you
okay that's what it is
next step is uh representative samsich
thank you Mr chairman um so
uh my concern about this bill is that in
fact when we exempt the state and the
political subdivisions from paying these
um proportions for the renewable energy
uh standards what we're really doing is
we're reducing the amount of money
available for Energy Efficiency and
renewable energy projects
and
yeah and the idea that somehow uh that
will give people a break on their on the
impacts of their taxes
uh it's kind of wishful thinking because
those very same entities even though
they're not paying those fees
into that fund are now coming in and
saying we'd like to ask for funding for
our renewable energy project in our town
you know they I mean if you were to
exclude them from those processes if
they're not going to pay their own way
why should they have the benefit of
getting these projects in their own town
and municipalities so instead of freedom
I I called freeloading really because if
we say if we if I in my town we decide
we want to be good people we want to pay
that because we support renewable energy
projects and a neighboring Town says
we're not going to pay that but we want
to have the benefit of getting those
projects in our town using the same
funds that we didn't pay into I say
that's freeloading
thank you
thank you representative samsich I would
remind you that during public hearings
we don't debate issues we ask questions
to gather information next up is
representative Kat McGee
um I actually have some testimony in
front of me here year that I wanted to
cite because I think that the
information that's being presented is
giving a very
um sort of high level picture to people
of what the implications of the bill are
it's Freedom it's allowing people to
lower their costs if they choose which
of course we always will choose to lower
our costs but there is kind of a flaw in
the thinking in that the way that the
RPS is structured it's a Rec system
which we're not talking about which is
another level of complexity and I'm not
going to go into the details of the rec
system because I really am not even
qualified to do that but if someone
doesn't have sufficient number of reps
to meet their RPS they would then have
to pay the ACP the alternative
compliance payments and what this bill
apparently uh you have a question
representative McGee yes I'm going to
ask you how you can square this hole
because it appears if I can give you
enough detail for people to understand
what I'm saying
um so the wrecks are the most cost
effective way to comply with the RPS at
this point and the alternative
compliance compliance payments are uh
the most expensive form of compliance
so uh I guess in a class 4 wreck the the
discount uh from ACP is about 30 if you
go with a wreck
so it's always better for rate payers
when the RPS compliance is achieved
through the Retro the rec purchase
so if hb614 goes through and doesn't it
doesn't address what happens if a
provider's ACP payments are low or even
zero so the bill could create a reverse
incentive for providers that would
increase their ACP payment their ACP
payments which would then um be more
costly for New Hampshire rate payers so
my question is you're presenting the
bill as one thing but you haven't
answered this scenario whereby it would
actually increase costs for people
because the alternative compliance
payments will be more expensive for the
towns to support if they're a direct
piece Falls away
thank you for that question I guess
maybe you haven't had a chance to look
at the amendment the amendment removes
section about alternative compliance
payments uh because it's no longer
necessary to make sure that there's no
cost shifting in the in the bill
so the chair now recognizes
representative brechner for a question
good questions can you point to me where
that is
into that language please yes section B
of the amended version of the bill
says that providers of electricity shall
not be subject to compliance under RSA
362 F3 for electricity sales that have
been Exempted so basically
the way the RPS works if you're a
utility and you sell 10 million kilowatt
hours or 10 million megawatt hours of
electricity you're obligated
to purchase a certain number of wrecks
based on that load
if
some number of kilowatt hours are
Exempted then they don't become that
part of that load and so the utility
buys wrecks based on what the adjusted
load is
so that's how that
particular provision
make sure that there's no cost shifting
in the bill
I didn't hear that so it undermines the
RPS program that we currently have in
statute
I wouldn't say that it undermines it it
simply gives cities and towns a way to
save some money that's all it does
representative brezhne did you have a
question yes thank you Mr chairman if
this bill passes and if towns choose to
pass the savings to the taxpayers when
could the taxpayers potentially see a
reduction in their company
probably when a new town budget goes
into effect
you have a follow-up no problem
representative
closure you have a question
thank you Mr chairman
um for the talent Epping for example you
used the thousand dollars they would
spend on the rps's send in
it would go to help efficiency
and say it's in the grant for we use
Elsewhere for 300 of them with the 450
000 residents
if the 1000 am I correct them
no the renewable portfolio standard
actually provides subsidies to vendors
of renewable energy projects
[Music]
that dilution over the state now that
one thousand dollars would stay in
Epping if 50 of uh
the vote wants to use it for renewable
efficiency in the town
wouldn't that be a greater
use of that money for the town their own
money
well that's up to the town to decide
right that the bill provides for a way
that the town can make that choice
sometimes wood some towns wouldn't
representative Jackie Callie Pitts
don't forget to unmute yourself
I wanted to ask if
um
if if the sponsor of the bill has the
breakdown count by count
of what each town would say because I
when when I heard that the taxes would
be lowered for a thousand dollars
of savings that to me is like a drop in
the bucket in Epic
um
and I shop in Epping quite a bit but I
I'd just like to know do we have a
breakdown and I'm disappointed
that no members
of the utilities or the puc or anybody
is here to ask that question can we have
a town by town
breakdown of what would be saved
that would be relatively uh
easy but time consuming to produce
because you would have to go to all 234
towns and ask how many kilowatt hours of
electricity they purchased in the
previous year
and then use the
um
the rate the PSA rate the uh I mean RSA
rate
RPS race
for the utility in that town to com to
compute uh what their Town's savings
would be I didn't do that for all 234
towns I did it for a couple of
Representative towns just to provide
some context and some numbers for for
the committee it would be possible to do
that work
but I have chosen not to do so at this
time
I would like to follow up
yes go ahead follow up the other
question would be the state of New
Hampshire paid 510 000 for the RPS is
that for
All State properties and state-owned
properties
uh or is that for the entire state were
you talking about state-owned properties
I thank you for that question that's
that's actually an interesting uh
question because the Public Utilities
Commission
gave me the figure of a hundred and five
thousand 105 million uh kilowatt hours
that the state used but the state energy
manager gave me a different number it
was more like 80
000 or 80 million kilowatt hours I use
the Public Utilities Commission number
because
I figured that they really ought to know
but the state energy manager probably
ought to know too so I'm not entirely
certain how to record reconcile the
difference between those two numbers
but yeah that information is out there
thank you
I'm told that uh in response to the
question you asked Jackie Kelly that's
uh a minute ago that eversource is
online and is willing and available to
answer questions if anybody has one
next step for a question is
representative uh Jacqueline credition
you chair I do have two questions so one
just as a very practical matter after
this amended Bill comes into effect
with the immediate effect be for this
number to disappear from the state and
Municipal bills or exactly how would
that
am I making sense so so if this applies
will will that line item still be on the
bills will it disappear how will that
work
if I understand your question correctly
you're asking
how would the city or town know that
they uh that their Bill had been reduced
by the amount uh that they would have
ordinarily paid for the RPS
dinner
basically this is an opt out bill but it
provides a provision for the political
subdivision to opt in with a majority
vote of its governing body
so the default will be for it to come
off the bill and then yes so the RPS
charges would just not appear on the
bill they're just part of the the bill
anyway you don't see them broken out
separately
so the bill would just be reduced by
that amount
thank you um and my second question if I
may
amount I guess that would be taken out
of the renewable portfolio standard if
no municipality is elected to keep going
with this
without uh
getting data from all 234 towns plus all
the school districts and the counties in
the state it would be hard to put an
exact number on that but I would guess
based on how much the state is paying
for the RPS and the cities of Manchester
and Nashua that the total for the entire
state would probably be five million
dollars or less
thank you
okay next step
representative oxenham
thank you very much Mr chairman
uh
unfortunately we have not had the
opportunity as in previous years during
that orientation to be briefed on the
renewable portfolio standard or Reggie
as a result many of the people who are
going to be asked to vote on this bill
have no background in what the public
policy of the State of New Hampshire is
with reference to these programs
and we don't have the puc here and we
don't have Des because many part
available staff is being pushed to the
pandemic and helping with cobit so they
can't be here to cover every opportunity
and it's much more cost effective to
have a period of time where they present
to us and explain to us and let us ask
them the questions that would tell us
why do we have these programs
we are part of a regional grid that is
moving to clean energy we are part of a
national entity that is moving to clean
energy investments in renewable energy
are what are going to get us on the road
to making we talked about oh gee grid
Mod's taking five years why don't they
get off the second get it done these are
complex issues but there are also issues
that take money we're investing in a New
Hampshire business our renewable energy
businesses are jobs these are companies
in our state taking money away from the
renewable energy fund is gutting a
program which is going to result in the
larger transmission Regional
transmission charges it's going to cost
the rate payer more money it's bait and
switch you're calling it lowering taxes
and you're going to run for that on an
election and you're doing no such thing
and I think it's really
not a good thing
and I'm sorry that wasn't phrased as a
question because I just couldn't I just
couldn't find a question oh here's the
question why didn't we have the
briefings
that would enable us to make the
decisions we need to make in a
responsible way
we're having a public hearing that's
that's the way we always make policy
decisions we have public hearings we
hear from all members of the public and
from agency heads who choose to
participate and then we make a decision
I know of an agency here that asked to
be able to make a presentation and was
told that we were going to rely on
written testimony because of the time
constraints again and again we're we're
being curtailed in our ability to
function appropriately as legislators
because of this emphasis on time
constraints
well the time constraints are real
and so we have to deal with them it's
it's unfortunate and we hope that those
things that thing that situation will
change at some point in the future but
we have to deal with it now and so we
will deal with it now
uh and we'll deal with it as effectively
as we can is it a perfect process no but
we'll do the best job we can we'll do
the job we've been elected to do
and
we'll we'll accept the results that we
get
that's all I can tell you okay next up
would be
Penman town
thank you Mr chairman
um
if this bill were to pass we know that
this would end up decreasing the Energy
Efficiency fund which of course is for
Energy Efficiency work done throughout
the state but it also pays the 90 cents
I get back on my electric bill every
month I'm wondering if you could tell me
how much that 90 cents is going to be
reduced
um
this bill has nothing to do with Energy
Efficiency
portfolio standard and
um there's no 90 Cent figure that
applies to this bill
you have a follow-up follow-up question
um the the money that goes I guess I
must have misunderstood it but the
amount of money that goes uh that's paid
out uh to meet the RPS
uh I thought that goes into the the
funds for the uh Energy Efficiency fund
am I incorrect there
yes you are incorrect and and the
original version of the bill did talk
about
um the alternative compliance payments
which go into the renewable energy fund
but that language has been removed by
the amendment that I will file
um on the bill which I sent to your
legislative email last evening
thank you for that question next up is
representative
uh yeah always make sure can you hear me
yes chairman okay great I just want to
clarify a couple of things I think what
we were hearing here we were talking
about this and maybe you can tell me if
I'm correct the cost of the uh RPS at
least on my electric bill came out in
December because we passed the bill a
couple years ago and we could only get
it to be charged once a year so if you
look really close in your electric bill
in December you would find that it's uh
about eight percent of the cost of the
energy costs not the total bill so it's
about three and a half percent cost of
your total bill which no one's going to
notice much one way or the other
but on the other hand it is the actual
savings that adds up over the course of
the year and the towns and the
municipalities would then save this
money and again go back to the freedom
idea they could choose to spend it or to
rebate it to the taxpayers or do
whatever they want with it is that
correct
yes you are correct and the number you
you mentioned of about three and a half
percent is also correct
you have a follow-up
no I don't thank you
okay thank you
next up is uh representative McWilliams
thank you chair Vos
um I just want to ask a procedural
question on how this works um
I hadn't read the amendment until just
now
um and I'm just wondering what the next
step is uh for for reviewing this bill
it seems to me like it would be a
perfect Bill to have some kind of a
subcommittee and bring in some testimony
from some of our state agencies because
I think it is worth looking at and
understanding before we spend some time
actually
um
passing it I think some of us have a lot
of questions about it so I want to
understand since this is a new Amendment
what the next step is
uh amendment that I will offer would
have to be offered during an executive
session
and uh
if and when we have such a session I
will offer that Amendment
so follow-up is it possible to have some
kind of a working committee before we do
an exec session on this
it is possible
I don't know if we'll have the time or
the space to do that but uh I'll give
that some serious consideration thank
you
next up would be uh representative Mann
and representative
representative Harrington would you put
your hand down please unless you have
another question
go ahead representative Mann
and don't forget to unmute
thank you Mr chairman
um
I kind of think of this as a somewhat
Maybe I'm Wrong someone less important
issue to deal with the little bits of
money that people have to pay for taxes
and stuff
but um
I'm wondering why of all ways to save
money we're going to choose one
that reduces our response to climate
change given that our children
and our grandchildren have to live in
the future
was there a question there yes
why are we why is this important enough
for a bill
why is this way of doing it uh from my
perspective perspective uh
we as legislators have a public policy
obligation to the people who elected us
and
in my district I'm getting a lot of
people asking me to
for the state to provide a way to reduce
their property taxes and so I'm trying
to respond to that
if
that choices
important public policy issue and one
that we should always air on the side of
giving people more choices rather than
fewer choices
well um follow up follow up thinking can
I follow up yes
um
thank you
you know one way the state for example
could lower
property taxes would be to
come up with an income tax
one of the benefits of an income tax is
when we do things that make the economy
better
the government notices an increase
in their collections whoa whoa whoa whoa
this yes
why I'm just saying why why
one of our priorities is to deal with
the future of climate change well I pick
this way rather than all sorts of other
ways to
reduce taxes I mean why shouldn't for
example I'd be very happy to pay an
income tax if I knew most of it was
going to education for anybody in the
state
I don't care I don't have kids my kids
are 50 years old
well representative man I can tell you
that in every state where that's been
tried
imposing an income tax in an effort to
lower properties taxes it has not worked
it has never worked
who's banging on the table
well thank you I thought somebody was
trying to get my attention I apologize
representative Mann for interrupting no
I'm finished I'm finished thank you okay
thank you representative Kelly Fitz you
said the uh
the utilities were on the line I I I
can't see who's on the line and who's
not but I would like to ask for
the usage at least for my town
uh Portsmouth and what their RPS payment
is and if they had that as a breakdown
uh by town I would like to do that but I
don't know if it's still here
are they still on the line
uh I see
Donna Gamache on the line
well I'll put Donna on the spot and ask
Donna
for that breakdown about how much money
we're really going to say and how much
you know and and
if how much is in the RPS fund right now
but I would like to know town by town
because when we say low at taxes
you know if you give somebody 20 cents
the town's going to spend it they're not
going to lower the taxes that's the tax
rate so I just want to know how much
it's
each town is going to have much each
town has spent knowing that this year
2019 is probably
a high year because people have been
home more but I don't know so I would
like to see that if not if possible
email it maybe email it to the committee
is that possible Donna
um I will do my best
um my um I don't know that can I just
say I don't know if it's possible I have
gotten some feedback on this language
and I know that they felt that
um that it may be difficult for us to
kind of separate some of this
information out but I will double check
to see a if it's something we can do to
be able to tell you about Portsmouth
um and uh and I cannot answer off the
top of my head I have to admit that I
have not been allowed back in my office
since March 13th and all of my files are
still there
like everybody else right and so I don't
have at my fingertips what on average
all of our customers jointly have been
paying for the RPS maybe the puc has
that information they may be able to get
it sooner than me but at the very same
time I will check to see if I can get
that information for you and I will make
sure that whatever I get I share with
all of you
thank you you're welcome
thank you Ms Gamache do you have a copy
of the amendment that I filed for this
bill I do not I do not either you get a
copy I think that would help with your
questions thank you very much
okay uh next up is representative McGee
thank you
are we going to hear from other people
other other people waiting to testify
that's one question and then I have one
for you as well
are there other people who are planning
to testify in this area there are okay
the other people who are waiting to
testify okay great
great
um I would
about at what cost because I think did
you say that it was one thousand or two
thousand that nothing would save
your calculation at the beginning of
your testimony your written testimony
wasn't it 2000 in your written testimony
because I read it last night
yes I believe it was the number was two
thousand yes and once the number of
people in Epping
a few a little over seven thousand
so those
seven thousand
by
a thousand divided by seven
it's not like a you know it's a very low
amount like a dollar forty or something
I mean I I'm questioning at what cost
we're gonna disrupt because
uh that one that you guys want to spend
for energy
right but
but I think that people won't really
notice and the idea is that in the queue
in the cumulative the amount of good
that that does is the reason you put the
RPS standard in the first place so I
guess what I want people to consider as
we go forward is at what cost like if
what is this bill gaining us it's not
really lowering people's property taxes
to the points that were made earlier and
so I'm trying to figure out what the
intent of the bill is so disruptive to
the policy that really was confessions
there's one
um in the first place
there's no proof it isn't working as
intended so
thank you for your opinion I remind you
that uh we're here to ask questions
also remind you that the money belongs
to the people who earn it it's not ours
and we should allow them to choose how
they want to spend it
next up is uh representative partial do
you have a question
I do thank you for taking my question
Sheriff
um now first I have to say that I am not
fully dispute on RPS and I would
certainly benefit from more tutorials
and more access to the various
committees that could educate me on this
I'm doing my best
but I'm wondering why we can't earmark
the funds that would be saved directly
to public education
you can have these if you reduce your
property taxes within your town
that's one question okay well the answer
to that question is it's up to the
cities and towns to decide how to spend
their money
okay
and another uh second question
um this bill sounds like a potentially
it could be a billing nightmare for
finding out the cost for every uh
municipality and uh
uh in town
and I'm just worried that any potential
savings that might be made would be
offset by uh the utilities billing
procedures do you have any guarantee
that will not be happening
what billing features specifically are
you referring to
that's the calculation for every
Municipality of what their contribution
would be than dividing up among the
individual utility bills
maybe I don't understand as I said maybe
I don't understand the entire situation
but that's what occurs to me any
potential cost could thus be offset
immediately by
um utilities
having to
re-adjust their building procedures
uh oh I think I get your point now
um
the way the bill is worded providers of
electricity shall not be subject to
compliance under RSA 362 F3 for
electricity sales that have been
Exempted Exempted and pursuant to
subparagraph a that basically means that
when they calculate the number of
kilowatt hours on which they have to
base their their electricity sales
they just reduce it by the amount of the
electricity from all these political
subdivisions and the accounting for that
should be fairly straightforward once
it's set up
okay since we don't have any
further questions at the moment but we
do have three people who would like to
testify on this bill I would like to Now
call on Joseph quasnick
who
who is a member of the public
represented himself and Mr quasnick the
floor is yours thank you Mr chairman can
you hear me
okay great
um thank you very much for giving this
me this opportunity to provide oral
testimony and this is in opposition to
House Bill 650 614-ffn
I'd like to remind the committee that
the compliance fees and costs incurred
by state and political subdivisions
under the RPS are invested in renewable
energy projects
these Investments result in lower
electricity bills and electricity use
with within the state of New Hampshire
and it's my belief that they more than
compensate for the cost of the RPS
as we heard this morning on a house bill
of 80. uh when we're able to reduce the
amount of energy that's coming in from
out of state sources uh it benefits
every ratepayer and built there in the
state of New Hampshire we have reduced
transmission costs reduced demand costs
these projects will actually provide
jobs very high paying jobs to people in
the New Hampshire area
I also want to say that state and
subdivisions should be providing an
example to other regulated Bill payers
in New Hampshire of compliance with the
RPS
by providing acps and recs exempting the
state in the subdivisions perverts the
statutory impact of each end the purpose
of the RPS to require all of just users
in the state to contribute to these
incentives for renewable energy projects
but do as we say not as we do
um
House Bill 614 should not pass as its
intent to exempt the state and
subdivision from compliance with the RPS
is inconsistent with the original intent
of the RPS legislation thank you very
much for the opportunity to provide this
testimony thank you sir
do we have anybody who would like to ask
a question
yeah
representative Harrington you're
recognized for a question
yeah I'm just curious you you talk about
leading uh from the towns and the states
and telling other people what to do
should how where else should we do this
and should we in other words you can't
trust the individual towns to make their
own decisions so the state government
has to tell them what to do and what
else should we tell them what to do tell
them how to vote how to do other things
I mean where do you where do you draw
the lines it's just electricity or do
you want to have the state control
everything
let's pick up
pick up this is argumentative and it's
it is
I'm going to speak up in favor of the
public I don't think that's in order
Mr chairman
nowhere to treat the public
Mr chairman I'm sorry I was I was
distracted well I I wasn't and I I think
that Mr Harrington's
uh not question but statements to the
public to Mr kozniak I'm sorry if I
mispronounce it were inappropriate
yes I'd like to answer that question if
I could
oh
Mr kwaziak yes well this isn't a debate
on what the I I I I'm this is not a
debate on what the government can tell
you to do and what the government can't
tell you to do and I think we need to
stick to the bill
so that's that's my point
that's to the chair I'm sorry I didn't
hear a representative Harrington's
statement uh it may have been uh out of
bounds but uh thank you for
acknowledging that representative Kelly
fix
but well if I can my statement was
exactly what she said it's all about
what the government can tell us to do
and what the government can't tell us to
do that's the whole issue here
did you ask a question uh representative
Harrington he did I asked him what his
thoughts were on other issues if they
thought that the government should
should tell us to do everything not just
how we buy electricity
and not just quite that challenge
yeah thank you yeah I mean let's talk
about what the government should do is
there no public good involved here
you respond Mr quasnick or did he want
to
um says he wants to I'm responding with
my comments is that uh the legislature
and its previous in previous sessions
has passed uh the bill enacting the
renewable portfolio standards and they
thought this was an appropriate
legislation
incorporating uh contributions to the
RPS by all electricity used in the state
and I stand by that and I think it's the
right decision to make
thank you
thank you for your answer
has her hand raised I don't know if that
means she wants to ask a question or if
she has uh a response Ms Gamache I'll
give you the uh the floor
yeah I'm sorry that was raised from the
last question that was asked of me of
Representative Jackie Callie Pitts
oh sorry
that's okay thank you
okay so see no more no more questions uh
for representative quasnick we thank you
representative quasnick for uh or Mr
Cosmic I should say for your testimony
and I would like now to call on Heidi
Kroll who represents the granite state
Hydro power
thank you to testify on this bill
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee are you able to hear me
yes we can great okay good thank you I
appreciate it um good afternoon my name
is Heidi Kroll I work at Gallagher
Callahan and gartrell and I'm here today
on behalf of the Granite State
hydropower Association
um in opposition to the bill
um and respectfully uh urge this
committee to find it in expedient to
legislate
um I don't have the benefit of the
amendment that was um that has been
discussed so I apologize my um written
testimony that I did submit a few days
earlier is based on the
um bill as as introduced
um
my I think I just wanted to really hit
on two points
um
one reason for our opposition is because
we believe this bill will undermine the
renewable portfolio standards program
um and I think there has been some
discussion uh that the fund really
serves a key role in the market-based
design of the state's RPS program
um so essentially uh you know the
qualifying renewable facilities produce
renewable energy certificates every time
they produce a megawatt Hour of Power
the electricity providers can meet their
RPS requirements by buying wrecks or if
there are not enough wrecks available in
the marketplace then they can meet their
compliance obligations at least
partially or in whole by making
alternative compliance payments
um and so the money that's deposited
into the renewable energy fund is used
to leverage private investment in
renewable Generation
Um that investment boosts the supply of
renewable generation and the supply of
renewable energy certificates and
thereby making the rec markets more
competitive and robust and helping to
minimize RPS compliance costs for all
rate payers and so
um that is our concern
um with kind of undercutting the role of
the renewable energy fund and as I think
was discussed earlier
the renewable energy certificates are a
much more cost effective way to comply
with the RPS requirements than making
ACP payments
um and so the more we can do to
encourage compliance through the rec
markets the better that's going to be
the more cost effect that's going to be
for New Hampshire rate payers the other
thing I would simply note is that
another reason for our opposition is
that we feel like this introduces a
slippery slope to more and more
exemptions
obviously if the state and political
entities are granted an exemption other
groups will most certainly come to the
legislature seeking exemptions as well
and of course the more exemptions are
Grant the more exemptions that you grant
the more the RPS program will be
undermined so
um those are my the two points that I
wanted to make I know you have a time
limit and I'd be happy to answer any
questions and I do appreciate your time
and consideration this afternoon and
listening to my comments
thank you Miss crawl I would just
respond by uh assuring that acts have
been removed from the bill altogether
there's a different approach in the
amendment so that would alleviate your
concern over acbs
Mr chairman may I ask a question yes how
would I go about getting a copy of that
Amendment
uh since you sent us a written copy of
your testimony I have your email address
and so I will send you a copy how's that
thank you very much you're very welcome
does any member of the committee have a
question for Liz growl
anybody online have a question for this
girl
representative Harrington you still have
your hand up do you have a question uh
yes I do Mr chairman uh very quickly uh
Miss Kroll since you're testifying
against the bill I assume it's going to
cost you clients money could you give us
an estimate of how much money your
clients would lose if this passed
um
I don't have an estimate of that
um representative
um
there might have been some information
given
um earlier but I don't have data about
how much
um each town and each political
subdivision and the state
um you know I think there are Myriad of
scenarios where
um
all or none or some portion of folks
could
um uh remain up I guess that I guess the
default here is that you opt out
um and then you might be able to opt
back into the RPS program but
um so first of all I'm not sure how and
I unless there's a new fiscal note I I
haven't seen data so uh without more
information I would not be able to
um
to answer that question I'm sorry
a follow-up Mr chairman yes go ahead uh
well so I understand that's really
difficult to get down to Brass tax on
that but is it safe to assume that your
clients will lose money if this bill was
passed
well I don't know if that's true or not
I mean the compliance
um with with respect to the RPS
requirement for class four
um the requirement is a 1.5 requirement
which is
um fairly low uh fairly low requirement
among the classes
um and different entities have a
different mix of compliance
um approaches so uh some predominantly
buy renewable energy certificates to
meet that requirement others do a mix of
wrecks and acps
um and so you know if there's some sort
of
um
reduction I guess in in what the
requirement is in terms of
you know meeting the overall requirement
that could that could simply uh
come off the ACP Side Of The Ledger or
it could come off the wreck Side Of The
Ledger
so
um
I I'm not trying to be evasive I just
don't have enough information certainly
if if the number of wrecks that are
purchased declines then that would mean
uh less
um revenue from from selling wrecks or
it could be that just the wreck prices
decline
um
so it's it's kind of tricky for me to
answer that
well thank you very much appreciate it
sure thank you for the question next
step is representative samsich
uh thank you Mr chairman uh just to
follow up on representative Harrington's
question and I don't want to be too
specific Miss Krull but
um uh I think his question uh is similar
to what I I'm wondering
um in general uh if we look at the the
bill as written right now and I don't
have the amended version in front of me
either
but if you look at that can you give us
some idea of how uh your clients
perceive a potential impact to their
businesses their New Hampshire Hydro uh
facilities here in New Hampshire how
they perceive
what type of impact they perceive that
could happen to them
uh mature so there's there's two
different ways I think that there would
be impacts
um one is that you know New Hampshire's
small-scale Hydro facilities
um you know their local businesses they
employ local
um uh residents they they try to do
their best to use
um local vendors and service providers
whether it's um you know from the
Machinery side of things to you know
accountants and that sort of thing so
um and they make you know they their
revenue stream is what allows them to
pay for services and also to pay for the
maintenance and any sort of upgrades
um to their uh facilities
um a lot of those are are mandated
um uh by ferc and other Regulatory
Agencies so they're certainly the
um impact that uh
there could be a a great deal of
instability
introduced into the revenue stream that
comes from selling renewable energy
certificates and that you know as you
know businesses
um do not like uncertainty and so that
could have an impact on um uh how they
run their businesses
um you know scaling back on staff
um scaling back on the services and and
and obviously they're not going to skimp
on maintenance but um they may put off
other things that should be done and
maybe they could delay so there's
um
uh there's that piece and then the other
piece is there have been several
small-scale Hydro facilities in New
Hampshire that have participated in the
competitive RFP that the public
utilities puts out every year
um where
um
projects that are not solar related and
kind of um uh you know rebate based
programs uh the puc also runs out of the
renewable energy fund a competitive
grant program
um and it's you have to compete you have
to demonstrate that your project is
worthy
um in terms of what what investment
you're going to make with the grant
money how much you're going to leverage
that with your own investment
um and in-kind contributions and how
many renewable additional renewable
energy certificates your project will
yield
um and I'm happy to say that a number of
hydro facilities have won those
competitive grants and made those
investments in New Hampshire's
small-scale Hydro facilities and so if
there is a um a loss of
money going into the renewable energy
fund than presumably that could have an
impact on those on the competitive grant
program as well
thank you very much thank you next step
would be representative oxenham
yes I I almost feel like I got the
answer at that time but just just to
nail it down uh Ms Carl could could you
you said something about and twice about
the leveraging of private investment I
mean this renewable energy fund money
doesn't pay for a damn upgrade or you
know I mean projects get a proportion
and then you go into the private market
and I'm asking the question I'm trying
to give you the answer instead of asking
you the question how does that work this
this notion of leveraging private
investment money through fund money yep
so the grant um that the small-scale
hydro folks have um uh gotten I think
have ranged in the hundred and fifty
thousand to maybe
um 250 000 range
um I don't have specific numbers right
here in front of me but that's the order
of magnitude of a grant that we're
talking about we're not talking about a
half a million dollars or a million
dollars or anything of that order of
magnitude
um and uh and I believe that actually
one of the ways that the P you know the
puc has a a set of criteria that it uses
to assess who's a winner and and who's
not a winner and I believe that one of
those criteria is in fact
um how much leverage you're you're
offering so you know for every dollar in
the grant how much are is the project
putting in
um either of their own money or in-kind
contribution which obviously has some
value
um a lot of the hydro folks uh
um uh do their own their own work
themselves you know they're out there
with the Backhoe or whatever it might be
um so I believe that that ratio on
average is about a one to six ratio so
for every dollar of grant money that's
invested in a in a project in that
competitive program you get about six
other dollars worth of
um investment that comes from the
private sector uh that I believe that's
the average I don't want to say that
that's specific to each Hydro facility
that that's my understanding about the
average
follow up if I may
um and and that money is invested that
six to one that increase in in market
economy is happening here in New
Hampshire that money is not part of the
three to four billion dollars being
shipped out of the state am I correct
oh no these are all um uh you have to be
an in-state
um uh renewable energy facility to even
qualify for any of the money in the
renewable energy fund so those projects
are all taking place right here in New
Hampshire
um and communities throughout the state
um and uh the other thing I will just
emphasize is that those projects
um are graded are ranked if you will in
terms of how many additional new
renewable energy certificates will the
project generate and so that is one of
the criteria that's used to determine
who is a winner so these are all
projects that at the end of the day when
the project is complete
um we'll be generating more renewable
energy certificates in this example with
Hydro in class four
um and those are more renewable energy
certificates that are out there in the
market for the suppliers to buy
um and as I indicated in the testimony
uh at least last year on average class
four wrecks were selling at about 30
percent below the market prices for
class 4 Rex for around 30 percent below
um the ACP price
so and obviously basic supply and demand
tells you that the more renewable energy
certificates that are out there that
will bring the price down even even more
and as I indicated to
um class 4 uh
requirement in terms of on the
purchasing so you know the obligation
that the suppliers have
um is a it's a 1.5 percent that's flat
there is no um uh increasing of that
over time like there are um I think at
least for class one thank you Ms Crowe
for that uh answer we have one final
question from uh representative McGee
possible thank you
I'm sorry yeah louder
oh I'm sorry you know what I have a desk
in front of me so I'm not near my mic
I'll move up
um I just wanted to say while the
hearing is still going and before I ask
my question of Miss Kroll since people
have not seen or everyone doesn't have
the amendment the two changes that I'm
reading here which are B and C
letter B says providers of electricity
shall not be subject to compliance under
RSA
362-ath colon 3 for electricity sales
that have been Exempted pursuant to
paragraph a
so
um providers of electricity that is get
the exemption and then it and then C
says all competitive electricity
suppliers Shell One negotiate with any
service political subdivision or state
agency a contract that provides a rate
that excludes costs of compliance with
the renewable portfolio standard under
RSA
362--f so it's doing multiple things
here it's not just giving freedom to
towns in my estimation so I'm wondering
Miss crawl if you could comment since
you're now hearing that that you
mentioned the stability of the rec
Market the stability of the business of
energy I guess for the small energy
producers could you comment on that
um the fact that it's going to require
it's going to say that electric
providers will not be subject to
compliance anymore
for electric sales
and then
uh competitive electric electricity
suppliers which is usually what we call
the smaller people that are contributing
right
um they will also be
excluded
they'll have to negotiate contracts that
no longer include
those charges so it's basically it is
undermining the program completely so
people need to understand that
yeah so thank you for for reading that
um to me representative
um yeah so it sound so the percentages
uh the percentage requirements in the
RPS for example in class four the 1.5
percent
um is kind of keys off of whatever the
sales are
um and of course you know sales go up
and sales go down depending on a variety
of factors uh whether the economy Energy
Efficiency
um
you know usage patterns whether whether
everybody's in a single office building
or all spread out back at their homes
that sort of thing so but at any rate um
it sounds like this approach
um is simply just taking a deduction off
of the sales
um so that
I think it's it's appropriate for for
you to be uh speculating and commenting
on on an amendment that you haven't even
seen
and we shouldn't be debating an
amendment that is unapproved and
unofficial at this point so I think
we'll we'll end it right there and I see
that we have no other questions so I
want to thank you Ms Grove for your
testimony today we have one more person
who would like to testify here this
afternoon and that's Madeleine Monroe
I'm Madeline Monroe who represents clean
energy New Hampshire Ms no you are
authorized to present
thank you chairman Vose and members of
the committee for the opportunity to
speak on this bill today clean energy
New Hampshire opposes House Bill 614 and
I also have not had the opportunity to
see the amendment so I'll be uh speaking
about the bill itself mostly but I'm
looking forward to reviewing that
proposed amendment
um I will Echo everything that Ms Kroll
has said so I won't provide uh duplicate
information but the renewable portfolio
standard is really New Hampshire's only
policy that promotes renewable energy in
the state to us making it a crucial
policy for growing our clean tech
economy creating uh new high-paying jobs
increasing energy Independence and
protecting the environment we really do
feel that this bill would undermine the
renewable portfolio standard it sounds
like with the amendment what we would be
saying is that currently we're looking
to have 25 percent of all the energy in
New Hampshire come from renewable
sources by 2025. now we'd be saying
we're looking to have 25 percent of some
of the energy in New Hampshire come from
renewable sources but we're not going to
count any of the energy that the state
or any town or municipality uses so
really that is reducing our renewable
energy goals for the state
um I also agree that it is a slippery
slope once we start exempting certain
customers certainly we expect that other
customers will get in line and ask for
an exemption further reducing our
renewable energy goals I do think that
representative partial actually had a
very good argument that is a concern
that we share that implementing this
um in the utilities billing systems will
be a significant cost we hear this from
the utilities all the time the slightest
change to their billing systems which is
not state of the art costs millions of
dollars so identifying every customer
that's eligible every account that's
eligible and identify and creating a new
credit and added that to the bill and
then if a town decides to opt out of the
credit then adding the cost back onto
those bills in those accounts is not
going to be something that comes at no
cost certainly and it does reduce fun it
would reduce funding to the renewable
energy fund which funds a lot of Grant
and rebate programs finally the state
and municipalities many of them
participate in the renewable portfolio
standard by obtaining rebates from the
renewable energy fund by selling Rex for
the removable energy projects that they
own so they are already participating in
the program it's only fair that they pay
into the program don't have to take any
questions
thank you for your testimony Ms mono
I see we have a question from
representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman uh it sounds like
from the information that you just
finished at the end about how
municipalities are currently using the
RPS program that they might actually
lose significant money from this
from the funding being diminished is is
that a correct assumption yes if we're
talking about a hypothetical town that
may have just you know approved a large
solar array at their wastewater
treatment plant for example they're
planning on getting a rebate from the
state the cni solar rebate probably the
funding for that may not be available if
there's reduced funding in the renewable
energy fund and then they're in all
likelihood have calculated into the
economic payback of the project
marketing the renewable energy
certificates and so if there's a
decrease in the obligations or decrease
in demand for Rex the value of racks
will go down and therefore their payback
on their system will likely be much
longer than they had anticipated
which could end up costing the town more
than they would be saving
the cost of compliance is
0.0061 dollars per kilowatt hours or a
fraction of a cent per kilowatt hour
according to the last renewable energy
fund report from the Public Utilities
Commission which came out October 1st
and if you all have not seen it I'm
happy to share that with you but it's on
the commission's webpage
thank you we have any further questions
for Ms minnow
any questions from it within the room
here
yes representative partial you're
recognized for a question
yes I'm not sure if you can answer this
or not but I am uh earlier speaker spoke
of the the economic impact
of our local producers of uh
water and hydro energy in that case
um are you aware of what the economic
impact of our local energy production is
and what a loss of that impact would be
to the rest of the state
I don't have exact numbers
um we before the pandemic had a jobs
report that I'm also happy to share with
you
um the renewable energy and Energy
Efficiency sectors in New Hampshire are
growing work before the pandemic we're
growing rapidly much faster than the
rest of the economy or other job sectors
and they are it is extremely good
employment and any of our energy
spending that we can keep in state
benefits our local economy we're
reinvesting that in local businesses and
um you know I don't have an exact number
on on the effect on the whole economy
but it is significant
you need a follow-up of Representative
no but I would love to see that
information if you could share it at
some point I will be in contact with you
thank you absolutely thank you
thank you next I recognize
representative Kelly Pitts for a
question it's just a quickie the
this the municipally owned renewable
energy projects
will they
um
if they're exempt will they still be
entitled to take money out of the fund
uh according to this Bill yes nothing uh
you know it tells them they don't have
to pay in anymore but they can still get
the rebates so it is a little bit like
representative sansich was saying it
would be a free rider system
follow-up representative Kelly no
no thank you
that
appears to satisfy all the questions
that the committee has so I thank you Ms
minnow for your
testimony today thank you
signed up to speak so
um before closing this public hearing
I will read to you the blue sheet
information
which indicates that there were seven
people in support of this legislation 29
is opposed and one person neutral
some of the notables who responded to
this legislation were
representative Jason Osborne of the
house Republican office the House
Majority office
who signed in in support of the bill
Representative Bob Greene
who signed in and supported the bill
representative John podacek who signed
in to the support of the bill
representative Jeffrey greeson who
signed in in support of the bill
representative Herschel Nunes who signed
in in support of the bill and uh
representative Jonathan Jonathan Smith
who signed in as a supporter of the bill
I don't see any other
elected officials who oh yes there is
one more Richard Littlefield
signed in and then supporting the bill
so
I don't see any other elected officials
who were who signed in and supported the
bill but um
all this information is or will be
available
the members of the committee
after the public hearing so with that we
will close the public hearing at 4 35.
and we will open executive session
and I will call on
representative uh bresney for a motion
on House Bill 169.
I make a motion to retain build house
build 169.
okay representative bresney has moved
that we retain House Bill 169 uh
representative homolog
it's been moved and seconded that we
retain House Bill 169 is there
discussion
seeing none I asked the clerk to call
the roll on the motion of retain for
house bill 169.
six seconds
okay
the motion is to retain bill 169.
representative Thomas yes
representative Harrington
yes
representative Murray yes
representative hovala yes
representative resting yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative cambrose yes
representative yes
representative white yes
representative sausage
yes
representative
Kelly Pitts yes
representative Meen
unmute John
representative Mann
sorry
um what a mess
um I don't know what Bill we're voting
on 169.
the utility polls yes
relaxing him
yes
representative Vinson
representative McWilliams
no
representative here we go again
so Christian creation
thank you yes
representative
yes
representative passion yes
and the chairman representative Rose yes
it's 20 to 1.
the vote of 20 to 1 the motion passes to
retain house bill 169.
Christian rhymes with Grecian
no majority or minority vote
necessary for a retained bill
representative Thomas
questions
right
okay uh I recognize representative
Thomas for a motion
okay on HP 624
um
a motion to um
what representative natter is recognized
I second the motion
it's been moved and seconded that we
fast judgment on House Bill 624 as ought
to pass
is there any discussion
yes Mr chairman I'd like to speak on
this please
representative Harrington yeah like I
said earlier I'm the only person I
believe maybe I'm wrong but as if served
on site evaluation committee meetings uh
hearings quite a few of them and I've
seen that there's very very few of these
things of uh declarative judgment so I
don't think there's a big loss of
Revenue there but there is a loss of
frustration to the people because I mean
I had people call me up on the effect on
the one we've been talking about the
interim win thing after I was no longer
on the committee and all I could do was
refer them back to the general counsel
there is a council for the public
appointed by the Attorney General but
those people come and go too just like
the members of the committee does so
there's really not a good place where
people can go and say now I don't like
the service I'm getting here and I want
to appeal it and they shouldn't have to
pay ten thousand dollars or three
thousand depending on the size of it to
do that 250 is more than enough money so
I hope we'll all get together on this
one and vote Yes
ought to pass
representative
autism
yes I have a question we discussed the
possibility of an amendment that would
make it clear that this was something
that was being made available to the
public not to businesses not to
corporate entities I I propose that we
put this motion off until a time when an
amendment can be brought forward through
OLS
en it's emotions
uh thank you for that comment but that's
uh
I would
suggestion I'm sorry I can't hear you
oh I'm sorry
let's see where was
uh I would respond to you by saying that
this is an early Bill and we've been
instructed by the house leadership to
get the early bills out as quickly as
possible so if this bill needs an
amendment
I suggest that
we suggest that the Senate
amend it when it gets to the Senate
should it get that far I don't need to
to deal with that now that would simply
delay the process and uh
we're working with very tight schedules
to get these early bills assigned to the
second committee so they can be
evaluated there
and what second committee will this go
to
what will it be I think it'll be Finance
I'm not 100 sure
it's a dash FN on the end of the bill
so I don't think it'll go anywhere else
but Finance but I could be wrong about
that
it'll it'll be a second committee but I
don't know which one
this is just one more way that we're not
doing
unto it that's up to that's our
responsibility
okay representative sumsich
uh yes thank you Mr chairman I just want
to Echo what representative oxenham said
I have to say in the beginning I was a
little skeptical about this bill but I
gotta say I've been won over by the
arguments of having more access for the
public uh and I agree with
representative Harrington on this as
well uh this is a real issue that we
should deal with and it seems to me a
minor change in this bill which says
that 250 dollars is the fee for
non-corporate and non-businesses that
small change is easy enough to make it's
not a big deal and I think we would have
unanimous support for that
thank you for that uh comment
Representative Vincent
thank you again Mr chairman I have to
agree I mean you know we the last two
terms that I've served we have people
Representatives that move things out
that have been logical that have been
thought about we've been able to leave
the meeting and go do our own homework
to find out you know this and that you
know I just think that this is being
rushed and not paying attention to
detail doesn't make us as proficient as
we should be
um what else can I say I mean if there's
a fee for ten thousand dollars there's
something else that's hidden it just
seems like if it's too good to be true
it is I like I might be in for in favor
of this
or not but it would I would be able to
go and find out more information which
we've had in the past two terms I
understand the virus I understand the
pandemic I get it but to rush and to be
not as proficient as the professionals
that we are be voted in and hired to do
doesn't do us or anybody any justice and
I understand it I get it we all have
would pull this way in that way
but I just don't think we're doing our
voters uh and the people of New
Hampshire a Justice and I really
appreciate you let me say that Mr
chairman thank you
yes thank you representative
representative Thomas thank you Mr
chairs
this is more of a simple real simpler
bills we've had today and because it is
a second committee middle I'm positive
that we can suggest strongly that any
minor tweet can be done in the second
committee to move it on to the house if
we do otherwise we would have to
actually we would have actually vote to
say no on this bill and then free
execution amendment can come back it
takes up more time and it'd be very
risky and so my recommendation is that
we proceed with the vote that we're in
the voting mode and then we strongly
recommend and provide the simple
amendment that we may want
and then before the past
thank you representative Harrington
yeah in deference to the chair and the
vice chair I understand what they're up
against here for scheduling and so forth
but I will say to representative sawmich
and representative oxenham that we take
this to the Senate I will go with you
and I will talk about the need to change
this because the intent of this bill is
only to protect the little guy it's not
to protect the multi-million dollar
corporate so they don't have to pay ten
thousand dollars they get the money I
will work with you to make sure it's
clear that this is for individuals or or
municipalities or small entities but not
big companies and that's the best I can
do
thank you thank you
thank you Mr chairman
um I'd like clarification on a question
I took notes when chair person Martin
was
um telling explaining to us how this
would affect the situation with uh the
site evaluation committee and she
specifically uh Drew my attention to a
problem with going from the 10 000 that
can that Representative Vincent was
talking about being too good to be true
if you could just cut it to 250 how
great she said that um the specific uses
of that money by Statute had to go into
a fund that allowed operating costs uh
for the SEC and those would be used to
fund public members I'm assuming it's
like for you know travel expenses or
that kind of thing
um and compensation to the Department of
Justice so there were specific statutory
expenses of the SEC that were provided
for only by money that's in that fund
and so even though there are not a lot
of people paying that fund I think it
was that large for a reason
I don't disagree with anyone's argument
about uh having the public have access
and having it be a lower fee for them
but I think if it doesn't have that
specificity in the bill and I understand
representative Harrington saying he'll
go over to Senate and help make sure we
have that what we're doing is we're
taking away monies that will have to be
made up in the general funds because
that's what her testimony told us so
um I I just want to know if you heard
that same thing that I heard that that
by Statute that money is a is in a
dedicated fund which would now basically
be unfunded so
it sounds really good but I'm just
wondering if we're paying enough
attention to what we're doing and other
people will make in that point as well
so there are several other fees in
statute who may have noticed that go to
that same fund so there isn't going to
be much impact uh by decreasing the
funding of declaratory rulings so I
wouldn't worry about that
Next Step would be let's see
representative Kelly bits
oh
um
I had two questions one for the chair I
got a flow chart that said every bill
was due March 11th what is the early
reporting date
could you repeat the question
I gotta
flowchart March 11th what is the early
reporting date for this bill February
18.
report on house Bills going to the
second committees February 18th February
18th
so my question to the chair would be
we're meeting Monday 48 hours in four
hours
OLS could put through an amendment
that would say this and by the end of
our session on Monday we could have the
amendment it would be not out of order
to ask that the person who made the uh
motion withdraw it and the second
withdraw it till Monday afternoon so we
could get that amendment that says you
know for not for cooperation though to
exempt corporations and like they can do
that in five minutes on the computer
I don't know how you get a paper
official Amendment over but I think if
they send it over
by email it's official I don't know
can you tell me
and that's 48 hours
thank you for that idea uh
representative Kelly Fitz but uh I'm a
little bit nervous about putting this
off because
if we try to put it off till next Monday
that's February 1st if we couldn't get
it done on that day then we'd have to
put it off to the following Monday which
would be February 8th and then uh
then if we can't do it if for some
reason we don't get it done that day it
just seems to me it's cutting it too
close so I think we'll do this now we
have a strategy in place to add the
additional language either in the second
committee or in the Senate so I don't
see any reason to hold up the process
now just because of that small change
okay next up would be
because everybody has had a chance to
speak on this already so
since it is five minutes before five I
think we should ask the clerk to call
the vote
on Bill 624 the motion ought to pass
representative
yes
representative Harrington
where is he
representative Harrington don't forget
it has to be on video to vote
yeah I don't know where is these
yeah
that's it if he's out of the road
yourself do a vote let's have a vote
oh it's been called
is he still listed as being on
representative Harrington please turn on
your video
it's some of the top Frozen
you've seen the very top one
with the balloon
here you have to keep the vocal
s going to border
wasn't he required to be in the room
when the motion was red
it's correct
that is parliamentary you have to be in
your seat
if you're excited if you lost power all
right
let's skip representative nada yes
representative Berner yes
representative pomela yes
representative resnated yes
representative bernati yes
representative cambrose yes
representative Jose yes
representative white yes
representative samsich
no
representative Kelly Pitts no
represented me in
unmute John
no
Senator boxing him no
representative Vinson nope
representative McGee
representative McWilliams no
prep assessment
representative kitchen
husband's home now I can have him come
in and apologize to you for this last
name if you want uh no
representative Pimentel
no
representative Paschal now
I guess
and the chairman Rose
I cheer votes yes
his representative Harrington there yet
he wasn't in the room for the motion to
be read
you don't know that
we don't know that anybody's in the room
the Hampshire Supreme Court has answered
that question we are present
can't leave
it doesn't matter either party
Mr chairman it's a tie then it goes to
the floor with no motion or no
recommendation and there's both
before it goes to the floor
representative murder what was the final
vote the final vote is 10 10.
okay so the motion uh
oh
the one time he's
okay
get that phone and stop that thing
excuse me Mr chairman
yes representative Harrington
go ahead representative Harrington he's
new to it again
he's muted
I don't think he really wanted to speak
to us muted remember
no I I think Mr chairman we've had a
vote and it's 10 to 10. uh
seems like we need to uh
keep it at that but we'd like to I think
most of our members would like to see
that Amendment and could support it
I believe so
well we need the minority and a majority
report
so if we did a floor Amendment on the
house floor would uh the members of this
committee support it
yes I think that would be a great idea
yes going before the next session yeah
this will go to the floor with no
recommendation so I need a report from
uh the yes side and the no side
and uh
representative
I just uh texted uh Paul Smith our clerk
I asked if I told him we had a retinas
to vote
we don't know why technical difficulties
or whatever and can we vote again he
said yes if you adopt the motion to
reconsider and the bill hasn't been
transmitted to this office and that's by
two-thirds right
um
all right let me ask I don't think so I
think something I think so I'll ask him
he's he's there
do we have Mike Harrington back
Representative Steve made any
explanation that there's a difficulty I
he might have just not been in the room
in which case the vote is the vote no
um Paul says majority but
Paul said in answer to a question about
technical difficulties we don't know
that there were technical difficulties
I don't know
no no he I asked him if we could
reconsider the vote and vote again
and he said yes
by majority okay that's uh immaterial
because we've just been in communication
with Mr Harrington and he said he left
the room okay so the vote is valid at 10
to 10. we will go to the house floor
with no recommendation
we need a report from each side
supporting your
your position on the bill and uh
representative samsich and I will create
a floor amendment that we will introduce
at the time of the introduction of the
bill so thank you for that Mr chairman
that clarification thank you appreciate
that
thank you thank you very much you guys
101 system going through this process we
can do that
further uh
excuse me with somebody who need a
report
yes it's uh representative do you need a
report from me on this bill or I mean
somebody from your side
well I can do that if if that's what you
want
right there has to be a report in the
house calendar so please write
everything
is a minority Minority Report is
identical to the majority report in this
case
because there is no minority it was a 10
to 10 vote
or you just won things
I think the house clerk is going to
require a remote a vote for each side
a report saying that we we would like to
like the bill with an amendment
okay
representative Thomas
sure
if memory serves and I don't know if the
researcher is on here because what
they're saying this but I think there
was one case last year where there was a
no recommendation and I think they just
came with general report because they're
not it's not a major minor
yeah yes
representative matter
as I recall it's um the ought to pass
motion goes first and then the itl
motion goes second
Bill comes out without recommendation at
a time
check with Paul
correct right here you're right
okay so I'll work that out with
representative samsich and we'll work
with the clerk to get the appropriate
Port into the calendar at the
appropriate time so
I would like to uh thank uh everybody
will officially close the exact session
and I would like to thank everybody for
what has been along and uh uh difficult
day it was a terrific learning
experience for all of us we now know how
this hybrid session is going to work and
it is indeed time consuming so we have a
lot of work to do over the coming days
to make sure that we get all our bill
was done so
I will see you all again on Monday and
we'll do the whole thing all over again
thank you thank you thank you be safe Mr
chair everyone very much everybody have
a good weekend stay safe
bye-bye everyone everybody stay safe